what up it's the it's the midterms we
got everybody chilling up here Luke's
not up here yet uh we got a whole big
crew here man it's getting crazy in
Arizona Carrie late came out to give a
press conference she is upset but uh
very professional in her addressing of
these journalists talking about the
problems that are happening in Maricopa
County their uh Trump said stay in line
blank Masters everyone's saying stay in
line make sure they count your vote how
is it that we had all of these
Republicans saying there they're going
to be problems people were getting
banned for saying they're going to be
problems now there are problems it's
like people predicted this was going to
happen so I got no idea what's going to
happen tonight we have the uh the needle
we have over at the New York Times set
this one out can we pull this one up
the the New York Times needle I love
this image because I remember oh so
fondly When Donald Trump in 2016 was on
the verge of victory
when he was doubted and the estimates
were like nine greater than 99 chance he
was going to lose and then slowly over
the night it started to move and then it
got into like 50 50 and all the Liberals
in the RT office are starting to sweat
and then when it got to like guaranteed
for Trump everyone's crying and
Cassandra Fairbanks is like laughing her
ass off so I like the needle uh let's
let's see after the polls close this
will go live so in a couple hours we'll
we'll start seeing this or maybe not I
don't know maybe we'll be live for some
time just talking about whatever so we
got a bunch of really great people who
are gonna be hanging out today some
people are going to come in and out and
we're starting the show early because
we're going to be tracking Twitter we're
gonna be tracking various forecasting uh
forecasts and models and the news as it
comes in
so uh super excited for this and I can
definitely smell that pumpkin muffin
that Mary is eating because it smells
really really good is that what it is a
pumpkin muffin yeah it smells amazing
actually yeah am I the only one that
can't smell it you're like over there
yeah and there's a fan blowing it away
okay all right everybody so head over to
timcast.com become a member support our
work your membership fuels us it fuels
the Enterprise and makes all this
possible we've got great journalists uh
writing about everything going on right
now they're all on high alert getting
the job done Chris Carr of course
writing about the AZ gubernatorial
candidate Carrie Lake addressing the
voting machine problems with your
supports over at timcast we're expanding
the operation I also want to say a major
thank you to everybody who checked out
the song genocide losing my mind listen
to it right now on YouTube if you
haven't just pull it up and listen as
you're listening to the show we are
currently number 29 trending on YouTube
music and uh wow man seriously thank you
so much that's really really cool we're
uh just over 700k views in real time
analytics and I think we're going to hit
billboard very very hard because we've
got confirmation that this time they're
out track they're tracking the YouTube
and I want to make sure that all of
these uh woke lunatics and media who lie
all the time I want to make sure it's
undeniable and let me let me tell you
Elon Musk can't lie about Twitter's
numbers that would be fraud when he
comes out and says this is how many
daily act month daily active users we've
gained that is a sales statement to
advertisers so he can't just fake it
Twitter was accused of running Bots for
this reason and that they you know we
assume they lied about it Elon Musk is
saying this is what we're saying in all
of these new news outlets are lying
saying it's F it's failing it's falling
apart people are quitting so we want to
make sure that it is undeniable but uh
more importantly look if you like the
song then put in your playlist listen to
it and buy it on iTunes Amazon or
wherever we were number one on iTunes
for a little while we fell down but I
think we're still number one on Amazon
and uh if we keep having this tremendous
success constantly hitting trending
we're going to keep making more I think
the response we got in this song because
it's overtly political was way better
and I think it's fairly obvious I mean
we're literally making fun of the
establishment we have this can we pull
this up like we literally have Taylor
Lorenz you know singing for us
she's basically singing that she's a
liar and so I was really excited for
that one and we have a bunch of them
singing about how they're Liars so
seriously thank you all so much for your
support uh just let's let's if you want
to support us just listen to it go to
losing my mind.com play it wherever you
want to play it and uh we're killing it
on YouTube so uh thanks for that we're
trending number 29 right above Selena
Gomez with her new song that came out
five days ago I don't even know how that
makes sense like how does that work
she's got five million views five days
ago with her verified Channel we don't
we're above her that's really cool of
course as you know Tom McDonald is way
above us uh with his song fighter which
is really amazing you guys if you
haven't checked out Tom McDonald fighter
I actually think it's his best song I
love it I love the the organ I think
it's it's more melodic I just I think
it's an absolutely fantastic song plus
the message so uh thanks so much so uh
who we got hanging out today we got uh
we got Drew Hernandez chilling here
yeah man dude uh I just I feel pretty
good I feel pretty good CNN is telling
me it's all gonna be okay all over
social media that we can trust them
they're literally saying on live TV
right now stay off of social media
trust us it's all gonna be okay the
simulation is actually breaking I mean
even MSNBC Libby what were they saying
on MSNBC earlier they're coming out and
saying we can't say that whatever
happens tonight is a fair and Equitable
election no way they said that they have
someone on MSNBC coming out who said now
denying this election let's let's put
let's we'll start with that one let me
send you the clip yes uh retweet it and
I'll I'll grab it from your Twitter okay
it's on there right now all right
Perfect all right so we got to Libby of
course hanging out hey guys glad to be
back glad to be back after last night uh
I just I just saw this on Twitter I
wanted to bring this up
um did you see this new thing you know
how they're doing the Eight dollar
verification the new Eight dollar
verification so they're doing a new
thing now where they're saying
um
who's a lot of folks have asked about
how you'll be able to distinguish
between Twitter blue subscribers with
blue check marks and accounts that are
verified as official which is why we're
introducing the official label to select
accounts when we launch
did you see that well they're saying
that uh
people who are already verified won't
have to pay for it right but they're
also saying that not all previously
verified accounts will get the official
label and the label is available not
available for purchase accounts that
will see receive it include government
accounts commercial companies business
partners major media Outlets Publishers
and some public figures who are these
select major media Outlets let's talk
about it we also got uh Lisa's back hi
guys and uh if you're if you can see
Ian's right behind her give us a wave in
yeah
hi
Ian is here thanks for letting me borrow
the microphone but so we've got we
brought on a whole bunch of people
specifically so that we can rotate
people in and out Mary Morgan of course
is eating a pumpkin muffin which I
shouted out yeah
I'm eating a pumpkin
following the mid
at all so I'm just happy to be here all
right and then of course we have Serge
pressing all the buttons hey I'm over
here guys and then actually at some
point we'll probably have Kellen
pressing all the buttons he's chilling
as well so uh let's let's let's do this
man we're gonna have like 800 000
segments by tomorrow oh Luke just showed
up Luke is in the studio look you got no
seat you are late
do you want to sit on the floor next to
me
I can feed you my scraps are you getting
pumpkin muffin on the floor I'll get it
do that but no Mary please there he is
religious man just I don't hang out and
then I just want to see the shirt what's
the shirt say today
Joe and the hoe gotta go love it give
you one guess who the hoe is
oh just to be family friendly here but
you know can we I don't even know if
people can hear what you're saying yeah
this is kind of family friendly here you
know
all right let's we got we got to pull up
this uh the story let's go for it here
there's no grab a chair grab that big
chair right there there's one big one
right next to Ian
get over here
oh there's two chairs there's a there's
a chair over here too if you need it
and then uh whenever someone feels like
coming over you know what we're planning
on doing but because we're building a
new studio is we have the wide shot
camera and we are going to put
microphones over there so that we could
have the papasan chairs but we never did
because we thought the new studio would
be done by now let's pull this video
here's the first segment that is in in
on a long line of segments I'm going to
play this because Drew just brought this
up to my bus to my attention let's hear
this guy has to say this is the greatest
indicator that we have to always talk
about voter suppression one key thing
it's almost five o'clock right in the
state of Georgia thanks to Brian Kemp
and and rafisberger they changed the
state law so that you cannot get a
provisional ballot in Georgia before
five before five o'clock so if you
waited in line for two and a half hours
got there and they said oh there's some
sort of mistake you can't get a
provisional ballot here the level of
voter suppression is beyond anything
that we saw in 2018 so I think it's
completely up in the air there has been
youth turnout at levels we haven't
expected Democrats feel confident
Republicans I've spoken to feel
confident but we can't say that whatever
happens tonight is a fair and Equitable
election because there have been too
many laws passed by election demiers
stimulation shifts this is the greatest
there it is there it is dude they have
no MSNBC Live I'm sorry this is the
safest and most secure no unit I think I
think Democrats are going to do better
than people realize and all of the
Conservative Republican independent
personalities that are saying like oh
this is BS
tomorrow when the Democrats do better
they're going to bet hey last night you
said it was it was everything was all
good right right and then the right's
gonna be like hey you said it wasn't
free and fair right
it's bipolar man the narratives are
bipolar and I think it's going to be
interesting to see what happens all I
know is Maricopa County dude is like a
Banana Republic it's it's embarrassing
what's taking place I mean even tonight
taking a look at what's happening there
so many people having issues with voting
and they're telling people to go to
another location because these machines
aren't working conveniently and it's
like here we are in 2022 I'll say this
is can I even say this on YouTube can I
say this anymore is like
if if you're still watching what's
happening right now okay in this
election and you're still convinced that
somehow this is all safe and secure
after what's taking place in Maricopa
specifically you're just you're out of
your mind
to put it simply there's a problem with
broken machines not tabulating votes
that is a fact so the problem is Katie
Hobbs didn't recuse herself and she's
overseeing her own elections well that's
another problem didn't Brian Kemp do
that yeah still it's a prophecy yeah
it's a prophecy it is a prophecy of what
will happen to Arizona if that psycho
racist gets in I mean look everything
before it was it was Brian Kemp was
Secretary of State at the time when he
ran 2018 and so he was overseeing the
election he was in as well so I guess
the difference is when raffensberger was
in in 2020
everybody got mad at him over how the
election was handled and it was Trump
that lost and so they were met at the
Republican over it I yeah I think
probably Kemp and uh Katie Hopps
probably shouldn't oversee their own
elections but probably well I mean I I
didn't hear a lot of people complaining
on the right about Brian Kemp overseeing
his election in Georgia when Stacey uh
Abrams I still think that's problematic
no I agree yeah I agree uh but we'll see
man all that I can say is
Carrie light comes out a long time ago
she was talking I think she was talking
with Crowder that there were problems
with their with their elections and they
gave Crowder a strike over this
and now sure enough there are problems
they're literally happening right now
should what do you think would happen if
I started saying there were there were
no problems
YouTube would be like oh you're giving
out election misinformation no no we
have to tell people legitimately and
accurately what's going on in Maricopa
County and what they gave Crowder a
strike for we are now obligated to
report lest we be engaged in you know
disinformation or whatever nonsense it's
ridiculous that's the state that's the
machine dude that's the machine anytime
The Narrative shifts you either have to
be saying the right thing on the right
side on the right time and the moment
that you're not that's when you get shut
down you get canceled you get censored
you get de-platform and the whole thing
and and here's the thing too is I think
this is a good thing I think this is a
very good thing what's taking place in
Maricopa across the United States
because people that might be kind of
like sitting on the fence like I don't
know that sounds a little like
conspiratorial are our elections you
know messed up is there really a lot of
bad nefarious things going on I I don't
know there might be people sitting back
saying I don't know if I can agree with
that yet
I'm glad that this is happening because
people like that are watching this and
they're having their own experiences at
the polling places and waking up to that
there's something that needs to be fixed
in our election process and Democrats
can't sit there and say oh this is safe
and secure and we want democracy because
if they really cared they would do
something about it they're the ones
saying it's not it's Amazon that's what
I'm saying it's bipolar
it's bipolar dude I
I says anything that they believe in
they just say what they think is going
to keep them and their cronies in power
power and it's just so transparent it
becomes increasingly more and more
transparent because you had Hillary
Clinton talking about this same thing in
2016 you had her just recently talking
about how you know
the Republicans are going to be election
deniers all over again they've been
consistently laying the groundwork for a
couple of for like a week or something
now that we're just not going to get the
results in a timely fashion
and these notices yeah like just so you
know it might take a couple of days
before poll results come out and that's
and that's to be that's just not how it
used to be like I remember voting you
know way back in ye olden days and I
would go in I would vote there'd be no
line it'd be no big deal you'd vote and
then later that night you'd know what
the results are and you'd be like dude
to do whatever Golden Days the olden
days of the 1990s is a time traveler yes
that is who wants to read this one who
wants to read it up on the screen
somebody read it
by 54 to 46 Rubio won by 53-46. Dade
County that is Miami yeah two
Republicans have just won the mail-in
vote this is this is oh that means the
mail-in vote Dade Melon vote yes yes
okay so what's what's what's worse than
apocalyptic for Democrats
um
uh apocalyptics like the end of the
world is there a word that signifies
like the end of all the heat death of
the universe there we go this is a
Democrat heat death of the universe this
is mail-in voting favors Democrats
extremely heavily for two Republicans to
have won in a blue safe Blue urban
center
in the mail-in vote by 54 and 53 that is
that is beyond the apocalypse that is
not just the world ending for Democrats
it is the absolute heat death of the
universe there is nothing left it's over
it's got to be Hispanics dude yeah I
think yeah they don't like communism
I would be willing to bet right now that
that is Hispanics putting both of those
two over the edge for the W because
these people are waking up to these damn
Democrats thinking they can control them
and that is going to become problematic
for these it's it's just so obvious the
people who have real experience with
socialism
saw it in the eyes of the Democrats who
were running and just said no thank you
and the media desperately tries to lie
to them but they're like dude you can't
lie to us our family experienced this
We're Not Gonna vote for it well and
then you had then you had like the
Christ campaign basically calling Cubans
racist for not for being like opposed to
Communism and socialism that was really
eye-opening I think for a lot of people
as well
they're all nuts I I just I I want
people to really understand how insane
this is
like the the mail-in vote it's like
sometimes it's like two two to one
Democrat or more like 70 yep but now
we're seeing the status won the mail-in
vote holy they were saying they were
expecting the Latinos to come in at over
50 for DeSantis I mean that's that's
what that would describe he's an
insanely popular Governor I mean he's
just because he's doing a great job he's
doing like you could see what a great
job he was doing when nobody would talk
about how he was handling the hurricane
and it's like oh I guess he's doing a
great job because literally no one will
talk about this you know several facts
check this out we got the uh fresh take
Florida data current turnout is 3.5
million Republicans 2.5 million
Democrats the GOP lead is nearly 1
million votes was that 3.5 you said I
can't see it 3.5 wow so this is uh uh on
top it's it's everything the GOP lead
945 000. I want to jump down to uh the
county and pull up uh Miami-Dade
Miami-Dade right now
the lead for the GOP is 6 000 votes just
about 6 400 or so votes so this is all
turned out including uh day of so that's
interesting interesting we'll see man uh
you know look I'm wondering where
they're getting the numbers from because
right here it says mail-in ballots GOP
is down
so so I I guess
what is this political polls I mean
they're a big account non-partisan group
I checked them a lot 233. here it says
that Miami-Dade it's uh Democrats had
the mail-in vote
unless they mean Republican votes not
including independent in which case it
would be that number does make sense
actually if Independents were voting
Republican I guess I don't know I guess
we'll dependents are the ones that end
up changing things right and and they're
heavily favoring Republicans right now
yeah I guess polling was saying that
leading up to this right they're not
saying Republican they're saying
DeSantis that means with the independent
and GOP vote DeSantis took it well and
also I mean I bet a lot of Democrats
voted for DeSantis yep oh yeah yeah you
know why not so like I would well there
was that Democrat who endorsed them yeah
you saw that yeah that's right oh man
it's gonna be fun but Rubio's up over
Val deming's by by like 20 000 votes too
down down there so I mean how about that
everybody's coming in hey Drew have you
seen one of these before that was uh uh
given to us by Lord miles Rutledge oh
passport yep yep fake illegal immigrants
use those he said he he left that one
there because when you got on the board
you find them scattered all over
un packets showing them how to get
across the globe wow telling them and
instructing them what to say in English
amazing to the border patrol so they
know where to go I just pulled up
Twitter and that was the thing it was
like DeSantis one by 53 I'm like I don't
even know well here's the thing it's
because they don't have anything of
substance to run on especially in
Florida in these areas if you're running
on child grooming child mutilation if
you're running on oh everyone's a racist
and a white supremacist even if you're
Hispanic and we disagree with you they
have a losing strategy with all these
things that they say they're running on
and they can't even go to the economy
they can't even you cannot go to people
and say that we are going to fix the
economy that we destroyed they expect
people to be dumb enough to just see
that and vote for them anyways and maybe
some people are I don't know they are
but people are waking up Tim that's a
good sign right they people a lot of
people don't know don't pay attention
but you cannot lie your way out of five
dollar a gallon gas exactly people and
the gas yeah no problem they were doing
exit polls earlier today though and it
was like they were saying that a really
good amount like it was like 22 or 23 or
32 something like that didn't think that
gas had been a problem or impacted them
in a negative way hey maybe it really is
maybe they don't drive they were I got
to look up these days
it may actually look for people and it
was like CBS and like CNN polls like
exit polls but so look if you're if
Republicans aren't talking they're in
Miami and you're uh an urban liberal
you're probably not driving all that
much so gas prices are probably not the
biggest issue to you in which case these
people in Miami are looking at communism
or at the very least they're seeing
signs of what they fled from Venezuela
and Cuba how much do you think the
gender ideology stuff being pushed on
kids is influencing photos because it
kind of it pushes the Democrats into a
corner where you have to confirm or deny
whether you're complicit in this yeah
and I think that that's been happening
not just in Florida but that's been
happening in Michigan it's been
happening in Arizona and we there was
recently a poll I think it was Trafalgar
put out a poll and they were saying that
there's a lot of people who would not
vote for a candidate that supported you
know child sex changes
um and I don't think that's surprising I
also though we saw the uh we saw the
Democrats leading up to all of this
pushing sort of insane social issues
like they put abortion at the top of
their platform and we know that they are
pro-abortion mainstream it's not really
yeah a lot of people just don't even
want to talk about it or think about it
and they put it up there up top
is crazy yeah I thought that was nuts to
put that up top and they also yeah
they're they're they talk about how all
of these you know like um
anti-lgbt laws that are going into
effect and if you look at the laws
that's not what they are and a lot of
people know that a lot of people are
just way past all of this rhetoric they
can see through it whatever they can't
keep lying what the law those laws that
are being framed as anti-lgbts they are
primarily primarily parental because
some of some of them are concerning like
conversion therapies or whatever but
here's the deal with conversion therapy
the way conversion therapy is defined is
uh so you can't try Ai and forcibly
convert someone who is gay but that
means you also can't try to forcibly
convert someone who is trans meaning you
cannot encourage someone to be
comfortable in their natal body that's
considered conversion therapy telling
someone who says that they're trans that
they're maybe fine without a bunch of
surgeries and drugs is considered
conversion therapy so it's kind of a
bastardization of the concept itself so
these laws are basically like if you're
a parent you have a right to know what's
going on with your kid at school that's
it and uh they can't have sex ad without
parental permission yes and so what the
Democrats did is they came out and
started saying gay over and over and
over again which is like really weird
it's don't say gay they're trying to
tell you you can't say the word gay or
right I want to I want to pull up the
sweet guys we need this everyone
everyone we're going to go through these
exercises
the New York Times says elections and
anxiety often go hand in hand here are
some evidence-based strategies that can
help you cope
with what
try five finger breathing trace the
outside of your hand with your pointer
finger when you trace up breathe in and
when you trace down breathe out
breathing like that just makes you angry
like you're nervous like somebody's like
here's your breath I'm like here's we're
gonna see it's gonna be that woman
screaming no again but she's gonna drop
her knees and go no
they're gonna change the the Tommy fists
to the the five finger pointing here we
go cool down listen no no guys guys guys
plunge your face into a bowl with ice
water for 15 to 30 seconds yo what is
that sounds fun dude I'm trolls this is
New York Times New York Times that's
very look at this move wait it gets
better guys move even a walk around the
block can offer some relief a relief for
an Aussie uneasy mind here you go
breathe like a baby focus on expanding
your belly as you breathe which can send
more oxygen to the brain limit your
scrolling consider plotting out specific
times when you will look for election
updates I gotta say it I gotta say it
Elon Musk starts Banning a bunch of
these whiny lunatics user growth is at
all-time highs and they're they're
having temper tantrums I am so happy to
see Elon grounding the naughty children
because they're children that's what
they are when when I when I'm watching
election results I'm not crying I'm
sitting here and I'm like well this will
be interesting we'll see what happens
when when Joe Biden won I had a video
I'm like there it is they've announced
the winner it's Joe Biden and the left
made a Supercut of that as if I was
crying about it and I'm like I just
literally said he won I'm not mad like
right what are you talking like you guys
are you these people
have to put their face in a bowl of ice
water right now because of the results
aren't even in and the New York Times is
telling everyone please keep calm calm
down yo in Portland let's jump to this
one in Portland they're getting ready
where's this where's the silly tweet
they're boarding up Windows look at this
look at this look at this video
here we go back to the office
I noticed several businesses
we're boarding up their Windows now why
would they be doing that
they're expecting a red wave that's why
because the only people that complain
are look at the banks Wells Fargo
they're boarding up their windows
that Rite Aid down there not a bad idea
closed closed Payless closed
wow
that's their new normal dude down here I
gotta retweet this one
pretty soon I bet you Chase Bank over
there is gonna board up their Windows
because you know how some of these
people in Portland get that's right
that's right the New York Times wants to
make sure that you try five finger
breathing dude when these this is the
problem with the internet you have the
with Twitter particularly you have these
journalists who are just like I'm being
harassed and it's like someone who says
you're dumb and they're just like they
they someone calls them dumb so they
quote tweet it and they go like we're in
hell and I'm like dude someone insulted
you have you never been in a city before
I find that crazy too like or all the
people who are like oh I get horrible
things in my DMs it's like okay I know
everybody else who doesn't you can turn
off your DMs welcome to the internet
solves the problem in a crazy so funny
when people say they get death threats
like that doesn't mean they're credible
or that anyone is being right or like
the ones that are like you know when
people tell you to kill yourself it's
like oh okay I'm getting death that's
really convincing and the problem is I'm
gonna run and do that they keep
pandering to this so in the past the
advertisers would be like hey people are
crying to us and they're complaining and
they'd be like don't worry we'll take
care of it now elon's like don't care
band shut up because they're the ones
who believe that Twitter is a privilege
and not a right like they're they think
that free expression is a privilege and
if you break their rules you should get
kicked off no now it's now it's not
being enforced without a double standard
but now it's a right now the same people
that were like my private company are
like Elon Musk is a tyrant yeah so
here's so here's what happens you saw
everybody changing their names Elon Musk
you guys saw that all these actors they
did that because someone made the point
that once anyone can be verified
impersonation will be a problem I'll
prove it by changing my name to Elon
Musk they instantly get banned and then
they're like but I was doing parody it's
like wait hold on your point was
impersonation is dangerous and that we
can't tolerate it Twitter has never
tolerated impersonations they banned you
now you're complaining you should be
allowed to do it these people are not
serious they are not serious serious
people they're not arguing any real
positions so I don't care to listen to
what they have to say now they're like
this is such a loss for free speech like
they were the champions of free speech
no they're just Kathy Griffin hopped
onto her Dead Mother's account no that's
why I did that she hopped onto her Dead
Mother's account to impersonate Elon
Musk on that account again and get into
it back and forth with him on Twitter
again she's like my mom won't mind me
doing this right what's her mom would
like it I forget what it was it was like
her mother's name was like Maggie
Griffin Maggie Griffin I don't know if
that one has also been suspended since
then yeah maybe Maggie Griffin Kathy is
is trending
and she's like my mother would have been
okay with this you don't know like the
severed head wasn't ghoulish enough yeah
she always takes things too far huh
she's just gross she's ugly to look at
too
from the New York Post is that it
Catherine given uses the late Mom's
account to evade Twitter ban like what a
ghoul yeah
yeah I like a steaming cup of my own
urine in the morning
so what pissed me about the story is
that Elon was giving him special
treatment again
the rules are you can impersonate if
you're verified period And so Elon said
no no fine fine I'll let you do it as
long as you put parity in your name and
they went no and it's okay with your
band like don't give them a special they
changed their name to Elon Musk ban it's
always been the rule sorry goodbye I
think there should be some kind of path
to Redemption but as I stated yesterday
I am not going to advocate for any of
these people to get their accounts back
because they oppose Free Speech well
that's not free speech that's like
identity theft right but anyone's
identifying the real if you steal
someone's identity in the real world
it has nothing to do with free speech if
someone's house is on fire that's what
they've been claiming if someone's house
they've been crying saying I have free
speech saying elon's not for free speech
if someone's house is on fire and I
don't like them I will I will call 9-1-1
and be like let's help them put this
fire even though I don't like them if
someone is an arsonist and they're
setting fires and then they get burned
by it I'm not gonna call 9-1-1 because
they deserve help I'm gonna call it
because the fire is a problem and needs
to be stopped my point is I don't want
anybody get hurt by fire I don't anyone
get get banned when they're engaging in
free speech but I'm not going to to help
an arsonist this is not going to happen
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna advocate for
these people and you know it's just not
going to happen well these these Skittle
people are just a bunch of [ __ ] dude
I mean at the end of the day yeah they
just the rainbow Mafia you know these
are the same people that are running
around threatening everyone threatening
to bash your face in but they can't
handle a word this is why they want to
change words because if you say words
that are too offensive they can't handle
it in reality this is who these people
are they're pathetic they're pathetic
and they don't represent America because
if you did you would be able to stand on
your own two feet and be offended in the
face of anything that opposes you but
they can't the children their children
this is what Kathy hokel has been doing
in New York right this is why I think
that yeah this is what she's been doing
she has changed uh she spent all of this
energy and money to change
um the word inmate to incarcerated
person in all legislation as if this
means anything at all apparently the
word inmate was offensive but like if
you change a word that you think is
offensive to a different word shortly
thereafter that word becomes offensive
as well I know prisoner was offended no
inmate is offensive
they've changed all the gender language
in in uh in the state legislation about
this incarcerated person
we are thankful that when I when my son
was in like a kindergarten they had this
rule that you couldn't say stupid
because it would make people feel bad so
the kids
so the kids started calling each other
yeah it totally so the kids started
calling each other silly and then silly
became a bad word this is stupid yes
[Applause]
anti-bullying was always yeah
anti-bullying is a mistake and like as
someone who was mercilessly bullied like
you grow up and it's fine and you're
resilient like suck it yeah
life is hard
get used to it early yeah you're gonna
get pissed off people are not gonna like
you
that's what's crazy is these people want
to be put on the Forefront like beyond
the news they want to be like blowing up
on Tick Tock and social media but then
they get criticized and they run away
and claim it's hate speech and put their
talent between their legs because like I
said well you know what then they do
then they breathe like babies right what
was the five finger breathing thing they
were saying and tomorrow all of these
people will have to cope and they will
too
that's why there's that like that
demonics
family friendly drew the screaming is
like the craziest part like the thing at
Penn State yeah like are you possessed
is there something literally wrong with
you like they know who's remarkably
resilient to this stuff is Dylan
Mulvaney
why are you so good at handling the
online bullying well they need is a
performer Mulvaney is a bully intending
to insult trans people you will never
convince me otherwise I don't know about
it you think it's a I I think I think
people on the right are so eager to look
at trans people as Dylan Mulvaney that
they accept what is clearly a troll
designed to insult when a dude put on
when they used to put on blackface they
didn't act like black people they acted
like insane caricatures to mock them the
way they painted their faces Dylan
Mulvaney and what was for the longest
time making social media content was I
believe a gay man yes and now all of a
sudden all of these videos are just the
most insane mockeries of women and trans
people it's been a great career and
mulvania is getting praise and
protection from it while mocking women
and trans people it's worse than that
it's worse than that he's not he's not
impersonating a woman
it's a little he's impersonating a
little girl right
listen he's not he's not impersonating a
female adult even more mentally ill and
deranged
this is the issue you fell for it
you guys believe this it's a little girl
taking hormones at least has one breast
bigger than enough
all right all right what did I fall for
a guy who wore hiking heels and you're
like that's a legitimate human that's a
that's a real that's a real thing no
he's a weirdo that thinks that that's
how women actually he said he's
performing he said he's doing a bit he
said it he said he's not in the white
house he said people take it as legit
right he's doing a bit and Performing
and he wants to be a performer and this
is his performance he doesn't want to be
a performer he is a performer this is a
career move prior to doing this he was
doing tick tocks where he was
interviewing animals as a gay man he
went on The Price is Right and and won a
massive pool table and had a great time
it was actually kind of a good segment
on that show but this this move to be
trans to be like a little trans girl or
whatever brilliant career movement
opportunistic gay man it's a performance
he's an actor he's an actor you look at
I will I will cite as I did before Blair
white and uh uh Contra points these are
two trans people one person's uh left
left sphere of influence right sphere of
influence they don't wear hiking heels
they don't flail about and fall down
when dragonflies come by they don't talk
about Barbie pouches they don't say it's
time to normalize the Bulge that is not
what a real trans person is going around
doing the argument so so what happens is
so what you're doing too is you're doing
what like the anti-trans activists the
like gender critical people would call
giving into the idea of true trans what
I'm saying is we had Blair white on here
talking about
you know actually when we've had Blair
on several times we've not really talked
about transitions because I don't know
just we talk about politics well Blair's
very smart person and Blair was talking
about like she she said that Dylan is
legit legit like people actually think
you know I I I I I think it's it's
you're being trolled but I think
conservatives want this to be the
caricature of trans people yeah they
want it to be that way well it's like
that like you look at Blair and you're
like why is it Blair acting like that
because that's not because I think that
I think there's still like a a spectrum
of mentally ill trans people more normal
trans people like this especially right
but what you're saying Arrested
Development but but he is still going
through like that but what you're saying
isn't all the things some people are
mentally ill some people are not
mentally ill so therefore you might have
someone like Blair who's a very smart
individual uh and very you know you know
reasonable and then Dylan Mulvaney is
trans and also happens to have other
mental illnesses including arrested yeah
Arrested Development I stuck in that
like so do you think Dylan is grifting
even the left
and you think that he got into the White
House because he's playing and drifting
his base come on dude normally I'm just
asking him yes yes can we say this and
still doing it at the same time like it
he's a gay man that probably saw an
opportunity by being trans he's
exploiting it but he's still going
through all the things because that's
what's going to make him money so it's
like a double it's a double right he's
screwing women screwing the trans people
screwing the trans let's just say trans
kids right so he's screwing all of them
at the same time because he's pulling a
grift on all of him so he doesn't really
care about trans people he just wants to
be famous did we take Rachel Dole Is All
seriously like the way I see Dylan
Mulvaney would be if someone put on
blackface and started running around
demanding watermelon and fried chicken
it's like that is insanely wrong
offensive and stereotypical that's not
reality
Dylan Mulvaney is doing all the things
all those things 10 times hiking heels
but
normalize the boat those are performed
performances
there is an amount of
and fakery and non-reality to all
transgenderism versions of it all it is
artificial
no the hormone therapy the surgery is
this is why we appear in stuff it's all
artificial and cosmetic it there's a
performance people are trying to present
a certain way
so like this is what this is what Blair
white was talking about and and it's
probably it's it's Blair's a better
person to talk about it than I would be
she mentioned the difference between
gender dysphoric individuals and
fetishist individuals correct and
they're not the same right can they
overlap though
well anybody can overlap that's that's
not an argument you can you can be uh
I'm just saying you can be a communist
and trans person you can be a trump
supporting trans person right there's
overlap and all sorts of ideologies the
point I'm making without getting into
the greater all of the trans stuff is
that Dylan Mulvaney I just look at that
and I'm like the first thing anyone
should think when they see Dylan
Mulvaney saying normalize the Bulge is
like this is a gag this is not real this
is not this isn't this first of all
we've not seen something like this it's
over the top tenfold and going into the
woods wearing like women's biking
outfits and high heels is not a real
thing I don't think any of trans is a
real thing but there is but
transvestite's a real person who exists
okay I'm not that's like you're denying
our existence I'm not denying that
people who identify as trans are real
I'm saying that the identity is
artificial what I'm saying is there's
not a woman that frolics around in the
forest in Heights yeah he does it like
way over the top and he's kind of guys
it's a gag but there is transvestite
fetishism right or whatever you say okay
yeah right and what that is is that they
get off like having other people totally
a woman dresses a little girl dresses
all those things and I think yes and I
think it's a totally conversation that
he's grifting off of it getting off on
off of it like if you watch it because
I've gone down like that Tick Tock like
feed look endlessly that's that's that's
that's there's nothing indicating that
he's having like that this is getting
him off like what he talks about he
talks about like saying oh my gosh I'm
I'm dreaming about the way the the this
guy gonna kiss me and he's seeing me as
a girl and like he talks about the stuff
like you can clearly tell he's getting
off on it in some way I don't We're not
gonna solve this now and we should
probably get back to election stuff my
point was just sorry for bringing him up
my point was just simply that when a
person does as many cartoonish things
that insult trans people and then
everyone on the right is like haha see
that's what trans people are I'm like
dude come on
like I think it's an extreme expression
of what all of that is I don't like I I
guess but he says he's performing
and he he was doing tons of videos as a
man and then all of a sudden starts
doing these gag videos like I will I
would say wearing high heels in the
woods is a gag it was a it was a joke
saying normalize the Bulge and then
trying later to walk it back after trans
people started calling him out then he
was like oh no I was just he put about
put out a video saying like I was just
self-conscious and didn't really mean it
and it's like but I don't think I don't
I don't think he's that uh out of the
normal though I don't think he's over
the top it completely is over the top
now another person saying normalized
like when you go to these protests Tim
we were we were in Nashville at Matt
Walsh's thing and it's all those kinds
of people running around screaming
foaming at the mouth like their eyes
rolling back so okay so all dressed the
same way yes yes totally mentally ill
you cannot dress this full every single
person that's not what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying is that there still is
people in the left that are over the top
like okay on the ground when you go see
them I know I know for sure
issue is the the handful of grifting uh
uh fake ideological individuals are not
representative of the General Public
like simply put when you go to an antifa
crowd you are looking at a group of
antifa mentally ill people that's what
they are all of them
that you you don't go around smashing
windows and burning buildings down
unless you have some serious mental
problem so like I'm not going to look at
antibond be like look at all these white
people yeah antifa tends to be
overwhelmingly white if I'm not going to
go there and be like well white people
are clearly mentally ill because antifa
is it's like no those are the unwell
people my point is that I don't want I I
guess we can we can talk about a bit
later otherwise we're going to go in
circles again
we'll start talking about the election
again all the things that go with that
I'm seeing reports that uh Marjorie
Taylor green won
really I mean I wouldn't be surprised if
they called that one early right yeah I
feel like they call Rand Paul too right
MTG is based I like MTG
I was skeptical of her at first and then
I she's amazed her several times and I
she's pretty I really think she's I
think they're called very down to earth
great I like her a lot she's a sweetie
yeah I don't know though
New York Times New York Times oh dude I
mean with three percent reporting she's
at 71 yeah so okay there you go that
doesn't really there's still no I know
it's only three percent but so you said
the New York Times is reporting yeah I
always get decision desk too people get
all hype when it's like waiters no no
they didn't call it yet they didn't
decision desk did decision desk calls it
for margin I saw this here well I got
the New York Times right here and uh it
does not have a check mark or anything
decision desk projects Marjorie teller
green wins wow all right let's pull up
decision desk
yeah they just said it at seven o'clock
it's on Twitter all right here we go
it's on Twitter Pennsylvania is looking
pretty right when did when did when did
they do you think it's um so you mean
like a clock so an hour ago they called
yeah yeah just about what is this
Transylvania looking pretty red wow yeah
but the urban centers yeah we'll see
what happens
ridiculous like how do you vote for a
guy like that
so oh so so hold on check it out check
it out decision desk has projected uh
Tim Scott is one wow GOP hold I mean
that that was was probably obvious uh
Rand Paul has won oh this is amazing
look at this Marjorie Taylor green has
won yeah uh in Vermont Peter Welch has
won this is uh he was was he Senate yep
U.S Senate yep so uh that's what we got
so far so I don't I don't know if this
was surprising anybody that Tim Scott
ran Paul Margaret Taylor green we're
gonna win but there you go everybody
they won you know what I like that
Marjorie teller green one because she's
going to get some committees back you
know she's going to get a little more
power she stuck it out this whole time
they really tried to trash her they
tried to destroy her life by swatting
a career you know she wants committees
back she wants them yeah well she ought
to get it like that plus we get the
control sure but it's less work she can
do she wants to do work I don't want to
like just be a media but that's not what
I mean to like get her hands dirty
there's not a lot you can get done as
like well I guess we wouldn't be in the
minority anymore but as a minority
member on a member on a committee anyway
so if we're in the majority fine she
wants to see that way she wants to do
investigations I think yeah yeah then
that's fine but like as a as a member of
the minority on a committee and the
Committees that they were giving her
anyway it's not but now she's going to
get to pick like yeah carthy's going to
let her be I think he's going to let her
pick he said it
did they call North Carolina already wow
Ted Bud's way down
33 in we've got Sherry Beasley at 58 Ted
Bud 39 they haven't called it though
New Hampshire Maggie Hassan it's two to
one wow 63 percent to uh with eight
percent in so we'll see we'll see
how's that do we have any information on
New York
I really wanted I really want that to go
New York I really want nothing in yet
does anybody like Kathy Holcomb nobody
likes her like anybody nobody voted for
her walk up and down the street in New
York can you find one person that's like
oh yeah she's great no she does nothing
worthwhile in the entire State now how
does how does New Hampshire go Democrat
that's what I don't get did it is that
what happened so so that right now it's
looking like it do you want to know how
New Hampshire goes Democrat because
everybody from Massachusetts moved to
Southern New Hampshire so why that's
literally how like and so we have to say
family Luke over here is always saying
like you go to New Hampshire and I'm
telling them like dude you're right next
to all of these
are you drinking Luke
just put your chair here
eight o'clock 10 minutes 15 minutes
I'm telling you you can take my seat now
so uh okay I think they're calling
Florida for Rhonda Sanders already
he's out there doing what what do we got
in 43 in this hand is at 53 to Chris's
45 yeah I don't believe it did you see
that I think it was uh CBS sent a
reporter out in Miami and he couldn't
find a single Chris reporter he was like
I went to a few restaurants and like a
reporter a reporter couldn't find a
single supporter okay yeah they found
like one guy like nobody wanted to
support him
I guess we'll see man we got the
decision desk map let's pull up uh the
house results what do we got so far it
looks like the areas where they're
they're calling it our red already is
that how it works or what no no no
that's not it I think that's just what
they're showing
so it looks like they're saying 30
Republicans to hate Democrats so far
oh not looking good for uh Caroline
Levitt
man it's like two to one twelve percent
in and Chris Papas has 61 percent to
Carolyn Levitz 38 she was a former I
think she was a White House eight in uh
the Trump Administration
I got an ad for on Facebook so I donated
looked pretty good
what else we got going on I don't donate
to politicians
I work for them I don't do anything West
Virginia district one Carol Miller wins
they're calling it for Carol Miller with
zero percent
this is so the home thing is bizarre
this time right I mean I mean there's no
point in saying anything else about West
Virginia come on it's Maga country
everybody agrees
can we not I don't get it why can't we
make this bigger
there we go
all right let's see where's a West
Virginia There we go West Virginia one
we got uh Mooney they're calling it for
Mooney already I guess is that what this
check mark means I don't know why is it
the Twitter verification Mark but it's
red look it is yeah probably what is the
icon
my most likely
are they is does that mean they called
it is that what is that what it means
runoff maybe it means it's no I don't
know what it means because they don't
have a check mark here
it's weird yeah they need a legend all
maps need Legends 2022 let's do attorney
general I don't care about that
we'll care about it later
so far Democrats got 37 seats
Republicans got 31 and they're saying
zero zero seats gained
well all right then the Florida Senate
looks interesting 61 in with Rubio
leading 53-46
so Florida's just going to be 40 red
decision death says 46 estimated votes
in
I was looking at political polls 61 for
that oh maybe political polls was saying
that they won the male and mail-in vote
and they currently are at 53 to 45
because that's what he's got right here
okay maybe it didn't mean they won
at that number I don't know oh man look
at this
no yeah he did 53-46 Marco Rubio won
Miami-Dade wow yeah well okay it's only
32 percent in so I don't know about the
mail-in votes but it's it's Miami's red
yo that's crazy
let's do uh let's do Governor results
and see what the DeSantis got down there
yup it's red 32 percent in DeSantis is
at 53-45
I care about Pennsylvania but I really
want to know like did they I don't know
if you I wasn't watching the news
clearly all day I was writing but did
they go to court today and say that they
could count votes up until the 14th or
the third they're trying to I don't know
or something right yeah and they were
still in court as of today yeah but the
federal campaign but do we know if that
is decided or if they decided I mean
look I don't know what came of that yeah
that undated and misdated ballots would
count it's like right what's the point
of having election laws and integrity at
all there is no election day anymore
it's election month
with 87 percent of unofficial results
reported Hillsborough County a county
won by Joe Biden in 2020 by 6.8 points
is currently led by DeSantis by seven
points CEO
man that is crazy this is uh it's turned
out to be a red wave huh where's
Hillsborough does anybody know where
Hillsboro is
no Tampa
is this what is this one you can't say
Red Wave yet because I still feel like
that's a very this is a very Philly
thing that you're doing with driving
which is like do not jinx do not I am it
is don't just don't say it just don't
say it don't give us any beard you do
that's what we say um but yeah don't
jinx it I'm gonna read some super chats
too because we got a long night ahead of
us and we better just read the ones we
can otherwise we're not going to read
any right so uh we got this from Dustin
wiser he says Libby is correct about New
Hampshire my sister is in banking the
amount of out-of-state house buyers from
New York Massachusetts and Connecticut
were five to one in state buyers so you
know I remember
um it's like a year ago maybe Luke was
like you got to move to New Hampshire
the free state project and I said dude
you're surrounded on all sides by
democrats or Canada like you can't do it
and then Luke was like nah you're wrong
you're wrong and now all of these
Democrats are moving in and it's turning
the state blue they're being invaded
Luke he's over there he's smiling he
knows he can't say anything because I
got the microphone no one can hear him
no one can hear what you're saying
he's agreeing with me he's saying Tim
you're right I'm so sorry
[Laughter]
going north go to Canada Luke sitting in
the back he's holding a bottle keep it
to your rebuttal now if you want yeah
come on
come on
bring the musket I'm not keeping count
no don't bring the musket okay
Luke's also holding a model 1861 rifled
Civil War musket it's an antique he's
just kidding always ready for the silver
but I will be drunk over there but I
think it's been done so that's why I
don't want to fire it can we look it up
and figure it out I'm seeing uh oh yeah
Anna Paulina Luna uh in Florida saying
that she won
really who's got that one Charlie Kirk
just congratulated her so that's what
I'm saying what's the decision desk
let's see if they got a new thing yeah
let's check that one out her videos were
21 seconds ago Anna Luna 165 to Eric
Lynn's 143. I don't think they haven't
called it oh what's this you've reached
your maximum allotted page views for one
day wait what decision desk I'll just
follow you on Twitter for free
yeah they got her at 52 to 45. that
wasn't so split like that oh with
greater than eight 95 in it looks like
she won yeah is that is that a flip yeah
that's a flip yeah she lost last time
around
that's definitely yeah let's get that
retweeted yeah I think that was an open
which is that it's Florida 13. yeah yeah
I just thought when Charlie Kirk posted
it
so I guess as long as I keep decision
desk open it doesn't matter yeah then
it's okay that was funny that was like a
joke that my son told me recently he
said oh no don't be like Elon Musk Elon
Musk spent 44 billion dollars on Twitter
but it's free on the App Store
Wait your kid said that yeah
[Laughter]
oh so this is uh okay what is this this
is uh which which city is this
penas County St Petersburg Largo and
Clearwater wait it's that South wait
what
what is this
13th congressional district do they did
they call it here on Wikipedia already
nope
she ran there in 2020
oh yeah wow yeah and Charlie Chris was
the incumbent so he's out that that oh
that was a I mean aside from the fact
that we're looking at a Red Wave anyway
losing the incumbent really opened up
the seat for sure Anna Paulina uh Luna
well there you go it looks like with
more than 95 reporting Florida 13 has
gone Republican she's going to DC
yeah I'm looking at this uh Virginia 2 I
think Virginia two was uh Lauria right
who was on the who's on January 6
committee yes 20 reporting has uh the
opposition Jen kiggins winning it's only
20 but if that if that does go for um
the GOP then that's two January 6
committee members voted out
so it looks like Google actually has the
whole map so
you said in Virginia oh this is great
Google actually has a free AP map
so yeah that's what I'm looking at
Google it's not letting me off right now
not letting me actually look at the
individual districts I guess
I guess it just has it right here
so who do you say Virginia second yeah
the Virginia Virginia second actually
we'll just pull up decision desk what do
we got here
they're saying um
71 in oh okay so they updated wow
28 minutes ago Anna Luna was actually
down by four points and then she took
the league with greater than 95 in so
that looks like it's it
so she worked hard though like good for
her she worked hard she she was out
there knocking doors and doing the right
thing like she she really fought to win
that seat the GOP has gained Florida 15
Laura Lee called by the decision desk
decision desk HQ projects Laura Lee wins
and that is a republican gain there we
go
slow motion Red Wave and then here's the
funny thing they're calling it right now
they're they're all they're outright
calling it what happens if there's a red
Mirage and then a week later like oh
yeah we did call it but now we're on
calling it red Mirage yeah that'll be
interesting decision mate 752 South
Carolina
yeah where did that map go there we go
Real Clear Politics has a map too just
so you know is it is like updating yeah
I don't know if uh
if that's like it's like showing the
actual
victories and everything current house I
see is that what's happening yeah
wait no way no no no no hold on
yeah okay I was like that's that's that
what without house projections
what are you on oh yeah real clear right
battle for the house 2022
they're saying 227 Republican already
but that's leaning Republican okay so
it's wow
if the lean Republicans all get
projected and confirmed then
there we go
they got it
what else is new
I'm disappointed about New Hampshire
there there was a push for this other
guy to take over in the primary and
nobody was paying attention I remember
like emailing people things about his
bio and that was a totally winnable seat
and to see it here at like
plus 1.4 is kind of disappointing
because we could have had that one too
man this is crazy all of the reports
coming in about Republican voter turnout
Miami-Dade is R plus 14 turnout wow he
did that's why I want to know that the
the amount of Democrats that actually
voted Republican I've because I'm living
in Philly now and every time I talk to
anybody like clearly I was out for one
of the wins from the Phillies when they
went to the championship and my Nate
random neighbors see my sign like
mastering moms from ashiana or whatever
and they come up to me and they're like
oh I'm a lifelong Democrat and I'm
voting uh Republican and even like
working with lives at Tick Tock now like
the the leads that come in 75 of them
are from actual Democrats who are
outraged about all the stuff that is
happening in the schools you would think
it would be like you know far right wing
bigoted people but it's not it's like
people that are like I'm just waking up
and this is crazy so I feel like there
should be somewhat of a big shift
between from Democrats like now voting
Republican maybe not Street ticket but
certainly on like the bigger races the
interesting thing too about that like
what you're saying about about outrage
Democrats is there is a point when
you're talking to people on the left and
they consistently say no that's not
really happening that's not really
happening no they're not doing sex
changes on kids and you're like girl
look like actually look look at these
scars look at these results look at
these people who have come out this
other side like we had a mom I was in
Philadelphia and she she sent us in a
lead right that said
they're doing
um drag queen Story Hour for my can my
kids first grade class and she was like
I you know didn't think this was
happening and now it's here in my school
and I feel like I'm isolated I don't
have anybody to talk to I I feel like I
don't know where to turn just lives
right but but still there's like a lot
of these people out there that they they
say to me all the time like I didn't
think that any of this was actually
happening like I thought it was
everywhere else or it was isolated and
now here it is right in my face and I
think that that you know they're not
asking those questions in the exit polls
but I think that the trans agenda thing
has a lot to do with a lot of this shift
for sure so we have uh decision desk is
back the Republicans currently plus one
seats
so uh we'll just be sitting here for the
next several hours tapping away on our
phones hitting refresh yeah maybe I'll
play what's that game I feel bad for
like Anna come up here all right come in
here you're saying uh political polls is
saying it's likely going to be a runoff
for the Georgia Senate
Ian's coming in
you guys had a high five on the way you
gotta tag in Luke is gonna be done
peeing in a second so before he usurps
my throne I just want to plug my
Instagram
follow me at Mary archived and also
subscribe to pop culture crisis on
YouTube very archived yeah I don't think
that's right yeah oh Instagram
I'm gonna do it okay peace out God bless
bye Etc wait Mary archived
yes Mary archived I'm doing that
Luke's here
damn right yo welcome back
my name's here Luke granowski here if we
are change.org I come here with a simple
message Joe and the foe have got to go
and of course that is not what exactly
says on my shirt if you want to see what
it says on there you go on
thebestpolitical shorts.com and you
could support me there and it's crazy
what's happening right now that this
country one of the richest countries in
the world can't count there's ballot
boxes failing what in the world is
happening here come on obviously we see
NBA ABC News gaslighting the fetterman
campaign gaslighting saying hey it's
just going to be a few days it's okay
it's totally normal totally fine no it's
not it's not okay it's not normal a lot
of people more than ever have record
have voted before the election in early
voting we should be having a lot of
these numbers up to date when it happens
when it comes in we don't so of course A
lot of people are going to be skeptical
a lot of people are going to be asking
themselves a lot of serious questions
but there's so many different issues
that I want to talk about a Rothschild
pass away passed away on a Red Bull
blood moon yo there's so many crazy
things happening Crystal Matthews
reportedly deleted her account I don't
think that's true I think this got it
wrong okay I'm gonna fact check that one
what's uh Crystal matthews's Twitter
account
hey Ian that's great isn't it yeah it is
dude yeah we were sitting there in the
back and I was like we got to give these
guys a show in the back there so uh we
were trying to entertain as much as we
could that was one of the beanies that I
got Tim for I think one of his birthday
I want to keep it yeah and I was like
you know we got it you turned my head
set down a little there's yeah I can do
that thanks I can thanks bro no no
worries yeah I didn't know if there was
if it was dirty on the inside so I kind
of was trying to wipe that off before I
put it on Anna Paulina Luna wins Florida
13. yeah boom
what's this Crystal girl's name you're
looking for Crystal Matthews someone
Ryan savedra said that she deleted her
Twitter account but I don't know if she
even had one
how's that Tim Ryan is currently up
first votes in 103 uh 73 to 26 percent
JD Vance is down it's early though we'll
see what happens
I'm seeing reports that Abrams is uh in
the leadership oh that was 20 minutes
ago currently Tim Ryan's at 64-35. I see
that too what is this they've turned off
MSNBC in the west wing per White House
ever off from sobic really they turned
it off there's also reports of distance
in Florida so a huge lead for DeSantis
in in Florida which I think is also
extremely telling a lot of people were
saying that he was definitely going to
be with him he's got 15 points a couple
of minutes ago it was 12 12 now it's 15
and I think you know the longer we go on
it's going to be very clear that that
Florida again a purple State could go
either way just like New Hampshire a
purple State this is Battleground states
that will decide the future of this
country along with Pennsylvania and
Arizona uh we have Tampa's all red right
now wow what about Arizona and
Pennsylvania what are those numbers
because those are the most important
we're not there yet I don't think the
poll is closed I'm a bit of a novice
with the lingo if they're up 15 points
does that mean it's 57.5 to 42.5 yeah
seven and a half in both directions got
it no no no no no so right right Rhonda
Santos is 57.11 to Charlie Crist 42.26
hell yeah so he's up just shy of 15
points and uh he's got Miami red we've
got uh what is this Broward county is
blue
with 30 reporting that's surprising to
be completely honest but did you guys
talk about Arizona at all I saw some the
data's not in yet because that's not
going to be for a couple hours yeah so
we'll be here all night everybody we'll
be here all night it was a while there
was a Twitter clip of Kerry Lake and I
think it was harmy Dillon saying
actually here just in case you guys want
to get everything straight you're having
trouble voting you got to go to the
government website which is like
vote.arizona slash Goodluck dot find it
if you can hyphen look for me dot org
and she's like leave it to the
government to make the most ridiculous
URL for people to try and find like
they're almost they're almost trying to
make it difficult you might think when
you could just have bought like vote
Arizona 2022.com yeah vote now Arizona
2022.com and have people go to that well
this is where it gets confusing because
on one hand we know that there's a large
swap of the government that is totally
incompetent is that the incompetent arm
that is represented in what's happening
in Arizona or is it malice or is it
anything else we still don't know it's
still very early early to tell but what
I've been seeing from Kerry Lake and
Donald Trump is specifically setting out
videos being like hey I know the lines
are long in the Annapolis people are
waiting an hour and a half I know
they're long please stay in line please
stay in line because at the end of the
day we don't have a voting holiday
people have a very short window to come
and vote And when they see a huge line I
mean obviously the average American is
like I don't want to wait in line for
that long are you kidding me I don't
want to play in this fish or fight or
Fisher Price Ballot Box you make believe
uh pretend system I don't want to do any
of that for that long I don't care that
much my it's only one vote it doesn't
matter so the the messaging here is very
important and and it's just
mind-boggling that that we live in a
country that can't even count their
votes that you you can't test the
machines the day before I mean that's
just utterly ridiculous and crazy and
I'm getting some videos in Maricopa of
some of the poll Watchers instructing
people not to wait
uh just turning the boat right now don't
wait you don't have to wait they kind of
this is a crazy play on you not to wait
because they want you to do what they
want Carrie late tweeted out that if
you've checked in already
you need to wait and cast your ballot
either with a broken voting machine or
to put your your ballot in the box where
they'll check it later and then some
leftist journalists came out calling it
disinformation telling people to leave
and I was like what the why why would
Carrie like a go against her own votes
she's not gonna lie to her own voters
yeah and then some other journalist
comes out and says no no if you are
there and you checked in you can leave
don't worry like wait wait wait wait
wait wait I say follow the advice of the
election you know when they're when when
the uh what's his name Bill Gates is
actually his name the guy running the
elections or whatever oh that doesn't
surprise me at all but it's it's not the
building I know I know but he was like
you can still put your ballot in the Box
we will we will count it and then
someone was like there's going to be a
Democrat and a Republican and they're
both gonna be watching the count why
would this person go on Twitter and tell
people to leave that sounds suspect I
don't trust these people man yeah
there's three there's 3800 incorrectly
dated ballots in Pennsylvania that
ballot workers are going to have to
manually fix I mean that again like why
is why is that happening you know
Pennsylvania is going to be somewhere
that we've been gaslighted to think that
it's going to take many days to find out
what happened why is that happening I
mean is it incompetency is is it malice
well I it's just they also have the
issue where it's like
um they're they've already said that
there's a bunch of ballots they're not
going to account tonight like 300 000
ballots or something that's ridiculous
fired yeah it's fired automatically it's
happening because fire all of them
they're essentially asking people to
ride my horse back to get to a big open
clearing where you set up your tent and
camp for seven days like it's not 1840
why are we voting by paper we have
digital technology where we can vote
instantly like voting by paper I think
we should be voting by paper all the
time we should be marking our
fingerprints like not our fingerprints
but like stain your finger purple you
know like we see I think that it like
makes a lot more sense to do it as
simply as possible we're having so many
problems with the voting machines like
you saw was going on in Maricopa County
they had ballots that were so poorly
printed the scanners couldn't read them
and it took technicians to come out and
we got data data's coming from
Pennsylvania
in Georgia it's leaning Democrat
Pennsylvania just had some data drop
three percent is in with John fetterman
83 to mement Oz is 14 and it's Mo it's
just Pittsburgh's data so unsurprising
14 of the votes in from Pittsburgh and
and Oz is being fair I'm sorry fetterman
is being favored I think that this is so
crazy how could betterment be favored
it's just Pittsburgh brain damage it's
just it's a major it's a major city area
that is heavily Democratic if that guy
wins nobody's gonna believe it I got
arrested in Pittsburgh it wasn't fun uh
not a fun place they like drove me
around to like three different jails uh
not a good place I didn't have a lot of
fun there uh but but that's what you
expect in a major city major cities are
of course going to be voting for uh the
Democrats we've seen a big voter uh
turnout especially in the last
presidential election mainly because of
the efforts of Facebook and other
billionaires and other special interests
that got involved and said hey we're
gonna make sure that we're going to make
it as easy as we can and there's also
covid so we're going to have to have as
many mail-in ballots as possible there's
a lot of ballot Harvesters and Facebook
invested hundreds of millions of dollars
specifically concentrating and focusing
on people in major cities on voting
knowing that this is going to result in
a political party that is more favorable
of big Tech and won't of course censor
them or input them in check so you know
we've seen how Google reacted after the
2016 election I think we're seeing the
results of that after the last
presidential election and I think we're
we might be seeing some of that if it's
going to be consistent if it's going to
work we're going to see today how
effective those hundreds of millions of
dollars efforts are yeah it is decision
desk said seven minutes ago Ron DeSantis
has one in Florida he will hold the
state we have in Alabama Katie Britt
will hold the state Marco Rubio has one
in Florida this is all a whole lot of
fun Anna Paulina Luna called by the
decision desk as the winner in Florida
13. wow look at all this is amazing do
these ever come out inaccurate decision
desk well you know there's going to be a
red Mirage Ian and then we'll have to
wait we'll have to wait a couple weeks
take off the red colored glasses and see
what it really looks like oh man the
reason I I think that I brought up uh
voting digitally Libby and what you were
talking about is that I think that it
although voting by paper you mail it in
and it might make it easier on the front
end for people but it's created a mess
in the back end where there's paper all
over the place and people don't know
who's in what boxes they gotta count it
50 times and then if it gets moved they
gotta count it again and uh then we have
proprietary voting machines doing the
tallies like if we had an organized just
because one system of digital
digitization of voting is gone wrong
doesn't mean that it's all bad I think
that sorry future of voting we got data
from Missouri and the libertarian party
is currently in the lead oh my God
all right we gotta open up the Louie
right now
this is actually pretty cool with uh
five votes uh five votes five five we'll
take it we'll take it we'll run up with
it all right then so in Butler County
with less than one percent reporting
five votes for the libertarian I'm sorry
Libertarians you know we love you but to
see the Libertarians in the lead
screenshot it now because in the nation
look at this time look at this nation
right now I saw Missouri turn yellow and
with what it's going to be a yellow wave
of you know what going over all over the
political party a yellow wave of of pp
all over the political system and
establishment I saw Missouri turn yellow
and I just was like what and then I
clicked and it's like one County and
it's five votes just five it's happening
screenshot it while you can Libertarians
I gotta I got a derail here for a moment
I'm looking at blue and red and thinking
about the red white and blue American
colors the blue and the red the way that
the Republican Party already in the
Democrat Party have co-opted the red and
the blue and they've also called their
parties republicanism democracy as if
these parties have anything to do with
those Concepts or represent those
Concepts in any way we're all
Republicans and that we live in the
Republic of the United States the last
time Ian made this point he said you got
the red part in the blue party and then
he called from the white party
no
Democratic party does not more or less
represent democracy then the Republican
Party represents that's more or less
republicanism we're all Republicans no
no no actually the Democratic party is
all about direct democracy and the
Republican party is about republicanism
it it it wasn't supposed to be that way
but that's what it is for now yeah it
could be but don't it's not because of
the names the names almost should be
legally changed it's like calling it
Federal Express when it wasn't Federal I
I think it's misleading I think we're in
a simulation what's going on over there
was it I just looked at there's a Blood
Moon this morning signifying uh Incans
and Mesopotamians believe that it
signified the death or overthrow of the
king and so I'm just like that was at
1202 a.m Pacific so like when the
contiguous U.S entered November 8th a
Blood Moon happened that is weird yeah
that's just crazy
as Evelyn D Rothschild of the banking
Dynasty died at the age of 91. I heard
that he was worth 260 trillion dollars
in night in 2011. well he comes from the
family that of course is has
historically been controlling a lot the
bigger banking institutions the same
family that of course Hoodwinked at the
Battle of Waterloo the situation which
allowed them to become so prominent and
have so much money uh in their entire
family this has come up before so the
Waterloo things when Napoleon is about
to lose the war and they knew he lost
but they came in and they actually faked
out the British uh stock market and said
that that he won and of course that made
everyone sell they bought off uh the
stocks on the cheap and then when the
real news came in saying Napoleon lost
the stock market went up and of course
they were super rich uh that's one of
the historical kind of understandings of
it but I don't want to uh you know to
talk about the Rothschilds so we do do
we think uh well actually okay Real
Clear Politics uh projected that uh Ted
Bud would win in North Carolina right
now with 45 percent of the vote in
Cherry Beasley is up about nine points
uh 9.3 points so we're still waiting on
several counties to report but uh I
don't know man and like I said my fellow
New Hampshire state that I love and the
free state project that I love in there
it's only 16 that are counted yes 58 uh
blue but but again only 16 of the votes
are in it's still a long night the
libertarian party is winning in some in
some jurisdictions that's impossible
it's not supposed to happen uh it's not
no Libertarians in New Hampshire no no
in Missouri
it's my boat
it's only 16 of the votes in in New
Hampshire currently right now I love the
state it's a beautiful state but there
are a lot of mass holes moving in uh it
is kind of changing demographically but
it is also home of the free state
project that does bet on local politics
and I think you know a lot of people are
looking at the big Senate races and the
Congressional races I think if there's
going to be any big significant change
it is absolutely going to be in these
small local races uh the free state
project has captivated all of New
Hampshire and has won a lot of seats in
the local offices that was able to make
laws and get rid of really bad laws in
New Hampshire and it's going to be
interesting to see where the state goes
it's a purple state it could go either
way and at the end of the day I'd rather
be where the battle is rather than be
somewhere comfortable that's why I love
Florida that's why I love New Hampshire
purple States it's where the battle our
ideas is and that's why we need to be in
Missouri uh seven votes counted
and and the issue is in uh in Butler
County they only had seven votes to
report so it's probably really easy to
wrap up
you know they they opened the door seven
people showed up five of them were for
the libertarian one was for other one
was for Democrat and no one voted GOP
and they're like that's it seven all
right we'll send it in and so there you
go that's how you get it
can we call the race now
can we please with seven votes in the
libertarian takes the state I mean I I
don't like the political uh the
libertarian political party even myself
uh to be honest with you I think the
party has failed many times over and has
become an embarrassment in many
instances will it have a different face
with Dave Smith
um I'm a little optimistic especially
coming up in the 2024 elections this is
going to be the precursor of I think the
larger bigger Battle of the presidential
elections uh it is surprising to see so
many people vote again 44 million people
voted early this year it's a 40-year
high so we're seeing the involvement of
people in politics uh escalate
throughout the throughout the last few
years is that because of you know
Facebook and all these other
institutions telling people to vote in
the cities is this because people are
understanding that you know if you
ignore politics if you try to be out of
politics politics is going to be inside
of your life I forgot the exact phrase I
think I like that one though yeah yeah
oh I mean if you don't take uh take an
interest in politics politics will take
an interest in you thank you though if
you're not inside politics politics will
be inside you I like that yeah more ways
than one especially if you're Bill
Clinton and all these other uh
presidents and and really bad
politicians that go to private islands
but that's a separate order and that's a
separate deal we're not here to talk
about that but but I I again I want to
revert back local elections are I think
the biggest game changer the biggest
difference and I I think we're seeing
people especially with what happened in
Loudoun County not so far away from here
of people saying enough is enough this
is crazy what happened with covet this
is crazy what's happening to my children
this is crazy what's happening at the
gas pumps I need to get involved in
politics because politics is getting
involved in my life in more ways than
one and it's making my life miserable
and I I think this could be a
representation today of what we're going
to be seeing what do you guys think of
the people I guess we can call them like
refugees of California or people fleeing
New York yeah going to Florida or going
to Texas going to Arizona do you think
they'll actually learn and start voting
differently yeah absolutely no they
don't I don't think they will I don't
think so I disagree with you let's hear
why no you want to go first okay how
about this there was a guy who wrote
about how he was moving to Florida
knowing the politics were bad but
California has just become too awful so
he's going to continue to vote Democrat
when he gets to Florida okay I think
those are rare and usually when people
leave they had enough of of this
nonsense I I was in New York City I left
New York City I first went to New
Hampshire now I'm in Florida uh but but
obviously the people who are naturally
either conservative or against the other
Insanity that the Democratic party put
forward within the last three years are
the ones who were leaving people who are
fed up and sick of the policies sick of
the taxes sick of the regulation sick of
the Mandate sick of the lockdowns are
leaving this is why I like right but I
think this is why you know I don't know
if you want to talk about your okay
that's fine uh but but personally you
know I left and and I see a lot of other
people like myself leaving because of
the same reason they had enough of the
big cities and they read and and you
know I'm going to be voting a certain
way in Florida so so I think there's a
lot more people like that and it's only
polarizing the political landscape I do
think though that there's a lot of
people who will leave you know New York
California wherever other horrifying
place that they find themselves living I
think they will leave and they will go
vote Democrat in other places because
they will feel that the Democratic party
just didn't do it right where they were
you know like those people who say that
wasn't real communism those kind of
people they're just going to keep voting
the exact same way but the people who
love the mask mandates the people who
love the lockdowns the people who love
the transitions that are happening to
children they're going to stay where
they're going to have where they're
going to have the best representation
they're going to be like you know what I
have to leave for this very specific
reason I do think that it was correct
but perhaps why would they be moving to
a state with crazy anti-maskers why
would they be moving to a state looking
at it look at New Hampshire all of the
as you say all of the mass holes they
moved to New Hampshire right because
there's no income tax and whatever and
they're just going to pay high property
taxes or whatever so they move up there
and now New Hampshire purple like they
they're moving up there and they're
voting blue I don't know well here's the
thing we are seeing that there's a lot
of where where was it that we were
looking at earlier where it was a lot of
Independence was that was that the Rubio
election that Miami did was it it was a
bunch of Independents that put yeah it
was the end they didn't actually say
republican the GOP was down to compare
to Dems but the independence
tacked on so I'm I am curious to see if
there are people that might be like
ghost voting not really identifying as
anything that are kind of really sick of
what's going on the people that Luke is
talking about but I do think there are
probably a bunch of like woke-hearted
morons that like just will probably
think like that what Libby is saying and
still kind of think there's a different
Democrat that might do it better I I'm
just curious to see where this lands
because I'm genuinely curious to see if
people actually learn from 2020 the
lockdowns the riots and all the stuff
that's been taking place yeah I'm just
curious to see where these people
actually like you might be right and I
might be right but it depends who's more
right depending on the individuals and
it's very hard to get such a thing I
talked to a lot of parents during the
lockdowns who were dealing with masks
and whatever else and their kids were
being suicidal because they and the
force inoculations all of this stuff
they were dealing with it it was even
pre-force inoculations as you as you say
um and they they were moving to Texas
and different places so that their kids
could go to school but that was the only
reason so it was like they once they get
to the place where the schools are open
they're going to keep doing exactly
voting exactly the same way that they
were voting before I think kobit matters
a lot more than we're actually giving it
credit because this is the first
election kind of officially after covet
and I think that's going to matter
because there's going to be certain
amount of individuals that fell for the
trauma-based mind control and they felt
safe because their state was locking
people down inside of their own homes
there's other individuals who were
denied seeing their loved ones at their
deathbed and when they go through such
emotional trauma because of the state I
don't think those people are going to be
reverting back saying we need more State
that's just me personally their grandmas
die live on Zoom they're not going to go
back and not even going to be able to go
to there and those are a lot of people
and those people are fed up and those
people usually vote with their feet with
their dollar not just with of course uh
you know the election box so so I think
a lot of those people were like this is
insane I can't believe I had a
government that was controlling every
aspect of my existence every aspect of
my life treating me like I was a little
child I don't want this nonsense I want
to live a place where I have actual
freedom and liberty I want to go down to
Florida I want to go down to you know
New Hampshire I want to help out the
free state project I want to go down to
another state like West Virginia where I
could have more freedom more personal
responsibility and a government official
is not going to be not going to be
telling me how to live my life I think a
lot of people have voted that way with
their feet with their movements
um and I think that's why Kathy Hogle
was even coming out a couple weeks ago
and saying hey if if you're voting
Republican you're not a New Yorker you
got to leave yeah again and a lot of
people have been leaving big mistake of
her by the way yeah so obnoxious I
thought that was just so horrifyingly
obnoxious you don't get to decide just
because you're you know you ousted your
opposition with fake sex scandals and
took power doesn't mean you get to tell
the entirety of New Yorkers who they are
and what they're about what garbage what
a garbage person I mean look what's
happened to Beto yeah Beto's not having
any kind of significant victories in
Texas today there's no way I mean I
don't see uh Texas turning up purple I
just don't see it I see a lot of the the
Latino Community actually you know doing
180 degree turn on the Democratic party
and saying you guys are too crazy for us
stop calling us latinx stop trying to
patronize nobody likes the latinx nobody
wants that it's just a bunch of white
people who want to call people yeah a
few yuppies in in the real colorizers
yeah in Williamsburg a few yuppies with
nose rings were like yeah latinx this is
great it's not it's horrible it's
disgusting stop it you know we talked
about
um this common cold times mystery what
do you think about it drew that it's so
easy now to travel between state to
state get a new house in another state
that maybe you should have to wait a
couple years before you can vote once
you relocate States you know there are a
lot of states that have residency
requirements and there are rules and
some of what you've been seeing over the
past couple of years with States
changing election laws and allowing
illegal immigrants to vote has had to do
with residency requirements so in New
York I think it was something like the
city council passed a law saying that
that illegal immigrants could vote no
leak it was legal immigrants it was
non-citizens New York said New York City
Council non-citizens can vote if they
have had three months residency and I
know that there were some other states
that were trying to do the exact same
thing but say they only needed one month
residency and all the states do have
residency requirements before you can
vote but some of them are far lesser
than others I don't think any of them
are a year allowing uh I'm sorry go
ahead to vote three months in sounds
like they're harvesting but they want to
get low information people to vote yeah
it actually yeah
yeah it got overturned by a court what
what got overturned the uh the uh legal
it was legal immigrants it was like if
you had a green card or whatever but you
weren't a citizen you were going to be
allowed to vote and I'm pretty sure
Supreme Court in New York overturned
that and said that that's not actually
constitutional well let's just say we
got the uh the needle meter here which
is showing it's uh the Senate is
actually starting to lean slightly
towards the Democrats but still toss-up
range and they're currently saying
there's a 76 chance that Republicans
will take control of the house a Drew I
wanted to ask you what are you seeing
where you live because like I I spent I
spent a lot of time in Miami Miami looks
like it's it's going red which is
surprising to a lot of people not me
when I was on the ground there talking
to the people there living there having
neighbors there uh seeing the the the
the change to that city which overall
was was for the worst like crime it's
just crazy especially down in South
Beach I think that's having a major
effect on what's happening right now at
the polling booths uh in Miami
potentially a heavily Blue Area
potentially turning red what are you
seeing in your area are you public about
where you live can you talk about it so
Arizona that's a purple State too
Arizona Cary lake is a freaking rock
star dude like nobody likes Katie Hobbs
everybody knows that Katie Hobbs is a
lifeless empty puppet that doesn't know
anything because when she's asked right
she did like some kind of little town
Town Hall thing with like the Hispanic
community in Arizona and they were
specifically asking her have you learned
anything about the Latino Community
while you've been in Arizona while
you've been campaigning on the campaign
Trail could not say one thing could not
come up with one single thing this is
part of the reason why Katie Hobbs would
not debate Carrie Lake because Carrie
Lake would destroy her and humiliate her
publicly and annihilate her but I think
the Democrats in Arizona kind of know
what they're doing because they know
they need to keep her away from Carrie
Lake but what I will say to go to your
point is Arizona okay is red obviously
there are some purple pockets and
there's some like like Tucson is pretty
blue right and they call Tucson like the
armpit of Arizona but what I will say is
that the majority of arizonans they do
not want this far left stuff taking over
their schools taking over their children
and the gun thing too and people from
California have been moving in in large
numbers and the anti-2a stuff does not
sit well in Arizona right now I don't
think it ever will but this this is why
a lot of people think that this is
probably why they want to you know rig
their way in we got uh uh a decision
desk calling Massachusetts governor
democrat flip yeah that's a shame but
I'm not really sure anyone thought
Massachusetts was actually Republican
yeah Massachusetts is not fun I think
it's about like Springfield moved out of
the State Historical Springfield Armory
they moved out of Massachusetts because
of very restrictive gun laws insane gun
laws that are absolutely nonsensical
don't make any sense at all and are just
ridiculous uh like I I you know being in
New Hampshire totally different world
for now which hopefully we could hold on
to gun control people are the dumbest
people on planet Earth dude the dumbest
people I don't know about the dumbest
but they are the dumbest people Tim you
know this very ignorant Tim Tim you know
they're stupid people you know this when
you have a conversation with these
people and you ask them it always goes
the same way do you support gun control
do you support taking firearms and
disarming the public they will come out
and say yes I totally support that
because I want to save lives but then
you turn around and you ask them well
what about the government are they going
to disarm too they will literally say
the same thing it's not that they'll be
stumped these people will respond and
say well yeah the government will do the
right thing if you ask a gun control we
should do a man on the street and see
yeah what they say is I don't want to
take everyone's guns away I just think
these assault weapons are really
dangerous you say what's an assault
weapon and they go
30 round magazine semi-automatic that's
that's that's that's that's not that's
what I was told when I asked my dad
about it but then I was like well we
need that to protect ourselves from a
potentially tyrannical government and
then I get this stuff that's the stunned
look where gun people want to disarm are
completely at a loss it's not even that
you need to protect against governments
or or wild animals or wild animals I'm
talking about Mexican cartels American
psychos you know you've got to protect
yourself but this is where the local
voting absolutely matters because if you
look at gun rights they have been
actually expanding because of states
rights because of individuals in the
local jurisdictions as and the State
Assembly members and the Senate assembly
houses coming together and saying you
know what constitutional carry makes a
lot of sense let's pass this for our
state this is where I I think your vote
absolutely matters in the larger scheme
of things because at the local level you
can make the biggest amount of
difference as soon as you start paying
attention to what's going on in your
life I started to think like the border
states are the most important to have
armed where the citizens are armed
because we literally have an invasive
Force pushing slaves across the but the
South border at the moment uh
terrifyingly by a narco-tierney state of
government with these cartel that are
like de facto The Mexican government
it's terrifying yeah that's terrifying
you notice we don't have the police
force or we're going to send in the
military at some point nobody's doing
anything I mean like your states are
trying to do stuff about it on their own
but they're not getting help you know
what you know what's funny is as I've
been reading more about the Civil War
the southern Democrats wanted slaves
because they wanted you know a
effectively cheap labor when the cotton
gin got invented it made it so that
seeds could be easily removed from
certain cotton that was worth less now
became worth more and so they needed
more slaves they needed people to do
labor at a dirt rate right now the
Republicans want America First policies
they want by America they want American
manufacturing they want American free
labor to make products and the Democrats
are the ones who have consistently
advocated for this International Trade
free trade trans-pacific partnership
which is basically slave labor
Outsourcing jobs from America to places
like southeast Asia where people work
for dirt so that people in the United
States can have cheap products same
party same old same old garbage
they also were trying to I mean the
trans-pacific partnership was trying to
essentially blackmail people into
forcing them to use slave labor
Americans if they were like we're not
using this Malaysian Oil Company more
because they're not paying their their
employees the right wages the company
like well you signed the partnership we
have the investor State dispute
settlement Clause that allows us to sue
the United States government now because
you won't buy our slave labor oil so
it's crazy Trump got us out of that
thank God Sanders would have got us out
of that Obama wanted us into it I don't
know now it's it's done and we Trump
signed us out of it so it's gone I think
we have a new partnership deal without
the US now we get cheap products abroad
because people don't have health care
don't have unions don't have Labor
rights get paid dirt and then U.S
companies import these things for dirt
sell back to Americans and it's
destroying it's it's destroying our
economy it's very very bad and we're
we're we we don't even produce our own
vitamins or antibiotics we get them from
China when when the pandemic hit the
masks weren't even being made here so
when we needed them the boats get turned
around trying to takes them all back
it's funny Democrats are are the party
of having you know impoverished third
world countries do your labor for dirt
and and advocating that they should be
happy for it and Republicans like Trump
were like bring the factory back to
Detroit where American free labor will
produce it it's amazing I think there
was even a story about the United States
stealing masks from uh the the French
and and and the Chinese hoarding it
themselves and then upselling it at a
bigger profit uh with specifically even
them being accused of hoarding medical
supplies when they knew that there was a
virus going around they they allegedly
hid that information to themselves in
order to profit off of it as they were
telling even their citizens in the
mainland get as much of this as you can
it's going to be really valuable and it
was
Indiana's first first votes are in
Democrat is up but you know these are
all kind of whatever we'll see what
happens though we got uh New Hampshire
Senate General Maggie Hassan is at 59 to
Don bolduck's 38 percent
oh boy it's gonna be interesting I'll
say that I think they're gonna impeach
Joe Biden yes if if the Republicans win
yes I think they'll impeach him for
there's a number of instances there's a
new whistleblower also coming forward
making some allegations against Hunter
Biden right now that's one possibility
uh I I think what's happening draining
the oil Reserve yeah what's happening
with uh Biden and in China with Hunter
Biden with the business dealings Tony
bobolinski all that stuff when when the
Republicans do take office one of the
hopes I have again I'm not that hopeful
and I don't have a lot of faith in the
Republican party to be completely honest
with you guys but to hopefully open up
the hearings get Dr fauci in there get
Tony bobolinski there get Hunter Biden
there and and let the world see what's
actually really happening behind the
scenes let's let's unveil the contracts
let's see what other business dealings
there was with Ukraine let's see what
else uh the Chinese government was
influencing with our government let's
see how the Chinese government profited
off of the Afghanistan withdrawer uh
let's see you know the large landscape
of of what's really happening here you
know uh Santorum was on the show he was
saying that you have to impeach a
president for something they they've
done as president
so I think draining the petroleum
reserve the problems on the board is a
bunch of things to go after and for in
terms of impeachment but uh 25th
amendment may be the actual approach
that might be the one that works
although I do have to say about the
petroleum reserves I find that sort of
terrifying you know that we can be
depleting our Reserve so quickly so
brazenly and and he just keeps
congratulating himself for it and I look
at that and when I look at my bank
account numbers if they're you know
dipping 33 because I'm just randomly
doing whatever you know that freaks me
out I think if there's anything that Joe
Biden has done or is trying to do that
is worthy of impeachment is I don't know
if you guys saw this video he announced
publicly that he wants to make Roe v
Wade a rallaland did you see that one a
rallaland is that it I can't believe it
I can't believe he would say that
you don't say he said that he wants to
make Roe v way to rallyland and I'm like
that is disqualified yep too much so in
addition to no more Drilling in addition
to you know firing all coal workers all
people in the coal industry all of that
he even wants to go as far as to make
Roe v Wade around I can't believe it
that right there everyone tell your
family because when your parents when
your friend's here he wants to make
someone who wants to make Roe your way
to Rattle and they're going to gasp here
we go here are you ready you ready you
want to hear it yeah let's hear it
codified Robey weighed in January and
make it a round of the land we're gonna
codify Roby wait in January and make it
a round of the land a rally Lane
January and make it around the land a
rally on the land you're right it's a
rally land
law of the land and he said rule of the
land all I really think about it but why
would you say all of the land instead of
the rule of the land I don't know
because I don't know why I didn't know
how to speak we do not translate for Joe
Biden we say what he said and what he
said was rela land Reliance that is
disqualifying right there I'm sorry
impeached what if there's a country
why would we want to make Roe v Wade
that country why not it could be a place
where you know like Taiwan it could be
America the ultimate abortion place like
you just go there it's run by death cult
and you know they're safe there exactly
you know governments
has won oh how about that big news big
news let's jump back decision desk where
she was Alabama
Arkansas right right yeah so political
polls showing it so do they call it
Sarah Sanders okay there's no data in
but decision desk has called it and then
we have uh where were we just now
political polls says AP projects Sarah
Huckabee Sanders wins the Arkansas
governor nice
do you remember a couple of years first
everyone was telling uh when everyone
was saying that like if you saw people
who worked with Trump just having dinner
somewhere to go out and attack them who
was that uh what's her name oh how can I
not remember her name the California
congresswoman
Maxine Waters yeah she was out there
like if you see people you just go
confront them where they are and then
remember they like forced Sarah Huckabee
Sanders out of was it a Waffle House am
I remembering this correctly do you guys
remember that we got a message from
Carrie Lake here everybody Arizona stay
in line if you are lined up ready to
vote and the polls close they gotta let
you vote so do not get out of line until
you cast that ballot that ballot is your
voice and you must vote tonight we need
a red tsunami in Arizona we'll talk to
you later Carrie Lake and and Rhonda
santis are like two of the best
politicians I've seen I think we got
some Texas numbers Texas
just Austin and Dallas right it's Austin
and Dallas yeah it's a major city that
of course is coming in people in the
combat section are like Pedro's not when
we were commenting to make a Quinn obedo
they're like no Barbados winning yeah
early on the votes are still coming in
yeah the votes are mainly coming in from
the major big city areas which Hannah at
post millennial posted that and she was
like ooh ooh and I was like no it's just
too early it's too early don't puke yet
so hang on
yeah they said Democrats are obsessed
with Superstar losers what if it becomes
the next Abraham Lincoln
was it Beto uh a stand-in for uh
Napoleon Dynamite
I hope so Abe Lincoln started his own
political party won a four-way race if
we really want another Abraham Lincoln I
think they're gonna have to step outside
the Paradigm create a new party I mean
Trump had the opportunity Bernie Sanders
had the opportunity the world is ripe
for it right now we need someone that's
just brazenly say talk about the
corruption within the you know obviously
what it created two-party system it's
been set up that way Thomas Massey talks
a lot about it on purpose there's two
Chambers they're not supposed to be two
there's unlimited they're infinite
amounts of political parties so the next
great Abe Lincoln character is going to
come out of left field and create their
own political party I think otherwise
they're not an a blinking character
because that's what it did well there's
a divide also in the Republican party I
think a lot of them are either neocons
or or want to be populists some of them
are actual populists but as of right now
how do you guys see it I want to ask you
drew this specifically Santos is up 17
points of 1.2 million that's a bloodbath
but but Drew you're you're in the kind
of conservative World more than I am how
do you see this divide who has more
support on their side especially when it
comes to the political institutional
power is it neocons is it the
establishment Republicans or are
populists bigger more powerful or do you
see this election being a turning point
in either of those directions well I
think the establishment on both sides
the unit party is always going to be
unified uh behind the scenes and then
when you talk about the donor side of
that and the money side of that they
have the ability to really pull some
heavy strings behind the scenes
especially in DC so as much as the
establishment continues to be unified
behind the scenes together I think
that's always going to be a problem for
the populist movement whether it's on
left or right because I mean you take a
look at Bernie Sanders and how he got
destroyed immediately by The
Establishment two times multiple times
it happens so as long as they're
continuing to be established and unified
I think that will continue to be a
problem for conservatives and populists
on the right but I I will say this
um this might be an unpopular opinion
whatever but I think DeSantis and Trump
really clashing with each other is going
to become very problematic for the
populist movement because for me it's
just kind of like sitting there watching
that like
your parents getting a divorce and you
don't know why and you're sitting there
kind of questioning why is this
happening and then you're starting to
see the there's like kind of like a
donor War have you been seeing that as
well I know why I've been seeing it for
a while I've been calling it here on the
show saying DeSantis and Trump are going
to be going at it and they are and you
see Trump kind of making the Jabs today
like yeah we saw that all over on the
New York Times today I love these these
tweets from Define else Charles Booker
on October 7th on November 8th Kentucky
is going to get a new United States
Senator I'm him and the next one is WDRB
news Rand Paul defeats Charles Booker
wins third term to U.S Senate so just
back on the silver General topic because
I think it's important to to understand
here this larger Republican civil war
between the populists and the neocons uh
because again if if the Republicans win
overwhelmingly today it's going to be
who Kevin McCarthy and Mitch McConnell
that are going to be here
uh okay yeah not surprised uh sununu is
very popular he did let a lot of people
down with some of his policies but
overall he's a lot better than all the
other ones in New Hampshire that's
specifically the race there but what is
Mitch McConnell and Kevin McCarthy going
to do wag their finger and just
implement the same policies that as the
Democrats 10 years from now uh you know
this is why you know a lot of people are
kind of disenfranchised being like okay
you know we have this right away but but
is this Red Wave going to do anything
that's the larger question that I think
a lot of people are asking them well
that is that is the concern because
typically when people get into power
they find that they don't perhaps like
governing they instead like attacking
their opponents
um and don't actually tend to get
anything done so that's a concern but I
do think were we talking about it
earlier like they're going to you know
if the if the conservatives take
Congress they're still not going to be
able to pass any legislation because
Biden will veto everything they do and
so all they'll be able to do is a lot of
like rhetoric a lot of Investigations
which I do think are important and it's
important to get to the bottom of that
stuff but they're going to come up after
two years without having made any major
changes in Congress they will have
perhaps made major changes in public
opinion if they can move fast enough and
then the Democrats are going to be like
look they they had power they did
nothing with it right you know this is
this is who you want to vote in as
president of the United States I think
that's happening and then it's
interesting because again as you were
talking here Civil War within a civil
war with now DeSantis and Trump butting
heads going at it uh not really DeSantis
you just see Trump just kind of jabbing
he did this a number of times he did he
did this a couple days ago called them
uh Ron D sanctimonious he did this even
a couple months ago after that and I
just see this big bigger battle I did
see a lot of push people push back
against Trump with his attacks uh and
and we see the scientists not answering
back so how do you see this kind of
unfolding because I see this as even you
know more of a bill of a bigger battle
than a lot of people are expecting well
I think I think the establishment would
love to see those two
um split it apart and then split the
base somehow I don't know how that would
end up but I know if like just just
picture this right fast forward we're in
a Republican primary and you're seeing
Donald Trump going head-to-head with
DeSantis in the middle of that primary
on the debate stage
just like thinking about that is like
where does that really go but is is is
that something I think this is the
question people have to ask themselves
and I know the answer you know the
answer is that something that the
establishment would want is that
something that the establishment on the
left and the right would love to see is
two populists destroying them each other
and splintering the base so that the
populist movement doesn't have the power
and the steam that it could have had you
know I don't know I and I don't know
whether I can't speak for Rhonda santis
I can't speak for Trump I just take a
look at this and I see it going in a
direction where it can become
problematic for people that want the
country just to be where they believe
now the bigger question is will the
party be stronger because of this like
iron sharpens iron will the two test
each other and really become the best
version of themselves in this larger
battle or will it weaken the park well I
think Florida would have to answer that
question because what what will happen
with the void in Florida with Rhonda
santis gone
what would that be yeah that will cause
a massive vacuum he's doing such an
amazing job and I talked to a lot of
Floridians that are influencers people
in the media it seems like a lot of them
want him to stay they want him there
he's an amazing Governor he's doing a
great job could he go another few years
continuing to build his resume for the
public for the people to be this rock
star populist that would just absolutely
destroy it if DeSantis can get in and
basically do what Trump is doing just be
uncontested in the Republican party is
that a better strategy going forward for
the populist movement let Trump just do
his final four years and then bring in
the next populace at least my opinion I
think that's I I think if Ron is going
to have any kind of chance of being
president ever it's going to be in 2024
and that's it I I think this is his time
I think it's his time more than ever and
I think this is why Trump is
preemptively launching attacks on him
because he understands DeSantis
represents a big political force that
threatens uh his his presidential uh
your hopes in 2024 as as we just saw
yesterday he was he was announcing that
he's going to be making another
announcement next week which most likely
will be that he's going to be running
for the president of the United States
and I think the Jabs there are
deliberate and I think there's going to
be a bigger fight I think DeSantis is
going to run because he has to run if he
wants to be president of the United
States and a lot of people told me but
listen
I just want to make I just want to I
just want to make one more point before
we you get to you know uh you know
rebuke what I'm saying here specifically
I'm gonna let you finish Taylor Swift
it's because specifically I've been
saying that this war is going to be
happening for a very long time I had
guests that came on here and said no way
it's not going to happen it's going to
be fine it's going to be cool and now
we're seeing the Jabs we're seeing the
infighting and I I would say I was wrong
on what a lot of people told me that I
was I was I was right on what a lot of
people were telling me I was wrong about
I think the Jabs are coming but don't
you think that it's
suspect that the whole establishment is
backing DeSantis like the pro what's
going to happen is Trump this is he
can't run again this would be his last
term he can go in there and destroy
everything that he needs to destroy and
go balls to the wall excuse my language
right but if you have DeSantis in there
who's backed by The Establishment and
all this money and all these donors that
are that are donating to him is he going
to give us more of the same the person
that we really need to back is Trump and
so that he can break it all down and yes
and is that but but I agree because as
much as I do think DeSantis is better in
a lot of ways if he does get elected
it's his first term and he'll be very
careful right and he's going to be like
just like Trump let's let's just get to
the first term and do what we can and
then really hit him hard in term two
whereas Trump will will come in with
term two and be like let's get it done
and then pave the way for DeSantis to
come in with a clean Road I I
respectfully disagree because when
Donald Trump lost he still had a couple
months in office where he could have
went balls to the wall
he knew that he lost why didn't he go
balls to the wall then
that's my question because he knew he
was going to run again and if he went
balls of all then he would lessen his
chances of being elected some weird
choices I gotta be honest yeah Hey
listen I thought he should have part
massage but absolutely the Assange thing
was a major thing he said he didn't know
who Assange was he was like who's a
sergeant I don't know a couple of couple
years before that I love Wikileaks now
he doesn't even claim to know who
Assange is come on now even even if he
didn't in those last few months the odds
of him going straight for it and and
going harder than DeSantis are way
greater people would have supported him
people would have clapped if he would
have pardoned Assange he would have
bridged a gap with the populist he would
have made a whole bunch of Bernie Bros
and a whole bunch of people who were
politically disenfranchised actually
hopeful in him in actually doing
something the way he treated his
supporters after January 6th I mean
that's a telling sign a lot of people
were felt like they were just kicked to
the curb here honestly all right Luke
let me ask you this political landscape
right what happens does would DeSantis
need Florida to win the presidency
um most presidents do okay if the Santa
this
this is why I don't know when DeSantis
was asked on the on the debate stage if
you get elected governor are you going
to stay as Governor or just go run for
president and like kind of like do a 180
on how you're and he didn't answer okay
so what happens to all those voters that
may be offended by that may kind of be
worried that there's a huge vacuum now
we needed you now you want us to vote
for president what happens to the state
I'm just asking hypothetically what what
what do you think that happens to those
voters I mean it depends who that might
be pissed off that he would need that
might not vote I don't know I'm just
thinking hypothetically I don't think
people would be that pissed off I think
he would appoint someone that is capable
of doing the job that is uh just as as
well as equipped as he is again I'm not
even that big of a DeSantis Fanboy
because I'm I don't even know his
foreign policy I'm very critical of some
of the things he actually implemented
and did in Florida but I think out of
the two we're seeing a a battle of ideas
that I think is worth testing I think
this battle a lot of people are trying
to avoid but I say let the best I ideas
win let them go at it I I think DeSantis
would win in a debate in a conversation
especially with all the ammunition that
he has but that's just my perspective
from what I'm seeing and either way even
if it's DeSantis I'm still going to be
critical of DeSantis myself to be
perfectly going honestly well why split
the party and go through all that drama
why can't he just stay and do a good job
at Governor like he's been doing let's
talk and there would be no DeSantis
without Trump anyway right like he's the
one that paved the way for this populist
movement he's the one that desensis
pretty much has all his mannerisms from
right like he's DeSantis is following
his lead why not let him carry out those
last two years and then go well before
that it was also the Tea Party it was
also individuals like Ron Paul that kind
of that kind of pushed it into the
perspective and made it where it is
today but but I think there's a lot of
people disenfranchised with the
political system
um so this is a part of the
establishment is the answer there well
Trump I would say is a part of of of of
another element of the establishment
especially when it comes to kind of big
Pharma so that's another aspect that we
do have to understand here with his kind
of support and push of that industry but
again we shouldn't make this a debate I
could respectfully disagree with you
guys this is just how I see it I guess
and I respect your guys's perspective
and you guys might be right I might be
wrong you know I like to push back on
you it's fine it's good yeah let's do it
I love it all right interesting
conversation I do have a story I do have
a story I want to pull up so we'll do
um we'll do a quick brief because we've
been going for almost two hours now so
my friends uh thanks for hanging out
we're gonna be hanging out probably till
I don't know we're gonna be here all
night I'm gonna be very tired but it'll
be fun because we're having good
conversations already so smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends we've got a
Rockin 76 000 people watching right now
you guys are awesome thanks so much for
hanging out tonight it's really exciting
so far it looks like that the uh the
Republicans have picked up two seats in
the house but we'll see how things are
going the New York Times says that it's
currently a toss-up we're still waiting
on tons of data it's early it's not even
9 p.m yet so we're waiting for a lot of
polls to close and we'll see how things
play out yeah what about the super chats
should we get into I want to get into
some super chats and I want to do a
round of everybody to shout stuff out
because like Mary pointed out you know
as we're moving in and out people want
to know socials so of course I want to
promote uh the song that we we produced
so check out losing my mind.com check
out the new song genocide by Tim cast
and if you really want to support us you
can purchase it it's a rebuke of the
establishment we got a CGI animation of
a bunch of news personalities to sing
lyrics about how they're evil and
they're Liars so we're really excited
for that and it looks like we're
trending on YouTube with your support
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast uh Luke you
you didn't get a chance to send anything
out because you joined late you want to
shout stuff out we'll go around and
everyone can introduce themselves well
thank you yeah I appreciate that to
where today I'm wearing a a very nice
political shirt that will definitely
have your neighbors talking it's a great
way to start a conversation at your
local bank or Supermarket this is a way
to make friends spur conversations and
hopefully make people think this is uh
you know a little bit of a of a strong
statement but I think a statement that
might make some people laugh if you like
the shirt you could get it on the best
politicalshirts.com because you do
that's why I'm here thank you again so
much for having me Ian Zenny came in
late what up homie I didn't have
anything really particular to shout out
tonight except genocide which you've
already brought up the new song Carter
Banks produced uh me and Tim and Carter
sang on it Pete Parada on drums just
spectacular drummer really the heartbeat
of that song So if you're having her
genocide check it out uh work on a
couple other projects upcoming I'll keep
them under the under the sheets until it
is time for the big reveal Drew
Hernandez of course is hanging out yes I
am the host of frontlines powered by
turning point USA on real America's
voice you guys can uh find all the links
to the show on my Twitter at Drew H live
I go live Monday through Friday live on
the network at uh forgot the time of my
own show uh 7 30 p.m Pacific that's 10
30 Eastern actually right after Tim pool
right on and of course Libby's here I'm
here I'm here I'm the editor with the
post millennial we're covering all of
these breaking results at the
postmillennial.com and you can check it
out so uh Serge of course press on all
the buttons okay I'm here still yeah we
had Mary here for bit she's out Lisa's
chilling over in the back with her
Carrie Lake hat on yeah where's Mary is
she coming back
yeah and people are in the chats are
like where's Mary we were listening oh
Owen is also here he's coming up right
now as well okay yeah cool cool all
right it's about time so we have a story
for you guys as we're waiting for more
results to come in about 10 more minutes
we might get uh some more updates
who wants to read that I'll just read it
Rolling Stone Trump keeps musing about
journalists being raped in prison he's
not joking I think it's funny to say
keeps music because then you say like
twice or I think he said it one time and
then said they should be arrested or
something I don't know how many times
did he say it you know well their story
is a knowledgeable Source tells Rolling
Stone that the former president has
wondered how he might be able to jail
reporters if he retakes the White House
somehow I literally just don't believe
this
do you guys think Trump is going around
being like how can I arrest all these
journalists how can I how can I do it
the guy who wouldn't send the military
to shut down the BLM riots that were
firebombing Federal buildings I think
this is election day propaganda to try
and get people to come out and vote
against Trump even though he's not
running wasn't Obama the one going after
journalists and he used the Espionage
more than any other president before him
collectively to use that law to go after
sources and journalists and punish them
in very cruel ways which sent a chilling
effect in many newsrooms that prevented
a lot of important stories from seeing
the day of light so I again what Obama
did is absolutely atrocious these
comments also light a light of day the
light of day I like dead day of life it
works too day of life two works thank
you Ian I appreciate you always having
my back on my Lucas white magic but more
specifically you know what Obama did is
disgusting these comments by Trump again
hyperbole also I don't like them I think
they should be pushed back Don but you
shouldn't be sensationalizing it and
just crying about it all stop when in
reality his record uh doesn't really
tell the record of what Obama did to
journalism I would even step back from
saying it's hyperbole because it's just
somebody reporting that someone else
said that he said it it's not even if
he's well he did say we were talking
about this on the show he said that in
order to find out who's leaking
information to journalists we should put
them in jail where a male prisoner
forces himself in an adult way on that
prisoner and that should be the way that
we should get the source of information
that is disgusting yeah he said that on
torture and no one that speaks like that
should have the office of President
that's disgusting okay but but guys I
have shocking news what is it what is it
with 50 reporting Stacy Abrams is losing
oh no
because she's down by about 90 000 votes
but you sit here and laugh and then you
know you knock on wood Because by the
end of the night you might be you know
by the end of the week it's by the end
of the week sure but my point is well
look we got a lot coming in from Blue
districts already from major cities so
it's looking like it's going to keep
swinging towards Kemp yeah Atlanta it
looks like it's mostly in Atlanta very
heavily and Augusta Savannah Columbus so
water pipe is gonna break it may it may
get called relatively soon but I just
want to make make sure everybody you
know don't do one of those things where
you're all like yeah we're the best we
win high-fiving and then when it swings
right at the last minute you're doing
The Young Turks thing where you're like
I know very well as a Cleveland Browns
fan from the 80s there you can always
fumble on the one yard line when you
think you're about to win the AFC
Championship there is the game is not
over until the clock hits zero I saw the
the unfortunately we don't know when the
clock's gonna hit zero for these
elections these days because they run
for a week they have to count the votes
I mean it's Insidious 3 A.M dude
Insidious what do we got here va7 yes
Lee Vega is currently up by about three
points 3.3 points so it's uh it's
looking good
oh what are you gonna say I was gonna
say Rafael Warnock is currently leading
with uh by about we're at seven points
in Georgia Senate so let's actually see
if we can pull up the uh the Senate map
here see how uh how many how many votes
are currently in in Georgia we got 42
reporting it looks like most of the
major Urban centers are in so this may
actually start flipping it's only about
a hundred and twenty thousand votes that
uh Herschel Walker will need to clear
no guarantees man it's a long shot for
Herschel Walker look man like I was
watching some videos of Walker and the
dude is I'm sorry I'm not trying to be
me he's not a smart man he's in battled
to say the least
so when you know we rag on fetterman I
do there's a difference between you know
Walker and not coming off as I'm not
going to say he's not a smart man I'm
saying he doesn't he doesn't speak well
he's not very articulate and so the
Assumption people have is he's not very
smart fetterman's got some serious
injuries man and that guy needs to needs
to chill but uh but we'll see I mean
yeah fetterman needs like a Rehab Clinic
you know it's kind of things where they
help you walk again before we change the
topic that's what you before we change
topics we're on the topic of Georgia we
just got a 50 Super Chat from zoelle
Bliss who's talking about this situation
and he said salutations from Georgia I
work in the Atlanta area and noticed
today that a lot of businesses are
closed and boarded up also a lot of
local homeless people I know are missing
from the usual spot something's up PS
hiring field reporters question mark so
that's a 50 super chats that we just
supporters eventually but yeah we saw
the boarding up in Portland I wonder if
they're just preparing for uh some
Shenanigans and some chaos some riots
sorry I cut off the conversation with
Perry Lake hat it's a great hat it is
she came here and dropped hats
everywhere they're littered all over the
house like everywhere I go there's a
carry Lake I saw up there and I was like
I'm immediately putting this on her
shirt you could you could have it
because they're everywhere in the house
it looks great on you thanks her shirt
she gave me is the most comfortable
t-shirt I own really I won't wear it on
the show because it's like a it's like a
campaign yeah it's a campaign you know
I'd be like rather fetching in that hat
you're welcome thanks well I am
promoting
we are we are honored enough to have an
autographed carry like hat I think it's
downstairs though because we like to
show it off because Carrie lake is the
best she's the best I am such a big fan
I agree so what I was about to say about
fetterman really quick and we can change
this topic is that if someone were to
sustain an injury like that as the
president you would use the 25th
Amendment to take him out of office
clearly they're not doing that already I
mean how many times are they going to
take mentally like deficient people and
prop them up this is happening like
we've they've been doing it with Biden
for what a year and a half two years now
we knew that he needed to be in a mental
home and not the White House
and and now they're doing it with better
men how many of these candidates are we
going to keep doing this it's
the increasing collectivization of the
left
and but aren't there like laws against
like elder abuse and uh like disabled
abuse because that's what's happening to
these people they are exploiting them
they are abusing both of them I swear
that's that's what I believe I think
that Joe Biden is abusing Joe and I
think that just everybody Joe Federman
seems like she's the one who's really
itching for power here correct yeah yeah
I think that they're probably I mean
confedermen could hardly be itching for
power after living in his parents
basement and not having a job like
that's not an ambitious man no Jill it
strikes me she's in a lot of pain about
what Joe's going through the way he they
asked some reporter asked Joe are you
going to run again how does your wife
feel about it and you could just see the
pain in Joe's eyes like she thinks that
it's Gotta that we gotta do the like
it's we're making this sacrifice
together and and you could tell like it
is not good in their family life right
now neither of them are happy about it I
think she's the one pushing him though
you think so yeah
I don't think it's that she loves it
she's the one that's like going to
Philly's games all like oh the First
Lady
yeah she got booed out of that stadium
and then they took it off everywhere
they wouldn't let you post it on
Instagram they wouldn't let you post it
on YouTube like part of me he likes it
the Deep conspiratorial part of me
thinks that there's like alternate
cultures that are trying to control the
United States government now with this
giant culture War we've experienced this
culture shock Global culture shock Rin
and that they're willing to put disabled
or uh destroyed people into power to
watch the system tank plus there's a lot
of money invested in these elections
we're talking about hundreds of millions
of dollars if not billions of dollars
there's estimates that ad campaigns for
this campaign cycle were up to 6.4
billion dollars George Soros decided to
spend 128.5 million dollars on this
midterm election is he going to get a
result well I think on the national
level no but I want to see what kind of
uh what kind of races and elections he's
focusing on and financing when it comes
to District Attorneys I want to see
those races I think those races are
going to be very important to see where
particular cities are going to be going
and money talks and we got to understand
here with fetterman specifically there
has been so much money behind that man
there's a big political machine behind
that man that probably is standing there
and saying I don't care how sick you are
I don't care how tired you are I don't
care how out of Health you are I don't
care what you're going to be going
through you're going to keep running
because we put so much money in this
you're going to have to do what we tell
you to do and I think he's a perfect
candidate of the multinational
corporations just like Biden because
they're they're empty vessels that again
are just told what to do and they follow
orders very well because sadly they're
not uh you know doing well physically
and mentally
it's still abuse and somebody needs to
pay the consequences for that is it
actually is it illegal like I mean I
know abuse of all kinds can be illegal
but like to push an elderly person with
this demented and I'm sure that they're
like pumping them full of medicine and
things like the other day where his hand
had the track marks it looked like there
was IV marks in his hand and it was sort
of disturbing to see that it just looked
like a a puncture wound it's a couple of
them yeah yeah you're not supposed to
you know IVs in your hand are painful
yeah you're usually supposed to take
them you know in in your arms I mean
like collapsed veins is almost
impossible to get them in yeah yeah so
it's like what's he doing every weekend
when he heads home oh Gretchen Whitmer
is currently leading but you know we're
still waiting a lot of results so I
don't want to say too much
but we will see in Michigan I don't
think they have the uh actually I'm in
the wrong spot
here we go Michigan we've got seven
percent reporting Whitmer is of course
in the lead but this is areas of Lansing
and Detroit for the most part we do have
a bunch of red counties but you know
City Air City counties reporting are
going to be way more Democrat well what
about what about Florida where did Miami
go because I mean when red uh wow I mean
I'm pretty sure Miami's red yeah Miami's
Red Bro it was 30 points for Hillary yo
he's 11. he is DeSantis is currently
with 46 reporting he's 11 points up in
Miami
wow that's crazy dude Tampa went
completely red you've got you've got
Pinas County and you've got Hillsborough
County both both for DeSantis
that's amazing yeah but I wonder what
Orlando know you know oh Jacksonville
went red yeah there it is man
DeSantis winning Urban centers is a
sight to behold yeah that's pretty wild
yeah you know
after watching what happened in the UK
with that huge Victory then remember
that it was like apocalyptic there were
areas that hadn't voted conservative for
100 years that turned conservative
totally swapped and then you see what
happens you know with Boris did not go
well for them so a conservative yeah I'm
not super confident but we'll see you
know it's you know we're chilling ladies
and gentlemen Owen Cook is in the house
he's here he's chilling he's taking a
step out for a little bit about it I
like your beard by the way
I said also I want to wish a happy
birthday to Renee Banks Mrs Banks I know
you're out there listening Carter's
mother you're a wonderful woman I've
still never met you congratulations on
your beautiful family and if you're
anywhere near as cool as Carter then I
know you're doing it right happy
birthday thanks for making him so that
he could bring him on board with us I
also want to add someone who super
chatted us we have uh Wrath of Paul
saying CNN's reporting Walker is ahead
by 77 votes oh my goodness with the
latest data coming in so decision desk
appears to be a little bit behind uh
we'll see you know we're using decision
desk but maybe you could switch to um
something more up to date I don't know
what's the New York Times that's what I
used to use like I like the times yeah
what is this look at the New York Times
says we're looking into an issue with
our estimates in Louisiana we plan to
turn the needle back on soon what is
that about what's going on here man oh
and cook who are you and what do you
make of what's happening right now
great intro I'm back uh back again today
thanks for um having me back on so I run
seminars and
um the reason that you and I became
friends Luke is because we both like to
do crazy stuff so I got to know you
because I admire your work and how many
people Luke understand the crazy stuff
that you did before you did Tim cast
that watch Tim cast I have no idea
there's been a lot of wacky crazy stuff
that me and Tim got involved in as well
uh you know travel over the world
yeah that was that was not not smart but
we're gonna get that we did it yeah yeah
but like does your audience understand
what gangsters you and Tim are like do
they get it or do they think you just
kind of chill at the table like do they
understand your background well Luke
still does more field reporting than I
do some crazy stuff and Luke is just I
mean I'm I'm afraid for him
raise yourself longer than me and still
does and I'm mostly in indoors these
days yeah so so I'm also a world
traveler I run seminars all over the
world I run free seminars all over the
world I post them on YouTube on personal
growth how to make cash how to have
better social relationships how to get
more spiritually tapped in we talk a lot
about the spiritual war that's kind of
going on beneath the surface of the
political stuff so it's a common thing
that we'd like to talk about well you do
a lot of work on the ground specifically
and I wanted to talk to you in the
garden Ted bud just took the lead in
North Carolina decision desk reporting
yeah
Republican is now up by about 5 000
votes so uh with with it hitting nine
o'clock we're getting a bunch of updates
fetterman's still leading blah blah blah
we'll see what is this we got uh
official Paul gosar has won in Arizona
uh 09 for a GOP hold okay there you go
oh is this shocking everyone
ocasio-cortez has won
the call has in everybody knew that was
going to happen how many votes ilhan
Omar has won Chuck Schumer has one there
it is surprise I was wrong I was rooting
for Joe pinging in that but I mean we'll
see with Zelda I'll take a look at where
we're at with New York yeah where's the
race on that because that's going to be
a very big one and I think the main area
of focus there is going to be of course
crime which oh and you had to deal with
you know two nights ago when you first
watched something so by the way I was
talking about the gunshot thing but
everybody thought that it was La it was
actually at Surfside tacos last night in
DC there was a bunch of gunshots going
off well that's why because you were
talking about shootings and Surfside
tacos
yeah I'm hearing from the uh zeldin from
a source at zeld at zeldon's campaign
that
um they think they're gonna know by
uh New York's 11 by 10 o'clock oh if
they won are they giving any yeah New
York's 11. who's that if that's a
blowout they're saying that's a good
sign
um I'll be wins and they're they're
having a lot of good reporting back from
from Brooklyn they're seeing the numbers
that they want to see so well that's
because of the Hasidic Jewish Community
actively taking part in in that election
and getting their whole Community
because like they've been taking it on
the chin well there's a very strong uh
you know Jewish Hasidic Community that's
very big in Brooklyn and I've seen them
politically activated now especially
when it comes to uh heshi he was on the
show before I forgot his last name I'm
so sorry uh what's it teschler Tesla
heshi teschler he was on the show he was
one of these awesome individuals in the
Hasidic Jewish community that said
enough is enough of these lockdowns of
these restrictions of these mandates and
came up to the public parks and opened
them up just got a crowbar and said
screw these stupid policies children
deserve to be in Parks closing down
Parks all in the name of Public Safety
was absolutely stupid I remember during
the pandemic I'd ride my bike around and
the only people I'd see out were Hasidic
Jews the only kids who were out playing
and they were arrested all right so it
looks like Reuters map is is much more
up to date oh let's go with that yeah
this is way better we can see in North
Carolina Ted Budd has taken the lead
with about what is he up 0.4 he's up 12
000 votes so let's keep it going that's
that's a really good look yeah seems
like with what's been reported so far
it's going to continue to skew red but
we will see we will see 68 reporting oh
this Reuters map is way better
way way better oh we could do that too
we can atomize that's that's fantastic
Reuters is one of the things I
consistently track
honestly more than eight we got uh
Warnock currently up they say by about
five points just well 4.6 uh is that
what am I doing my math wrong four point
four points sorry so uh he's a leading
in Georgia we'll see we got we've got
preliminary data all coming across the
board fetterman with 12 reporting has a
huge lead but that's meaningless and in
New Hampshire we've got 26 reporting
Maggie is on his leading ball duck but
also 26 reporting it's a bit worthless
North Dakota
five percent reporting we've got Hoven
is currently in the lead but you know
five percent zero percent in Iowa so I
guess we'd have to wait Maryland what's
this
with zero percent reporting currently
there's 13 votes in for Chris Chaffee
he's got one vote one vote above Chris
Van Hollen but I don't think that's
gonna go I like those numbers if only we
lived he lived in a place where seven
people voted I think the world would be
a better place but that's Mark Wayne
Mullen won the Oklahoma special election
and uh this is for this is a special
election for Senate I guess
against Kendra horn they're calling it
yeah so some of these these have already
been Alabama's been called Katie Britt
Indiana's been called Todd Young
Kentucky Rand Paul obviously we called
that earlier or we cited to them calling
it and then that's what we've got going
on for governorship Vermont they call it
for Phil Scott is that is that
predictable I don't know enough about
Vermont's politics Vermont is pretty
much blue are you sure yeah yeah they're
saying that Phil Scott won in Vermont
that's where Bernie Sanders comes from
is that yeah but I know he's independent
but is that a flip then for Vermont yes
really yeah wow
well okay then I'll pull up some more
data on that it looks like spanberger
might be going down in Virginia in
Congress
oh really yeah that's interesting we'll
track the house and we will she was she
was pro-child sex changes yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah was she the one who came out and
said a drag queen for every school uh I
believe that was actually someone in
Michigan oh okay okay yeah weird thing
that weird thing to say I think that was
Michigan's AG I could have that wrong
because that would be a random fact for
me to actually have in my head but it
might be true yeah by the way we're
doing really well on the numbers we have
74 75 000 people watching live right now
The Young Turks by the way they're doing
election coverage 12 000 people watching
uh you know that's but but still you
know I I think it does show a shift
because tyt again is it was one of the
major focuses it's it's one of the major
channels that YouTube promotes when it
comes to politics they have a channel on
YouTube TV exactly so so yeah you know I
think I think this also you know matters
but this is actually we don't even have
all those places we don't even have all
the fancy charts have you guys been
watching the shift for The Young Turks
uh Jack euger who said he was gonna
interview Matt Gates on his show and
they all got mad at him I think I think
Jack sees the Line in the Sand that he
sided with a cult that is not in touch
with the average working American person
I just saw them interview Matt Gates I'm
watching I'm watching The Stream right
now just just so you're one of those
10th at 12 000. one of those 12 000
people is me and Matt Gates was on I was
like wait this is a glitch or something
against stiff on the police they were in
favor of it during the George Floyd
that's what somebody was saying in our
Twitter spaces today right that we that
apparently I guess Annika sparian or
whatever the the reason that she got all
of a sudden like anti-crime was because
she was assaulted by and she's not
saying this publicly but like a homeless
guy and he was grabbing her and whoa
trying to do stuff to her yes so that's
a rumor though well I I I feel sources
knowledgeable sources have said is that
now apparently there's like articles and
stuff about it and so you know um Sean
from um
actual Justice Warrior he's like he's
pulling the police report wow to to get
more details on it well I I think when
you when you look at where Jenkins has
been going over the past several months
I think they finally started to realize
that they were pandering to a a
principal-less rage mob that doesn't
bring you anywhere sound and regular
people who have families who have kids
they're concerned about whether or not
their kids are going to have good lives
whether they can pay the bills whether
they can pay their rent whether they can
buy gas whether their kids will not be
receiving explicit material in schools
and The Young Turks were going for all
the bad stuff all the wrong stuff but
notoriously crime yeah they supported
defund the police changed their money
good for them I don't I don't I don't
fault them for changing their mind it's
the right thing to do but I think what I
Luke brought up their numbers and said
it's part of a bigger shift I think it's
a good point I'm not saying this to rag
on them but after a certain point when
you Pander to a rage mob eventually
you're left holding an empty bag and now
they've got very few viewers relatives
not just us I mean Charlie Kirk's got
more viewers Stephen Crowders got double
the viewership we do and that's on
rumble of all places he would have been
probably getting half a million if he
was on YouTube but they gave him a
strike rumble's very busy right now by
the way lots of viewers lots of people
going there on there as well uh from
what I'm just seeing there but I I do
believe that there is a larger shift
because this was the channel That was
mainly promoted by YouTube working with
them as an official partner getting all
the recommendations getting an upper
hand when it came to the algorithm
algorithm let's be honest here and and
still you know I think the numbers do
speak for themselves at the end of the
day so to what extent do you think
YouTube picks uh winners and losers 100
I I they absolutely do it it's through
their algorithm it's through their
personal connections it's through
individuals that they may personally
like or the individuals that play Within
the kind of confines of what they want
people playing in so you know I I think
they have certain rules we never trend
so where where this this show is never
featured in like live channels live
shows we've we've had videos that have
gotten I mean recently we had a video
get like a million views or something
did not appear on trending and this is
like a million views overnight we
launched a new channel where we're doing
music we put up our first video and we
got like I don't know six or seven
hundred thousand views in a day it's
number 23 on trending all of all YouTube
and it's funny because it's like there's
a new Channel with a video that gets you
know half a million Trends instantly we
put out a video clip talking politics
hits even more views no trending at all
it's just very obvious that YouTube is
like this is what we want people to see
this is what we don't want them to see
it really is them picking winners and
losers yeah that's the trending tab the
trending tab is someone at YouTube
saying I like this I like this I don't
like this it used to be in in the in the
good old days in the wild west of the
internet you had Google video you even
had YouTube video Implement a system
where oh your video is the most viewed
here's a list of the top viewed videos
here's a here's a list of the top
commented videos the most liked videos
uh in politics or entertainment or
comedy or cooking or or wherever it was
and this of course gave the rise of a
lot of Independent Media figures
including myself that used to get Awards
on my YouTube channel saying hey you're
the most commented YouTube channel uh of
all news and politics today and that was
huge because people were able to find me
and people were actually able to to see
what they wanted to see and now YouTube
Took an opposite approach saying we need
to curate who gets popular who doesn't
who plays with uh who plays by the rules
and who doesn't Yeah so basically
YouTube is to some YouTube and a couple
other platforms has kind of monopolized
the energy right so for example we used
to have an independent site and I would
do I mean it's not crazy but I used to
do maybe 30 000 views just on my own Hub
okay this was back before 2006 okay and
so now if I were to have that Hub it
would probably do 200 views or 500 views
or something like that right so it's
kind of a monopoly and I think this is
where the discussion gets messed up is
like oh well it's a private company but
they don't understand it's actually a
monopoly right like you can't just run
your own website anymore I mean you can
and you guys are doing it but it's
difficult and um I'd be curious if you
guys think that Rumble is actually going
to start to scoop up
um that kind of content if they're going
to make any Headway with it well I'll
tell you I just checked Crowders got 300
000 live viewers yeah that means I mean
compare him to The Young Turks sorry
look I'm not trying to be mean to The
Young Turks but twelve thousand so so
we've got 74 000 we're a talk show we're
not I think you know he's probably got a
bigger crew he does this stuff better
than we do so he's also doing it on
Rumble too so right like isn't he isn't
his rubble's smaller than YouTube yeah
but so it's like all the people that
prefer Rumble are just going straight to
him though too it's not it's not this
first not that I'm denigrating
hold on hold on bannon's got 65 000
viewers we have a fries got 18 000
rocata's got 10K Charlie Cook's at 62.
so it's not that there's a rumble is
very very active YouTube I think is
starting to realize that they've been
shooting themselves in the foot by with
their policies yo think about this they
gave Crowder a strike so that he would
not or or for whatever reason but now he
because of it he couldn't be on YouTube
so rumble's getting all of that traffic
that has to be one of the worst business
decisions you've ever made for what The
Young Turks The Young Turks look I'm not
trying to be a dick to jenk but they've
got like 10 12K viewers and they're
doing midterm coverage they're a
featured Channel when you buy YouTube TV
this is what we use on all our TVs for
Digital streaming I get YouTube TV and
The Young Turks is a channel just like
Fox News and they're only getting 12K
this is what YouTube deserves they
deserve to lose in their business for
for the for the dirty games they play so
what does Chris pavlovski have have to
do to take it over the top to get Rumble
to that next level do you think well the
challenge is one of the reasons a lot of
these shows are doing really well right
now Rumble is Rumble is overtly
political refugees they really need to I
think focus on attracting apolitical
Talent comedy entertainment and shows
but it seems like their big strategy was
to go to podcasters and you know
political commentary and it's like it's
good you know politics is pop culture
right now so it's a smart move but you
need something wider than that that's
why c will do it just went over there
yes he got banned well there you go I
mean but there's people there right so
we have 300 000 Subs on on our timcast
IRL Rumble Channel and uh my personal
Channel and then I got another Channel
70k but we just moved everything to one
Consolidated and I look at some of the
videos and they get between five and ten
thousand views a lot less than what I
get on YouTube I get 200 to 300
sometimes even 500 how about the one you
do it during BD
yeah that that was that was uh taken off
of YouTube for uh censorship reasons and
it was put onto Rumble where it got like
2.3 million which I believe was our
biggest podcast until we did Alex Jones
and Joe Rogan why did you get so many
with Darren do you think on Rumble
that's from Darren Beatty from
revolver.news if anyone screws why do
you think that you keep promoted me he
promoted it yeah you think that was the
big reason that it popped off two two
reasons one was that Darren Beatty
promoted the show saying you know
censorship is impacting us and uh that
factor of like the show was taken down
we want to see it so I think the big
thing holding back Rumble is that if and
this is just personal opinion I'm not an
expert on this but I feel like that they
just made it look more like YouTube as
close as they could get it to YouTube
without being YouTube and having maybe a
legal problem because do you guys even
know what is a rumble like I can't even
figure this out I've been around like
when it says you have like a thousand
rumbles yeah it's like you have this
many likes and so you don't know what a
rumble is I don't know what a rumble is
does anybody here know what a rumble is
no idea it's like an upvote almost I
think it might be like a link share or
something I don't know okay I think
they're calling uh they're calling Texas
for Apple yeah it looks like beta went
down yeah they don't Beto lost yeah this
can't be accurate no way isn't this like
the same people don't want to be
disarmed people don't want government
controlling every aspect of their lives
he realizes people just don't want him
they just don't want him people don't
want open borders in Texas what by the
way Tim Vermont's still blue
Vermont is still blue yeah like it was
blue I don't know what you were looking
at but they're no the governor race on
Reuters has Vermont called for the
Republican oh really yeah it was 16
reporting wait Vermont Vermont yeah wait
is that surprising Governor Phil Scott
Republican
it says he's the incumbent hey there's
your free state project it's just right
now no that's that's New Hampshire yeah
pay attention I know but I'm just saying
just saying for governor right you could
just what are you looking right next
door
legalized heroin and everything in
Vermont isn't that what they have
um no it's not hilarious I don't think
they have legalized here really all
right New Hampshire Governor they're
calling it for Chris but that's New
Hampshire Vermont I don't yeah Phil
Scott was the Republican incumbent
Governor from Vermont so them going
Republican is not that surprising yeah
yeah I thought it was the
Ohio is now leaning towards JD Vance
with 45 in so that's that's he's up by
uh point six point six percent I thought
it was interesting he got a Tulsi
gabbard's endorsement that was cool yeah
and it's looking like the big cities are
mostly in well okay no that's not so
much but we'll see 31 41 Dayton's at 44
so we'll see
will be interesting to say the least but
yep is that what we're hearing that uh
they called it for for Abbott Beto's out
yeah that's what it's looking like news
Nation called it for sure fetterman has
taken an early lead on odds that's
something well I guess is it
Philadelphia and Pittsburgh so
Philadelphia has a lot in already
they were saying that Philadelphia was
going to hold back a bunch of ballots
right weren't they saying that yes but
um they I think it was like 83 in and
they it leans very heavy
that I mean it's usually it's like 95 of
the vote there yeah yeah yeah so even if
it is I mean that's still a win in
Philly I think if you get like 80 if
it's only 80 percent
why do you guys think a guy as talented
as Dr Oz couldn't take on
um fetterman because fetterman put a
billboard up during the Eagles game that
said Oz is a Giants fan not a Giants fan
of Dallas fan that's fine that's what he
did no he really did it was like genius
and everybody was calling it out of
stupid but every anybody that likes any
Philly sports would tell you that that
was like why did they run Beto and Stacy
Abrams I don't know they're like these
people are losers let's run them they
lost last time so they're doing it yeah
they have though like honestly
I mean it's pretty interesting like
they're most of the political Talent
right now I think is on the conservative
side there are some talented politicians
on the uh on the Democratic side like I
think you know I think Tim you and I
maybe disagree with this but I think AOC
is pretty charismatic and relatively
talented as a politician she keeps
winning you think I disagree with you on
that do you did you disagree with me on
that no I feel like we disagreed on that
like maybe a year ago maybe maybe it was
somebody else in a beach I just got an
image academically Smart Way
from the conversation about who's next I
just got an image of the democratic
party going around intensive care units
in the hospital and nursing homes being
like who else are we going to get who
else can we pick here please we need
somebody to please represent us so you
could be the empty shell that of course
pushes the great reset agendas and of
course screws everyone over let me tell
you what really what what grinds my
gears y'all right now 36 of expected
votes are be have been counted and
that's 45
000 for Alexandria Casio Cortez and only
14 206 for Tina Forte
and that means that AOC will have won
the seat of congress with about a
hundred and thirty hundred thirty five
thousand votes in a district of 770
000 in a district with an estimated 180
000 conservatives or Republicans
so if there was maximum GOP turnout a
republican would have won um
people don't vote and you know
conservatives don't really well the GOP
work either they don't go there and tell
people to vote because they don't think
it's worth it and then you get these
days for sure with the zeldin campaign
right like I know for months some of the
some of the journalists that I know in
New York were like why isn't anyone
covering zeldon they would pitch stories
on zeldon and outlets and be like eh he
doesn't have a chance and they wouldn't
take the stories
it was only recently it was only within
like the past month that anyone was
willing to run zelding zeldon content
I'm feeling confident on on balduck but
we'll see we have a bunch of we have uh
Manchester Portsmouth and Concord are
reporting and then a bunch of the more
rural areas uh less so but there are a
lot of blue ones so uh you know we'll
see we'll see
we will see man I I'd be interested to
see Portsmouth is so expensive like I
was looking at apartments there at one
point and it was like I may as well just
move to Manhattan it's a no difference
yeah oh and you've been all around the
United States you work with people
one-on-one individually what do you
think is the cause the issue that people
care about the most is it the economy is
it crime what do you see with the pulse
of this country and and where it's going
I think where it's going it's going to
be economic yeah the the economy thing
is terrifying actually yeah you know it
should be for anyone paying attention I
think it should be but I think I mean
maybe I'm stuck in like lives of tick
tock world but I definitely think that
it's the gender stuff I mean even when I
talk to people on the street that's all
they're talking about I think it's good
it's gone too it's going to become
economic if we go into a downturn
and I think it's pretty clear we're
heading towards uh potentially some very
bad times financially potential not for
sure potential it could be very I think
their writing's on the wall I I think
it's pretty clear when when you print so
much money when you have such Reckless
policies that prioritize the ESG over
you know capitalism and freedom when you
have so many subsidies when you have so
much finagling by the by the
multinational corporations essentially
running governments and allowing them to
do what they want when you have such out
of control Financial policies I think
it's only headed down One Direction what
happened in 2008 was a warning shot and
it was something that we should have
taken seriously we should have let big
businesses and big Banks fail we never
did we paved over a big bubble with a
bigger bubble and I think that bubble is
you know going to pop eventually when
it's going to pop I don't know but I
think a lot of people are are fearing it
I think it's looming I think it's there
and I think there's no way we could
ignore the elephant in the room when it
comes to the larger Financial
ramifications of these Reckless policies
that have brought us here yeah the 2008
and we sold out American Youth in favor
of pumping up big businesses it was
really a crime yeah the Federal Reserve
we need Ian in here Federal Reserve Ian
we were talking about it Luke do you
think that it was deliberate that they
printed that much money
um I mean it doesn't make any sense I I
remember talking to Ben Bernanke after
2008 and I actually snuck in with Paul
volcker and got into this private VIP
area and I saw Ben Bernanke sitting
there and I walked up to him with my
microphone and I was like Mr Bernanke
how does it feel engineering one of the
world's largest secretive Banker
bailouts to some of the biggest
International Banks all over the world
that no one even knows about it
he got so flustered he got so pissed off
he grabbed my microphone and tried to
literally steal it out of my head and
was up in arms calling and screaming for
security people don't know about the
secret bailouts in 2008. those secret
bailouts were still going on and
probably still are going on right now
during covid they will have grave
implications on our entire economic
system and then when he got really
uncomfortable when security came they
had to literally pick me up lift me lift
me out of there and I was like okay we
could talk about Bilderberg if that's
another topic that you want to discuss
here he got even more mad because this
was my third confrontation with him
where we got face to face and we're
screaming at each other those old videos
that you posted are some of the most
insane things I've ever seen on the
internet they were fun they were very
excited so yeah and this is really crazy
because
Luke is the guy who just went and did it
yeah he just walked up to these people
asking questions he just hopped on a
boat with tapstein Island and started
filming everything it's about
persistence you want something you could
get it in life if you really you know
put if you were on Epstein Island oh God
I love it I was like I go like this is
Luke uh he's been Epstein Island I don't
want to go uh uh yeah
I'm not Bill Clinton I'm not a pervial
okay but you were there yes I did go to
episode I have to talk later
I wasn't invited I wasn't invited I I
crashed it and the video is completely
insane how do you crash you take a boat
and you and you go there I would have
done that and I started searching and I
started searching for tunnels it's like
where's the tunnels where's all the hits
I found a door that goes into the ground
on top of the the biggest hill there but
it's a huge area it's it's I I was
running throughout the whole space and I
only got to see half of it is that
creepy Castle thing fake no it's real
it's painted yeah uh so it looks uh like
it's a like it's a big castle but but no
it's real it's up there but the the
walls were boarded up I was trying to
get in there I was trying to rip it
apart
um it didn't have the tools I used to
legit worry about you bro like I I've
never under like the things that you do
could get you killed you know you know
what's what's the mentality behind that
you can get killed you could get killed
walking down the street you could get
cut sure but they're gonna get killed in
a car accident I understand bro but the
things that you've done like some of
these videos as your as your friend when
I'm watching you online like you'll see
Luke in a gas mask in the middle of a
Hong Kong protest and he's like let's go
in and and it's going off yeah you know
I mean he's done you've how much danger
do you think you put yourself and
attempted as well to write a lot of
craziness especially in Vegas
was probably a bad idea it was a bad
idea but the thing is I mean what you're
talking about in terms of taking taking
the the horse by the reins doing things
yourself learning how to do it on your
own terms I think that that's something
that we're really missing this is
something I've been giving a lot of
thought to
um in New York and you know just sort of
in life in general in this country is we
are constantly fighting for Access if
you look at what people are saying in
terms of like you know oppression or you
know wanting more
um wanting more for their group
specifically like that's what's going on
is we're saying we're always like trying
to get access to everything like let me
get this piece of equality let me get
this piece of equity or whatever instead
of stepping up and saying I have two
hands I'm gonna build something I'm
gonna make it for myself they're calling
Colorado for Jared paulus or paulus or
whatever you say his name but this one
was fairly obvious I mean he's like 30
points up with 42 reporting Ian heard
about the Federal Reserve so he had to
come up here and he just got in here but
but in short I I could get up I could
you could take my spot if you want if
you want to be here you want to be here
Libby or do you want to uh
my kids here and he wants me
go get snacks okay well come back after
we got a whole big thing bring them back
up here yeah I'm gonna go hang out with
my kid for a little see what happens we
grilled like 50 kielbasas and farm fresh
hot dogs what we did today was also also
great we should talk about that uh also
bring back Scary Mary scary Mary and
ghost girl get her get her back up here
uh we were talking about the Federal
Reserve But to answer your question is I
I had someone very close to me die when
I was very young when I was about 21.
that was a pivotal moment in my life
that made me realize how short life is
and how if you don't live life to the
fullest life is just going to pass you
by it was absolutely tragic what
happened to someone very close to me and
I was like there's no way and he was
very young and I'm like there's no way
uh you know I got to do this for him I
got to do this for my family and growing
up in Poland and communism and I could
keep going on Tim's trying to get me to
stop and I'm gonna try to go English
back the needle is back and the Senate
toss up over the New York Times it
started skewing slightly more back
towards the center it was leaning left a
little bit call their toss up now it's
leaning right a little bit and uh
leaning Republican 75 chance of control
for the house and we're just chilling
usually on the hour we get more updates
and as we're waiting for the West Coast
that might not be till way late so we'll
you know we'll go as long as we can go
Ian will there be a financial collapse
oh I heard you guys talking about that
I'm glad you were oh we're talking about
the Federal Reserve in the large I was
actually thinking about the bubble you
guys were talking about a bubble within
a bubble and I thought you know
scientifically you could put a sieve in
a bubble a really tiny tiny needle and
then slowly draw the pressure out of the
the bubble without popping it until
there is no more bubble so technically
we could deflate the economy and
stabilize things how what's the policy
what's the fiscal policy that represents
you would need when it comes to the
Federal Reserve printing money out of
thin air I I one way to do it would be
to transition away from Fiat cash into a
cryptocurrency that is calculable
digital like a central bank digital
currency no decentralized current
digital currency that's that's built
into the currency that it deflates
itself you scared me there Phil I want
to say I think one one good thing is we
haven't heard of any crazy violence we
do have this uh tweet from festive
holiday cluster
says an election official in Milwaukee
apparently made a racial slur against
two Republican observers whom I know
personally and are both calm and in
concert with a democratic Observer
called doj observers over to attempt to
falsify voter intimidation claims
okay hopefully that's as far as it goes
because this is what
you know effectively the bulwark and
others were suggesting could happen as
people start challenging each other
but it looks like we're going to get
through this day without without
anything too crazy I mean uh they're
boarding up Windows in certain parts of
the country but that's for the aftermath
the big concern is what happens if
during the election violence breaks out
so
we will see we will see well that's
something we're trying to keep a close
eye on and luckily things haven't
escalated luckily things stayed cool and
calm throughout the entire country and
we haven't seen any kind of acts of
violence which is great which is good
and I think we need more de-escalation
when it comes to our political circus
that we're all kind of involved in
there's been a lot of nonsense there's
been a lot of idiocy there's been a lot
of just ignorant stupid low impulse
control actions that have uh endangered
all of us political I want to shout out
Bridget fedesy with The Spectator quote
calling it now the Democrats are running
Beto and Abrams in 2024. it's just just
so insane how they're gonna they're
gonna do this
I don't know who do they have name name
one person Oprah and
Oprah and Michelle that's what I think I
think they're gonna run and then that's
it I mean I mean beta house can you beat
them we got donut operator beta work
tweeted hell yes we're gonna take your
air 15 in uh September of 2019 and then
he he just tweeted good luck he's not
gonna take anything now thank goodness
but he's gonna take a nap yeah he's
gonna take a nap I think he's the I
think he's the Democratic nominee for
2024 really yeah but how they had he has
nothing to run on where's the experience
where's him being in some kind of
political office where he made a
difference what can he run on other than
Iran and lost and was embarrassed they
might run him along with a bunch of
other people like they did like who
Stacy Abrams again they lost
um Pete bootage Maybe
by Buddha judge though it's like they
they stop making you know because he
already ran but the diversity yeah he
doesn't they've attacked him for it the
woke have attacked him for being a white
cisman
he's like a token candidate
well they already ran him once but he
ran he's gay but that doesn't mean
anything to the whoa crowd he is a white
cisgendered man they were like we don't
care about that doesn't do anything for
us he's got he's got no experience he
disappeared for a little while he has no
Charisma he's like you know look Newsom
is b-list you look at Newsom and you're
like I can kind of understand that he's
got that like you know slick kind of
suit wearing Democrat Vibe but he
doesn't reach that level like Obama did
and then you look at Pete bootyjet
you're like bro he's he's like w he's
like so far down the list he's a small
town mayor what are they doing and Oprah
Michelle Oprah Obama I see maybe yeah I
mean who else I think I think this is
also an argument for why DeSantis could
be a better candidate than Trump because
I think that sometimes people go to vote
against Trump yeah we were that
conversation about Trump and uh going
head-to-head with the sanus earlier made
me nervous because and you actually
brought up his the way he let the
pharmaceutical industry take over the
coveted narrative rushed this
experimental vaccine through gave fauci
the podium and like carte blanche is
really concerning to me I he did the
opposite of what DeSantis stood behind
and DeSantis stood behind a record of
not going into any of this bull crap and
I think that's going to be the biggest
difference desantes is like Trump
without NPD
could be yes NPD I know you narcissistic
person I think Trump's hilarious like I
will watch Trump for hours laughing
until I Cry he's so funny one of the
funniest guys I've ever seen but I think
he may have NPD to be honest so so
Rebecca Jones was running against Matt
Gates did she really expect to beat Matt
Gates
she lost
she's got a criminal trial coming up
whatever but they called that it's just
like did they really you think you're
gonna beat Matt Gates that's ridiculous
come on and and you know I'll concede
Trump absolutely hilarious a genius word
Smith he's awesome and when he's on
stage he's a master orienter like like
the way he could move
Oriental potato but but he's really good
at aligning the podium and like yeah
yeah oriented he's also going to go down
I think we'll appreciate him more when
he passes he's gonna go down as a living
legend imagine looking at him in 300
years from now these old speeches that
he did he's going to go down as an a
legend sounds like they may be calling
it for kemp let me see if we have any uh
for duski's saying that zeldom will be
the first Republican to carry Staten
Island in a governor's race since 2002
and it's not even close Brian Kemp wins
political poll decision desk hdu
predicts Brian Kemp has won Georgia
Governor Stacy Abrams lost wow I'm so
surprised
so so here's the issue they are calling
it how could there be a red Mirage
they've called it there's no way they
uncall it that would be insane
well
three o'clock in the morning and a whole
truckload of votes come in I don't know
that's why I I said poll Watchers should
be sitting outside these buildings with
a with a 360 view of them all night
chilling in lawn chairs enjoying a bag
of pork rinds you know what's funny I
have my poll Watcher certificate sitting
on my coffee table right now and I'm
here so did you do it before pull once
before I'm technically an elected
committee person in Philadelphia and so
they just gave me one but I had prior
obligations oh no Stacy Abrams she lost
get out of here what were they thinking
DeSantis came out today in his victory
speech and said Florida is where woke
goes to die so
I think he's been hitting the right
chords again I'll be critical of him uh
I'm still I'm still unaware and unsure
of his foreign policy but just to
continue the conversation I know you
were waiting to butt in Ian's comments
about big Pharma
is in Colorado they're calling they're
calling uh Colorado for Michael Bennett
overall day
a lot of people thought that was going
to happen so we'll see it's only 43
reporting but they're calling it so they
called it there's a lot towards the end
that I was unhappy with Trump for one
was like when he was advocating for the
two thousand dollar stimulus and the
other was his push of the vaccine
lockdown yeah he supported lockdowns
he's two weeks two weeks to slow the
spread honestly I I was very unhappy
with that however the whole the whole
thing seemed to like start falling apart
I remember that he had an aide that
worked for him whose father died and and
he said to Trump at one point he's like
not only did I lose my father I lost my
job and you lost the presidency like it
was like it was
um something they didn't under they
weren't prepared to hand like deal with
the New York Times needle has for the
Senate has ticked one degree to the
right oh yeah it's still a toss-up but
now it's off center slightly to the
right this is what's going to slowly
throughout the night it's gonna slowly
start going down and down and down it's
going to lean right very likely
Republicans yeah I hope you're right
from your lips to God's ears well but at
the same time the chance of winning the
house has actually gone down three
points since the beginning but we'll see
I really it wouldn't it wouldn't be
weird if they lose the house but win the
Senate that's like 5 30 5 38 said there
was no chance that could happen yeah I
mean it's going to be interesting to see
what happens we might be up for a while
until we actually find out what we
should bring up some of those Farm hot
dogs because you're not going to stay I
want to talk about that but wait I want
to I want to kind of continue the
conversation with DeSantis here a little
bit because this is an interesting
conversation that I think a lot of
people are interested in Mike cernovich
just tweeted Miami-Dade Democratic
stronghold DeSantis 2018 versus 2020.
look up those stats then tell me he
can't win POTUS in 2025 I'm not saying
that's what Mike cernovich said right
I'm not saying he can't win I'm saying
that he shouldn't be the choice that we
shouldn't rally behind him just yet I'm
not saying that I don't like Santos I'm
saying that we should rally behind Trump
first he's the one that's going to go in
there I mean think about it if we're
talking about him having narcissistic
personality disorder he's gonna go want
to destroy every single enemy that he's
ever had he's going to literally go
scorched Earth he DeSantis won't be that
motivated to do that knowing that he has
two terms to run so let's have Trump
first and then go CBS CBS News hasn't
called Pennsylvania Governor but they
are saying it is currently heading
towards Shapiro
see what I want I want Republicans to do
is take it easy for the next two years
don't start like they're great they're
doing any super radical you know they're
great at that policies or anything like
that and then make sure that we maintain
the house the Senate and the presidency
in 2024. insane look at this look at
this Vanity Fair cover from Beto
O'Rourke he says quote I just he says I
want to be in it man I'm just born to be
in it apparently not nope sorry dude
bye-bye he's great you're gone yeah he's
got to do like a really hot dance to get
people on his side are you going to play
this video you did do it and it cost him
it wasn't hot that's a problem but I
mean he really needs to like open up
some sort of rock star inside him if he
wants to Beto has has now lost a senate
presidential and governorship race oh
man I mean he is he is a well that's
that's three for three that's a hat
trick he's officially a loser well you
got to be careful Lincoln was a loser
too Lincoln won because of a split vote
that's interesting yeah big split four
or four parties I think he had like it
was four 31 of the vote he won or
something like that so uh currently over
at Reuters it's really close Warnock is
only up by about 26 000 votes twenty six
thousand five hundred it's about 1.1
percent with 72 reporting so
we'll see man we've got a couple areas
that look like they may go red we'll
we'll see we don't know for sure it
looks like some of the Atlanta and some
other major cities have have had the
results come in to a great degree but we
will see do you think that the Trump
DeSantis situation is actually setting
up a situation where Trump demonizes
DeSantis so much that the mainstream
media Gets behind to Santos which I
think you mentioned they already are in
a lot of ways but like big money
establishments like BlackRock comes into
be like anything that's going to make
sure Trump fails we want and then they
push DeSantis to the top and it's like a
5D chess move from Donald Trump to get
the Rhonda I would kind of question that
a little bit because I I do see a lot of
mainstream media hit pieces on DeSantis
I see them attacking him not just during
covet during covet they said that he was
going to be the Butcher of Florida that
that there was going to be a bloodbath
in Florida because he didn't Implement
any restrictions or any kind of larger
mask mandates that obviously didn't
happen but the attacks still continue
and and I believe they're they're
persistent from what I see because I
don't see any kind of Mainline corporate
pieces propping him up I see he's
fighting the corporate media a lot but
obviously when I say The Establishment
I'm talking about the right-wing
establishment I'm talking about the
McCarthy's and and like the general
um the packs and things like that
they're they're more on his side than
they are on Trump's side because they're
sitting there saying okay he's the he's
the tolerable Trump he's the one that's
going to not you know say stupid things
at rallies and the problem is though is
that that kind of behavior also can
instigate riots right I mean when you
like you don't look look
I'm on your team on this but do not
think that the way that he handled the
George Floyd situation kind of provoked
a lot of what happened no you don't
think he provoked it at all no I don't
you don't think there was any other way
that he could have spoken about it that
could have de-escalated the situation no
no
they they set anti-fund black lives
matter went around setting fire to DC
before the dude was even in the in
office anything yeah but there's there's
so many ways that I think that he could
have de-escalated the situation and I
felt like he intended Trump or DeSantis
right now he's talking about dude
and I understood his perspective
completely but but you know but I can
put myself in the head of somebody else
but see I think the issue you're lacking
is and most people watching probably
understand I think you very much
overestimate the good faith of these
people they when when they went around
smashing and destroying and killing
people the media lied for them and they
lied for it when Jack passobic got
punched on the street and the cops saw
it happen and walked up this anti-woman
goes nothing happened I didn't see
anything they just outright are lying
these are these are not people you can't
come out and be like we're gonna try in
a piece I mean look at Twitter right now
Elon Musk went to these welt groups we
got pissed about it and he said I'm
gonna work with you they did not care
they came out in the press the next day
and said he is a bad person making
everything worse and then he tweeted I
went to them and told them we're doing
what you want and they're still
attacking me there's nothing you can say
to an angry mob that just wants okay so
so in in the protests what percentage
would you say would be far left is and
what percentage would you say would be
mainstream people in like the so which
part of specifically like BLM um yeah
like during those riots what percentage
of people were kind of mainstream that
that genuinely believe they're 90 wait a
minute mainstream no no 90 of the people
smashing windows and burning things down
were mainstream normal people who are
not politically uh involved so was there
so with the people that are extreme I
agree with you completely but was there
any way to de-escalate it with the
average mainstream person yeah
I had so many regular friends that were
like we got to get out there we got to
help and what like by Smashing potatoes
you're thinking they believe that you're
thinking about maybe political there
were people that were didn't care about
politics at all and just wanted to steal
stuff right like they were just
opportunities but what percentage of
those people that were out there would
you say are like that or far leftist and
what's up
no no the far leftists make up between
like 8 and 12 of politics right now of
the country yeah most people who go out
were frustrated with the lockdowns and
weren't outside for months a lot of
people who conservatives tend to live in
in suburban and rural areas so for us
like I remember Ian's making fires in
the fire pit in the backyard during
lockdowns we go back out in the patio
where we can skate where we have our
backyard to half acre not very big but
we're chilling outside we have some
burgers we grill or whatever for people
in New York City you couldn't leave your
your studio apartment you're literally
some people have no windows their
Windows look at brick walls they're
locked in okay but when the riot started
they just said I'm outside I don't care
care you can't say anything to these
people in 2020 though like I wish Drew
was up here for this because he was
filming the riots right I was filming
the riots in DC we did it in
Philadelphia DC and when we were out
there I would say that 75 of the people
that were on the streets especially in
the DC ones where you had like antifa
really set up and then you had like the
proud boys that would come and and they
would Clash 70 maybe 80 of them were
straight up Lefty lunatics antifa people
no no no no no no no I gotta stop you
I've been on the ground way too many
times these people I was there the
strategy used by the far left is always
you have a it's always a small bit of
extremists that rely on regular people
to show up in Black Block because they
don't know what's going on the far left
so in New York during and and let me
know if you agreed a bunch of regular
people show up fumbling and bumbling
being like I'd like to be involved and
then one antifa guy goes in the middle
of the crowd and Chucks a water bottle
at the cops fighting erupts and now the
regular people are involved in a clash
of police going I didn't do anything why
are the cops hitting me and then they
start smashing knocking things over
antifa and these Fallout extremists need
the Normie regular people who won't come
out when the one of the reasons uh
they're well I'll put it this way they
like it when Trump wins because Trump
Riles up liberal normal Urban people who
aren't political to go out and fill the
ranks of these violent mobs
so either way you are not going the
president a republican who's Trump is
not going to be able to come out and be
like I beg all of you to please God I
agree stop smashing please don't attack
innocent people we're going to work for
this nothing but did Trump at any point
say anything about looking at like you
don't need to demonize the police to
just say that you might look at it at
any point it even say he'll look at it
why why would why would he do that
though
um I I mean you've never seen police do
bad things sure I tweeted about there's
a in in Columbia County a blind guy got
arrested by some Psychopathic female cop
because she called he's like she she
stopped him because he had a walking
cane and he thought it was a weapon and
then she thought it was a gun because it
was in his pocket and then he's like
it's a cane what are you a tyrant he
goes I am actually and then within 30
seconds they arrest the guy yeah for no
reason I would I would absolutely love
Columbia County Sheriff I hope you're
listening to put up a bunch of
billboards all over your county to make
sure you don't get reelected unless you
fire those people yeah there are bad
cops but the George Floyd story was
you cannot as a president especially
jump the gun and just give in to it but
is there no middle ground here where he
could have said look like I backed the
police but we can look into this that's
not in the Middle Ground that's you
giving in okay so there's just nothing
he could have said like there's there's
nothing he could have said the reason
when it comes to the point you were
making asked me if I saw the same thing
yes I actually saw the same thing but I
think the larger point that we're trying
to get across here it didn't matter what
Trump said it matter what the corporate
media reported on what Trump allegedly
said and didn't say and they mixed up
his words and you know I I criticized
Trump sometimes about what the media did
to him was absolutely unfair and it
didn't matter where he stood like what
he said or his actions but the the media
manipulated the situation to always make
him look like the worst possible guy so
no matter what he did they would take
his words out of context spin it and
make him make him look like the enemy uh
Drew do you want to come in here come in
here because we were talking about he's
eating though he's eating all right well
I was like did he get the kobasa or he
got the burgers oh delicious you got the
burgers I think
de-escalated the situation potentially
by sending in the National Guard on
night two that crossed my mind on night
so I'm like why why is the National
Guard not out right now
um You Might argue that when you're
saying what percentage of the of the
rioters were far left maybe you're
another way you're asking questions what
percentage of the Riders were militant
and I think there was probably 10 of
them were military the National Guard
wouldn't have stopped the militants you
might have to break them physically the
other people were being radicalized by
the militants so so and they would have
fled if the National Guard came out
they're all militant they all flee and
yeah dude I've I covered this stuff uh
Luke longer than I did but I was on the
ground covering this all over the United
States in probably hundreds of
situations they were all militant but
the radical left ideology is a small
percentage of the overall group
when when politics started to change and
you know I'm on the granite Occupy Wall
Street from for it's for two months two
or three months we have this this
protest when the camp got removed and
mainstream appeal was leaving all that
was left was an increasingly smaller and
smaller far left radical faction they
were squatters in New York City
eventually they didn't have enough
numbers to Stage any meaningful protests
and they started getting ignored they
needed mainstream press when Trayvon
Martin died there was a black lives
matter protest in New York the Occupy
Wall Street organizers went to the front
of the March pushing out of the way the
BLM organizers and changed the direction
of the March towards Wall Street where
they brought everyone to the Bowl these
people because most people who are out
there were not anti-capitalists most
people were just there because they
heard a story they thought was about
racism or something and they didn't know
but when Occupy Wall Street successfully
brought them to the Bowl they started
going nuts knocking down barricades
jumping and climbing on top of it and
now all of a sudden there was photos and
videos of anti-capitalist anti-wall
Street protesters the average person
who's down there has no idea what's
going on but they will gladly with mob
mentality join in the fight when the
extremists throw that bottle first I
have a feeling one more point
sorry
the the far left extremists know that if
they fight a cop and the cop seeing 500
people all wearing black hoodies they
don't know who's doing it they say each
and every one of you is the riot now
then the regular Normie person who was
told show up wearing a black hoodie to
show solidarity when in reality it's so
that they can mask their crimes the cop
sees 10 guys with hoodies one guy throws
a mortar shell so he starts shoving all
of them now the Normie goes why is this
cop hitting me and they start tweeting
the police randomly to start attacking
me rallying more normies who to become
radicalized and come down and then when
the cops start swinging at him they
start fighting back being like I was
minding my own business and got attacked
I have no idea why they attacked him
however I feel like you're you're kind
of letting a lot of them off the hook I
remember them being so organized as they
had like certain wristbands for press
and they would like I'd be able to
identify if you were pressed or if you
weren't pressed because you didn't have
the certain wristband they had they had
their umbrellas and it wasn't just like
10 it was everywhere you went if they
noticed you were filming or you didn't
have one of the certain identification
markers that they had given out ahead of
time they would get you and it wasn't
just like the people in the front it was
like every five feet somebody would be
attacking you or looking at you like
that there were more organized than you
think they are I want to pull up this
story real quick from the New York Post
we have um Nicole malliotakis has
defeated in Max Rose I believe this is
in Staten Island that's that's New
York's 11th that's my district in fact
is that Staten Island or no it's Staten
Island and it's a part of Brooklyn so
the reason why this story is so
important is that Max Rose ran on
kitchen table issues back in 2018. he
was going to focus on things like the
economy jobs Healthcare what did he do
right when he got in got on his knees
for Nancy Pelosi and says we are gung-ho
impeachment 100 and regular people in
New York said you promised you would
fight for these real issues and he
didn't so they said get out and they're
saying it again Jeff Van Drew however
was a democrat in South Jersey said I am
not going to be impeaching Trump I want
to focus on core issues thus I am
joining the Republican Party he won his
primary in a landslide got reelected
yeah I mean it turns out out that most
of the people in uh in that District in
the New York 11th District do not care
at all about January 6th they don't care
about any of these things they just want
things to go right right for them they
just want things to go right for New
York and with 50 reporting Jeff Van Drew
is currently up by 20 points well 19.3
is it 19.3 I'm a math wrong maybe it's
19.7
uh 19.7 points Jeff Andrew is currently
leading as a republican who switched and
ditched the Democratic party it's
obvious this was a this was this was
coming a long time I thought in 2018
Republicans were going to we're going to
win and do really well and the mistake I
made is that I am I am ahead of the
market I think all of us here are ahead
of the market
the average person is not paying
attention this closely so when we were
seeing this stuff in 2018 with wokeness
in schools we assumed or at least I did
I assumed if I'm seeing this in the news
regular people must be seeing it just as
much and the reality was they weren't in
2020 became more prominent more people
became aware of what was going on and
then finally in 2022 mostly because of
what was going on with schools and zoom
classrooms parents became aware of what
was happening now all of a sudden where
I thought we were in 2018 we are now in
2022 so it took took four years so um
you know maybe when I say Civil War or
actually like four to eight years out
and it's not anything coming anytime
soon how about that yeah you were also
one of the first people to point out the
parallel economy thing that could happen
you were one of the first people to
point out Civil War you're one of the
first people to point out that um uh
that censorship could get so bad that um
there was these huge huge consequences
to it it seems like it took three or
four years like I'd be passing your
videos to my friends in like 2017 going
look at this this yeah when I was on
Rogan and mentioned all the censorship
was going to lead to hyperpolarization
and graduate and eventually violence and
it's everything we're seeing it's just
just been escalating I suppose
it looks like Walker has a 61 percent or
is 61 percent likely according to the
New York Times the New York Times is
saying Walker is likely to oh he took a
lead there we go yeah okay this is a big
one uh for the senate race where where's
why did it just not stop showing me the
data come on in Georgia Herschel Walker
has taken the lead by point one percent
yeah 76 percent reporting it looks like
Walker is going to win we'll see though
yeah 24 to to come so we'll see
fetterman is still leading with 36
percent in he's leading by just about
nine points so that's that's really bad
for us
yeah I want to uh I want to follow up on
this Trump conversation about the riots
and how he could have handled it maybe
de-escalated it just just and we can
change the subject obviously but I feel
like if he had made the authoritarian
move and sent out the National Guard and
stomped had them stomp down the violence
with violence it would have been looked
at it as an extremely authoritary move
he was afraid it was going to ruin ruin
his presidency his legacy but that it
might have actually
ended up
uh preventing the rest of this
authoritarian Insanity that's happened
we're January 6 and they're talking
about crew served machine guns and
things like the riots created a powder
keg system where there's so many people
throwing so many rocks now it gives the
military industrial complex you know a
reason to to get more investment to
defend us against the riots it's Trump
if Trump wanted to win he could he only
had to do one thing and it was not
invoke the Insurrection act if Trump
wanted to write by the American people
he could have taken the advice of Tom
Cotton and sent in the military to stop
the mass violence that swept across this
country the issue however is you're
probably right the average person not
seeing what would have happened only
seeing Trump suppress any possibility of
protest they would come out and be alike
there were no riots because Trump didn't
let him happen right so with the riots
they can point and say look at all the
writing all the bad things that happened
that's blm's fault BLM lost all of the
support gains they made over the past
year or two and dropped a negative more
disapproval than approval Trump could
have crushed it stopped all the violence
and destruction
but then there wouldn't have been any
and the only thing people would see is
Trump sending in the military and but
what Trump could have done to win in
2020 and people people aren't aren't
going to want to hear this but this is
how Democrats think and how the wealthy
Elites plan on the 529 Insurrection when
the far left showed up to the White
House tearing down the barricades
setting fire to a guard post and setting
fire to a church to St John's Church
Donald Trump could have called the
police back issuing a statement
immediately saying out of fear for the
innocent peaceful protest protesters we
are pulling the police back but we
recognize and we warn there are violent
elements here that are throwing
firebombs then when the violent mom mob
tore down the fencing burned down a
church and actually stormed the lawn to
the White House they would have caught
the next day and said the far left
extremists have gone too far and the
whole narrative would have been not
January 6 it would have been 5 29 but
Donald Trump sent federal law
enforcement out to clear out the
violence stopping it before they burned
down the church
and then all the only thing anyone hears
about is Trump attacked peaceful
protesters so this is the issue if Trump
wanted to do right he would say I will
stop the Riders if he wanted to win he
would go oh oh no oh no we're helpless
the writers are burning down the White
House but imagine what would have
happened if they actually breached the
black fencing at the White House and
they would have they were trying to if
the law enforcement backed down under
the guise of we have peaceful innocent
protesters and we're we fear for their
safety we and and we try to engage but
there's a real risk of of harm so we're
pulling back
then you would have had the 509
Insurrection we'll be having
Congressional inquiries over that and
not January 6th yeah so you guys are
simple you guys are seeing through a
lens of what to do once the riots had
you know escalated right so the way that
I'm thinking about it is
okay so the other day I'm on a boat to
Nantucket okay and so I walked towards
the front of the boat and this cop I
don't even know there's cops on boats to
Nantucket Kevin Cape Cod this was just
about a week or two ago the cop rushes
down he's like put your hands up like
I'm not dude I'm just on a boat like
what's up you're not supposed to be here
drags me up screams at me won't even
tell me what's going on Reems me out
goes completely nuts and I can see this
guy is is traumatized off his face this
dude should not be a cop this guy the
last thing this guy should be doing is
being a cop this guy needs to be in
serious therapy so it was a crazy
situation going on with cops yeah so it
was there any way to not throw the
police under the bus at all but actually
say we're gonna support you more with
things like how to heal trauma I mean
look how many times you just had it
where maybe your girlfriend's giving you
a hard time and you're steaming okay
imagine going into these brutal brutal
situations
of overtime and the you know they're
working a lot of overtime they have
really bad morale
um they're not getting the respect or
appreciation that they certainly used to
and I'm not saying that they you know
should or shouldn't I'm saying they're
just not and I think also you know what
we're seeing with
um what we're seeing with police is
defunds the police worked it made people
distrust cops more it encouraged people
to not have a lot of funding for police
and it was very effective like people
don't want to be police officers anymore
no one's growing up being like Oh I want
to be a police officer that sounds like
a great job would you guys believe that
the some people have suggested that they
wanted to get rid of the police because
they're more right-leaning and they want
to replace it with some kind of like
leftist clipboard police wait say that
one more time some people suggested I
read this in a bunch of places that the
last couple institutions that are more
right-leaning they kind of just want to
create distrust get rid of them and
bring in some like woke clipboard police
to get rid of the they want to destroy
America you might have something to say
they did they they tried pushing social
workers they would try and push social
workers uh to show up in a violent
situation because they would be better
to de-escalate it but uh the the media
are the masters of this whole thing when
you're talking about 2020 and the riots
Tim Tim's absolutely spot on there
because what you saw a lot in Portland
and in Kenosha in Seattle this is why
they were saying
it's the summer of love when they
literally establish their own little
country in Seattle right and they had
weapons armed threatening anyone that
came in to try and stop it and people
got killed in there here's the thing is
that Warnock took the lead back sorry
yeah the the media that's wild the media
takes control of the narrative and the
media will take like Tim is saying
everything you saw I think in the eyes
of people that were just watching what
was happening in 2020 with the riots
whether it was in Portland or Seattle or
you name it New York Los Angeles they
literally believed those were protesters
they did and I would watch antifa do
this on a nightly basis in Portland they
would set themselves up they would go
head-to-head with the police for hours
baiting a riot and then the mainstream
media would turn around when the police
would respond okay when they would bait
the police to go head to head when a
riot was declared or an unlawful
assembly was declared now I'm talking
about like not yelling at the police not
screaming profanities I'm talking about
like taking Molotov cocktails and
throwing it at the federal courthouse
calling that peaceful protesting and the
mainstream media knew what was happening
daily on a nightly basis but they set
the narrative that these people were
peaceful protesters so any Act of law
enforcement even if it was an unlawful
assembly was an act against the First
Amendment and peaceful protesting that
was the narrative that they established
and that is why so many rioters got a
slap on the wrist and a pass even in
Portland to this day because the
narrative was set by the media first so
anyone that went forward in the name of
social justice in 2020 was a peaceful
protester even if they're throwing a
damn Molotov cocktail at a federal
building that is why they're that a lot
of intervention was needed but it's a
narrative War I want to pull up we got
Rhonda santis in his uh victory speech
we have embraced Freedom we have
maintained Law and Order we have
protected the rights of parents we have
respected our taxpayers and we reject
woke ideology
there it is I really like the United
States man we fight the woke in the
legislature we fight the woke in the
schools we fight the woke and the
corporations we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where wolf goes to die oh there it is
there it is Florida is where the wolf
goes to die it's looking like Georgia
may go to a runoff election this means
you're you're going to need Mass
Republican turnout again
and that's gonna that's that's gonna be
tough we'll see I mean Democrats aren't
turning out the numbers that the
Democrats were hoping for or I should
say what could they really hope for what
would be cause for a runoff if neither
candidate breaks 50 percent
so right now you've got Warnock at 50
and walk I'm sorry Warnock at 49 and
Walker at 49. and it looks like Warnock
did I say Warnock Warnock Warnock and
Walker the names are very similar uh
Warnock is up by about what is what are
we looking at 57 no no I'm sorry it's uh
63 votes I think 64 votes maybe maybe my
math is bad 63. 63 I think I don't know
I'm not I'm not I'm not going to do a
match on the fly like that but uh it's
it's flickering back and forth so if it
ends this way I mean we still got 23 uh
yet to be reported
uh it's Walker or Warnock they will need
a their needs about 30 000 votes right
now to avoid a runoff
man seems very
49.9 versus 49.9 I it's like looking at
a
fireworks in the sky of Mickey Mouse
exploding and laughing and pretending
like Mickey Mouse is really there I I
have seen video evidence of a guy
testifying that he built software that
will flip votes 51.49 for Canada paper
ballots even even then they put them
through machines with proprietary code
no no we're saying paper ballot straight
up put in a box and a Democrat and a
republican independent and libertarian
can all sit there and pull them out one
at a time in different little pack
little groups and they can count it like
they used to it's not scalable that's
how they used to do it yeah I know they
used to when they only have like 10 000
people you can pull it off when you've
got 300 million it's like that's a lot
of paper and that's that I I do think is
is a big part of the problem I do want
to pull up Pennsylvania here with 45
reporting it's looking bad for us so far
he's looking bad for Oz and mastriana
and mastriano he's at 45.7 fetterman's
got 1.247 million votes to Oz's 1.099
and then uh over in the governor race it
is
it is similar mastriano is now is down
to about 16 he's about he's down 15.8
percent
woof that is brutal but only 44
reporting
we'll see I don't think I don't I don't
expect it to change all that much oh we
just got a big a big jump in we got to
Clearfield County just came in and it's
not really going to add a whole much to
mastriano's count anyway
what's up Colorado three
Lauren bobert's losing yeah
whoa but come on how how how How likely
is that you're going to lose how much is
reporting in Colorado three I think it's
50 percent
right now with 50 reporting Lauren
bobert is down
52.2 to 47.7
we'll see though it's only 50 percent
you don't like was it you're not a fan
you're not a fan Lisa's over there
talking from the Papasan in the back of
the room Lauren bobert may lose
yeah I don't think I don't think people
realize we had we had Stephen Marsh on
this program
and uh he's he he's Canadian he wrote
the book the next Civil War I think was
called the next civil war and he says
that you know he's neutral he's not left
or right but he's clearly left uh in
severe of influence his worldview is all
based on the mainstream media he said
there is a multicultural democracy and a
constitutional republic existing in the
same space in the same country and they
both can't they can't co-exist he said
he was in favor of Multicultural
democracy and I was like well yeah there
you go I mean obviously you're in the
left fear of influence we are all in the
constitutional republic space that's why
even though our political views may be
actually liberal to conservative as long
as you're a constitutional republic as
long as you believe in a constitutional
republic you are right-wing to the
Multicultural democracy people but
democracy is nightmarishly dangerous and
multiculturalism for the sake of it is
insane I understand not wanting to stack
the Senate with a bunch of 85 year old
white men I get that there's that might
be good but an 85 year old black man
that's insanely wealthy and has friends
at the bank of international settlements
is just as dangerous to democracy as a
85 year old white man it doesn't the
culture is irrelevant it's about wealth
it's about class like it's about
perspective it's about being open-minded
it's about critical thinking it's about
all of those things it's not it's not
about it's a mean it should not be about
aligning yourself with a particular
political perspective and then just
going along with it and that's what
we're seeing from all of these people
and you know in a lot of these races I
think
Vermont nothing in for Vermont at large
for Congress
in New Hampshire's second we've got Ann
Custer is currently up with 27 reporting
and in the where's the first is not
going to highlight there we go with 24
reporting Chris Papas is up by about
three points by by exactly three points
it's going to be a long nights it's only
10 o'clock we should be getting more
data coming in in uh now ish Arizona is
starting to yeah Maricopa come in what
are we seeing 53 so reporting Katie's at
58. Arizona we are seeing uh the Ninth
District Paul gosar one that was called
he was running unopposed I guess right
so then we have in the second district
Eli crane is currently leading by uh
just about 1.6 points how stupid would
it be if Katie Hobbs won I mean she said
nothing she refused to take on her
opposition Katie Hobbs is currently
leading with 40 of his vote 11 points up
that's correct I don't know what she
looks like
definitely don't know what she sounds
like you know I mean she had uh there
were project Veritas reporters out there
talking to her being like why won't you
debate Carrie Lake and she practically
peed herself you know I think she
actually spilled her drink she spilled
her soda okay it was a project Veritas
oh right out there right yeah Bobby
Maxwell confronted her yeah it was good
stuff she ran away she sure did we're
we're still a ways away uh 40 reporting
uh this is what we saw in uh in the
primaries Carrie like was down for a
little while and then near the end she
ended up taking everything so in uh
Coconino County is that he pronounce it
47 reporting and it's uh 68-31 Katie
hobbs's lead in uh Pinal County is that
you pronounce that a penal County uh
Katie Hobbs is up only a little bit
sixteen thousand uh she's up like 200
votes and that's 25 reporting Maricopa
that's the big one that's the big one
that's where she's currently up about
130 some odd thousand hundred or so I
think in the primaries it was Pima
that was like the last one that we were
that they were waiting and we have no
data and this is important too we have
no data from Pima from Yuma from uh from
Santa Cruz and from Cochise how do you
pronounce that Cochise Cochise these are
these are the borders these are these
are the Border counties I I kind of feel
like they probably would go carry light
considering what she's been you know
campaigning on with uh you know the
invasion of the border and things like
that Graham County uh Greenlee County
and Apache County nothing in yet so
don't count her out just yet Blake
Masters looks like he's down to the uh
Mark Kelly the space perv the space
perfect that's what we've been calling
him at post millennial we've been
calling him space perf but I will add
the Senate data is the same counties as
uh the governor basically but I think in
the governor come on pull it back up
yeah Carrie likes actually doing better
in Navajo County as opposed to Blake
Masters in uh it's actually leading
towards uh Mark Kelly but but only by
like
334 or something very early 338 votes
I've been thinking about your question a
lot about is there something Donald
Trump could have said to the riders or
maybe
exp done that would have maybe made the
summer of 2020 not so riotous I don't
think so I don't think so I mean
obviously there's magical words you
could always in hindsight say but
because he issued the shutdowns he
basically set everything in motion from
the from the shuttle we got Trump
speaking I don't want to play it all
night but I want to make sure
everybody's talking about fantastic
evening just a little bit at 58 to 41.
that's really tremendous that's as of
this moment
Katie Britt I want to congratulate Katie
Britt we endorse Katie and she did
fantastically 68 to 30. that means she
has a future Young
and just a fantastic woman with a
husband who's great he was he's maybe
the largest human being I've ever seen
he was a offensive lineman in the NFL
for a long time and a great football
player actually played for Alabama but
Katie congratulations to you and we have
a lot of other good ones going out there
herschel's leading right now
so we have a lot of a lot of big races
going on right now so enjoy that enjoy
the food and enjoy everything and really
you know Fair it is a great honor to
have the media with us and we hope you
enjoy yourself and uh and this wonderful
group of people these are the people
that you read about they are not so uh
all right he's not wrong Walker is now
leading by a very small amount of votes
by around uh what looks like seven or
eight hundred or so give or take but
it's looking like it's going to be a
runoff so uh we'll see
the thing about the riots just to get
back to that real quick is there were
um I remember it was uh what was it was
like March 1st they decided they were
going to be you know shutting down
schools I think it was March 13th right
so um I remember so distinctly looking
at what was going on they were shutting
down schools and I said to a friend of
mine I was like there's gonna be riots
and he was like what do you mean there's
gonna be riots and I was like there's
gonna be riots you know there's going to
be riots in New York city so we should
watch it you know what I mean
um I didn't know what they were going to
be riots about but it was very clear
that if you were going to lock down a
populace at a certain point they were
going to freak out and all that was
needed was a reason it could have been
any reason right George Floyd was the
reason that happened but it could have
been something else and it was
interesting because the you know George
Floyd's death was the exact same day as
the Central Park bird watching incident
what was that do you remember that so
there were two people named Cooper in
the park they were both with the last
name Cooper Amy Cooper and somebody else
and the other guy was also his last name
was Cooper so Amy Cooper's in the park
she's her dog off a leash and this other
fella is like get your dog on a leash
you know I'm trying to watch birds and
she's like no don't tell me what to do
she threatens to call the police
um it turns out that the other guy the
bird watching guy was black and so it
turned into this massive racial incident
that happened the morning of the day of
the day that George Floyd was killed and
it set off a whole bunch of stuff until
it turned out that the video was
released of Floyd later that week but it
was the same day and it was exactly 10
days into the lockdown
in New York City uh not 10 days I'm
sorry I'm tired it was 10 weeks it was
exactly two weeks it is getting late so
in uh in in Wisconsin right now and I've
been up since five 44 reporting Ron
Johnson is currently down
Ron Jon Ron Jon's currently down I don't
know uh I don't know how much of this
stuff matters because it's it's too
early for some of these states yeah the
early games like watching a race like a
like car you know what do they call a
car race NASCAR thank you like if you
watch the first seven laps and you're
like I can guess you have no idea what's
coming there's gonna be an accident
there's gonna be someone's gonna pull
ahead in the last two minutes A lot of
people wait and then they but you know I
don't know what if mail-in ballots are
going to be coming until you said the
3am is the last moment that you're alive
Josh Shapiro wins in Pennsylvania yikes
Democrats win the governorship this is
big everybody there it goes this is Doug
mastrianos race yep yeah I like dog wow
mastrono was way too far down he's 15
points down
14.6 it looks like and so political
polls as decision desk calls it Josh
Shapiro the Democrat wins in
Pennsylvania
well I'd be happy to introduce him I
wanna I wanna let everybody know
I want just people to keep like look
it's likely going to be that the
Republicans take control of the house
currently the New York Times is it a
toss-up we will see moving forward but I
I kept saying
you follow me on Twitter Democrats we're
going to surprise people and everybody
kept gloating about how it was a
guarantee a big red wave and that's why
I was very cautious to be like we don't
know don't count your chickens you
better go vote because I think Democrats
are going to surprise you what the
Democrats were predicting is that
there's going to be younger voters that
aren't being polled and so it's going to
actually correct a lot of the the
polling we sought heavily favor
Democrats in the uh in the past so
everyone assumed it was now going to
favor Republicans because or because
appalling was wrong but now with younger
voters who are not likely voting for
political issues or culture War issues
it's it brings the polling back into
alignment I'm not saying Democrats have
won everything
so hard with like abortion yeah which
was abnormal targeting young people
young people trying to get new new
voters and uh hoping that their cult
would remain strong enough to the older
generation but but I want to stress
Masters was was down in the polls for
for a little bit uh shapir was up in the
polls quite a bit even when we had
Master round owan he was down by by this
point this percentage it was sort of a
surprise that mastriano seemed to have a
chance you know yeah in Pennsylvania we
talked about Christine when he was on
the show and I was like yo we can start
pulling graphene out of the air you can
hear the news
Shapiro beat carbonation and uh
his eyes lit up when I was talking about
the re-industrializing Pennsylvania you
know you know you pull the coal out of
the ground turn it into graphene you
burn it cleaner he was so happy about
that and the excitement thinking about
working with the state Governor to
create a new industry in the United
States and just to think that now that
he's not going to be Governor that
that's not possible it's not that's not
the way to think I think that whoever
this other well they're still
entrepreneurship like you could still
try and do something no do you need
different regulations in the state you
could I could definitely I mean
something this is tax money man yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot of attacks it's
no one uh Real Clear Politics thought
that bobert was going to win
so the fact that she's currently down
with 70 71 reporting in Colorado's third
Lauren bobert is down she's the
incumbent yeah she is this is actually
pretty crazy she's down by uh about four
points 4.1 percent who is she up against
was it Adam Frisch so you never know
what's gonna happen man I mean they
media really went after
but Marjorie Taylor green won and uh uh
and it's not looking good for Lauren
bobert so you know we'll we'll see we'll
see as the night goes on it's still the
night is young but 71 reporting is
pretty big
I mean that's that's getting that's
getting pretty close yeah she needs to
find four points for 4.2 points
meanwhile help at Fresh will be gaining
as well so
we will see now in uh Arizona
's sixth uh sixth district which is a
border uh border County let's try and
zoom out a little bit it's uh looking
like the Democrat is up by just over 100
about 120 votes Kristin Engel and that's
yeah that's uh Kirsten Engel in Arizona
7th District Raul Grijalva is currently
up by about 4 000 votes this is there's
only five percent reporting two percent
reporting in the sixth but considering
that these are the Border districts I
don't know how good that's going to be
for for Kerry Lake man I'm not report
anything yet but currently in uh let me
let me zoom out here and get Arizona
with 40 reporting Carrie lake is down
still 11 points so uh keep your fingers
crossed everybody I was thinking how
stressful it was to be an actor in LA
because you're always trying to get work
it's every time you want to get job it's
a competition like what these guys are
doing right now for running for office
it was so stressful to think I don't
have a job I have to compete to get my
next job every time the stress that
these people must be under running for
this kind of office like it's make or
break if Lauren bobert loses she's not
in Congress anymore that's what a life
change for Lauren Butler I guess every
not maybe not everything I'm not putting
that on a pedestal it's a lot yeah
and social media tools a little bit
better dude they could be making YouTube
channels what the heck they should all
have a YouTube channel so right now the
Senate forecasts over the New York Times
their estimation is that Republicans
will get only 51 seats so the chance of
control they say it's a toss-up with
their estimate being that it's slightly
leaning towards Republicans getting 51
seats which is
all that really matters uh 51 52 53 54
is it doesn't matter because they're not
going to have enough to override a veto
and Biden is the president all that
really matters for the most part is that
they get the house and then they get
control of committees and they get
subpoena power however we need 51
Republican seats so that Rand Paul can
start uh bringing the heat to Dr fauci
that's that's that that'll be very very
big one necessary yep but uh right now
the current forecasting
so here's what we have so far so we have
all the states they're saying uh you
know Colorado Connecticut Illinois New
York all called for the Democrats
Washington 91 percent Democrat New
Hampshire is 87 percent Democrat where
are you seeing Washington so I'm looking
at the you can look it up here uh the
New York Times tracking they're saying
Nevada's 50 52 chance of going to uh uh
Cortez masto
60 chance that fetterman will win
they're saying with 52 reporting
considering Shapiro won it's possible
but Federal the difference is
fetterman's brain doesn't work and that
does play a big role in this and then
you can see uh New Hampshire is very
heavily leaning uh Democrat and then on
the other side we got Georgia they're
actually predicting Walker will will
likely win 54 chance of him taking it
Wisconsin uh likely go to Johnson North
Carolina to Bud Ohio to Vance that's 95
chance Iowa greater than 95 it's going
to Grassley the rest they've called
already so
George is going to be important but it
may go to a runoff because Walker may
not get the uh the the votes that he
actually needs so they're saying 51 and
right now the chance of control is
considered a toss-up it's not looking
like a Red Wave right now especially
with Lauren bobert losing well Drew you
were talking about the narrative War
what are some things that you think
could change the narrative War to where
a guy like fetterman you know couldn't
be elected when you look at fetterman
getting elected I mean
what could be done different
I think how does that guy get elected
but I mean what percentage of the
average voter just wants low drama and
isn't even following it that closely yo
they've got five dollar a gallon gas but
the cult is strong and you'd think it's
the economy stupid
we'll see I suppose what would it take
though I mean as far as social media
channels TV media things like that
because you're really impassionate about
that it was like a amazing thread that
you were going down there I just think
it's showing these people for who they
really are and I think what's happening
with fetterman is I I find it hard to
believe that that guy is really
dominating like that I mean the average
person really taking a look at what that
guy is how that guy talks maybe let's
just say in a real world in a real
election maybe there's just stupid
people that feel sorry for the guy maybe
I just want to point out we got new data
from Georgia Walker needs only point
seven percent right now to win with no
runoff with 20 left to be counted Walker
is has got a pretty strong lead of about
sixteen thousand fifty thousand or so
votes he's up by point five percent but
he needs point seven more if he gets it
there will not be a runoff however it's
looking like there will be a runoff so
that's not good or bad news I guess you
know bad news would be Warnock winning
good news would be Walker winning but
it's looking like it may go to a runoff
we'll see anyway sorry continue where do
you post most of your content Drew uh
Twitter
my shows on real America's voice because
YouTube took my show down
I would say the majority is Twitter so
do you feel like that's where the
Republicans are losing the media war is
Big Tech probably I mean with all the
shadow band going on and the throttling
on YouTube and big voices I think that's
obviously definitely part of what's
taking place so so it's it's the media I
I ask you what motivates you right you
said you're a Christian so can you
believe that we live in a world where a
Christian person you're doing things
that are putting you at tremendous risk
right you're putting yourself a
tremendous risk you're doing so trying
to add good how do we live in a world
where you're trying to add good and
you're being demonized for that you're
putting yourself at risk you're being
demonized for that and then now you're
losing you know the narrative Ward and
fetterman is getting elected like can we
all just see the humor in fetterman
getting elected you know like you like
you don't want to lose the absurdity of
that so what has to change do you think
to change that narrative War I think
what Elon Musk is doing
is that going to be enough I mean
Twitter is still kind of a Twitter
platform I think Twitter will be a huge
platform because that I mean you got to
think about what they do why do they
want to suppress Free Speech because
they know when millions of people are
speaking up saying what they really feel
and how they really feel showing the
truth that's going to wake other people
up as well whether that's on social
media or in the real world
authoritarians have known this for
decades for hundreds of years and that's
why they want to suppress those things
because that ends up promoting truth as
well and when you're speaking the truth
you're going to expose a lot so that's
why they try to suppress that's why they
throttle that's why they Shadow ban
because more people begin to see
something different than what the
mainstream narrative is so I think
I think what Elon is doing could
potentially be a game changer
New York Times house forecasts their
current estimate is that Republicans
will win 227 seats to Democrats 208 so
they'll have control they're estimating
a 71 chance of that happening and they
just updated their needle it has tilted
slightly to the left
so while the control of Senate is
currently in toss-up territory the
needle has actually shifted about one
degree to the left not that shifting a
needle one degree is actually any kind
of any kind of scientific measurement
but that's what they're projecting so
far who is that who are they who are
they predicting I think that Georgia or
I think it might be charges already
Masters and fettermen yeah our masters
and and uh Oz losing but uh one seat one
one gain is all the Republicans need to
control and and stop Kamala from having
a tie breaker so right so it is what it
is not the Senate is going to do too
much but that can that majority control
would be great for uh it would be great
for stopping yeah Roe v Wade from
becoming what is it
yeah but that actually doesn't matter
because they won't have the house so
it's not going through I just wanted to
say rela the land what we will get the
house is the most important because
they're gonna they're gonna have a
control over budgets and uh that's gonna
that's gonna give them a lot of uh
leeway however one uh one Theory that's
been going around is that Democrats
actually want the Republicans to win the
house so that way when Republicans use
the the budgeting strategy or like you
know Omnibus packages or whatever they
can then say hey we gave the Republicans
a chance for two years it's 2024.
they've failed this was their fault vote
us back in
and then look man the cult is strong
they call this strong we'll see we'll
see it's it the night the night the
night is uh is Young ish so how do you
begin to chip away at that though like
if we have oh oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
what happened they just updated right
now they are now predicting that the
Republicans will not gain control of the
Senate the New York Times has updated
their Senate forecast for a 50 50 split
giving Democrats control of the Senate
there it is still control stay tuned to
the New York Times so the New York Times
was actually predicting 51 seats
Republicans literally just at this
moment the Neil shifted blue they've got
some 26 year old dudes on slack just
laughing and changing these numbers so
people stay addicted to the New York
Times right now it's a robot
when so it's all algorithm algorithmic
for the most part algorithmic when Paul
when data and election data comes in
they update their numbers then based on
how many uh counties are left in certain
votes for like the Senate it it adjusts
their percentage likelihood of winning
so this is why they're able to call
races when it's like there's only three
percent reporting how did they know for
sure this guy won and it's like so right
now the challenge for Arizona let's pull
up a governor for Arizona so I can so I
can explain this um Maricopa County is
seven is eight hundred thousand eight
hundred and twenty some odd thousand
people already and that's 53 but when
you look at these other counties that
that Kerry lake is winning it's like 17
000 votes it's 40 000 votes it's 3 000
votes those are meaningless to Maricopa
so she really has to perform well in
Maricopa to win because that's where all
the votes are so if Katie Hobbs it's a
53 reporting and she's leading in
Maricopa and they say she's got X many
votes they can look at all these other
counties and be like yeah we only have
one County reporting
doesn't matter there's not enough votes
left in the state so when they say three
percent is in does that mean three
percent of the counties are in or three
percent of the total votes across all
counties that I'm not entirely sure but
they're calling it for Shapiro now with
only 56 reporting so it looks like we
went from a red wave to uh blue balls I
think it's a fair comparison to what's
happening right now also finally we got
all the boys together uh boys boys boys
just like Ryan long says uh Libby I fed
your kid a lot of sugar sorry not sorry
uh but this is interesting this is a
very interesting development Happening
Here your kid's great and awesome but I
gave him a lot of sugar uh but but this
is this is this is interesting to see
this is this is uh curious to see what's
going to be the response from this
because essentially the predictions of
the Red Wave they're they're wrong it's
amazing that
um Progressive channels get no
viewership nobody's watching independent
to conservative channels have insane
levels of viewership but the vote
turnout is for the cult that I think
breaks it down man these are people
watching these these garbage media
channels and getting their news from
memes Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Kimmel talk
about a really just awful person how
about that cult dude it's a cult it was
a funny show where they're running
around dressed as uh syringes yeah
that was cold bear Colbert when they
were and they and naturally what people
don't realize is the vax scene thing he
did with the dancing that's actually an
ongoing thing that wasn't like a one-off
he actually had the vaccine as like a
series of segments I guess but uh this
is the reality man there are there are
people they're in a cult they don't know
they're in a cult but they don't read
the news and they don't watch videos and
the example I like to give is when
Hunter Avalon came on the show and told
me straight up smugly and surely that
Joe Biden never said if you want the
billion dollars you gotta fire the
prosecutor and I just played the video
but he just believed it was true without
doing any research we do research all
day and night so why we it's why we're
here it's why we all have different uh
viewpoints but we agree because we agree
on the set of facts they just follow a
margin locks that behind the lies and
you know what I gotta say this was a
surprise to a lot of us turns out
abortion
not abortion at nine months and evil
Maga really was a motivating factor or
or we could say it wasn't and that
Republicans are just too lazy to get out
and actually cast a vote to fight back
I actually think it's probably a little
bit of both a little bit of both I think
Democrats very much are in the cult and
saying you know these people are eviling
to vote against them they will they're
you know you go on go on Reddit and see
how manipulated it is there's these like
watching um I watch politics girl right
and I don't see your offer but anything
substantive other than platitudes I
watched uh all these celebrities
Hollywood celebrities it was John
Leguizamo and Marston and they were like
Kathy hokel is going to bring equity and
equality in the environment it's like
you didn't tell me anything you didn't
actually say you're going to do anything
if you're someone who is in a cult
that's good enough for you
if you're somebody who cares about facts
and making life better and a better
country you're like tell me what you're
going to do but that's not what these
people are I think
it's also true that Republicans don't go
out they rarely protest their uh less
likely to organize it's been changing
but the sad reality may be
look we're seeing a a a tip it is not a
red wave so far we're not looking at Red
Wave we thought there was going to be
one it's it's looking more like a
typical first term uh midterm
presidential uh or midterm election well
you know what happens before a giant
tsunami the the tide goes out and you'll
be like wait this is the opposite of a
tsunami the water went down maybe that
must mean that there's no tsunami no no
no that means that there's going to be a
giant tsunami because the tide just went
out so yeah but metaphorically maybe the
Tide's going out right now I'm just
perhaps but in 2016 Donald Trump won by
I think 77 000 votes between three
states and that's what got him the
Electoral College lead Hillary Clinton
was just really really unpopular and
they they really thought she could win
if they ran maybe anybody else maybe
could have beat Trump maybe not they
didn't have anybody else as part of the
issue in 2018 we actually saw the
Democrats win the midterms in 2020 while
the polling was wrong across the board
in in 2016 18 and 2020 any Democrats
still retained control in 2020 and now
it's looking like right now hey I'm not
I'm not saying it's over
where we are right now in the night
the New York Times actually predicting
Republicans will not get the Senate this
was a potential scenario and I think it
was um I think 538 had 41 chance this
actually happened so we're still in coin
toss territory sort of it's looking like
the initial predictions you know from a
month ago were were more correct again
we don't know for sure
it it may all start changing but it's
looking like less of a red wave and more
of a typical election now here's the
crazy thing what if this is the red
Mirage they've already called it for
many people but what races are they
going to hold out on and make us wait a
few weeks and then it's like it does
seem like Republicans are winning and
then a week later it's like oh actually
Democrats swept they control everything
yeah Maricopa County is reporting right
now that they expect to have 99 of their
ballots counted by Friday right so
that's that's already a staggering
figure it's predominantly also a
conservative area where there's getting
there's a lot of reports of four to one
Republicans voting there so again a lot
of questions are going to emerge from
this uh election uh the the blue North
is kind of very eye-opening to to I
think a lot of people especially
specifically Minnesota Wisconsin and
Michigan that do look like they are
going to be voting blue overwhelmingly
so it it's still early but uh that that
Red Wave doesn't look like it was true
at all but don't be demoralized because
sometimes these polls it's still early I
mean in Arizona what is it like it's
eight o'clock right now 8 30. and I want
to stress too as much as the New York
Times is saying like we don't know I
want to remind everybody When Donald
Trump was was in 2016 the needles for
the forecast were actually skewed all
the way to Democrat the whole time yeah
they had Hillary at 99 greater than 99
to win and then slowly throughout the
night it started rolling back the other
direction which indicates to me that's
like ideology at work whoever owns the
company that's running that poll is very
much just wanted Hillary Clinton to win
they didn't care they weren't doing it
was all the polling was wrong they they
missed the the Trump vote they didn't
see it
but it is it is uh really crazy I will I
will I will predict that if the
Democrats retain control the Crackdown
on social media is going to be
apocalyptic
if the cult is is is is this strong then
they're going to do everything they can
to make sure channels like ours like
Crowders are not able to have these
conversations and that's why I think uh
rumbles actually dangerous I like Rumble
we use Rumble for uh teamcast.com but
the danger is that if everyone silos
themselves in Rumble
then YouTube is the dominant platform
that everyone uses it's the number one
platform for Gen Z they say what's when
I asked the majority say YouTube
if everybody leaves YouTube to go to
rumble on some kind of like free speech
principle congratulations you are now
siloing yourself away from the average
average person who's not into politics
that could change if Rumble were to have
more fun creators you remember back in
the day would be ABC CBS NBC Fox right
and then it was the really fun creators
that brought everybody to YouTube but
then YouTube went and demonized all
those fun creators so you know not all
the but many of them so could Rumble
begin to attract more fun right people
could actually get out there and have a
little bit of fun how much are you
posting on Rumble
um my show's on Rumble but I'm
predominantly on real America's voice
got it yeah what does Chris need to do
to take it to the next level do you
think what is what Chris pavlovski he
needs help I feel like what does he need
to do to take that to the next level
he's got an amazing start there's a
foundation there's a real Foundation
something amazing there that's a long
conversation yeah I don't know you gotta
take YouTube's partner program make it
better so whatever YouTube's able to
like they need advertising they need to
control their advertising Network like
Google does Google's has 20 years head
start on them they also need to disperse
their service platforms so like their
servers and need to be spread out all
over the place in property to the point
where it's decentralized because the NSA
can shut down Rumble and then it's all
gone so that needs that's a
vulnerability in their system like
technically but um consciously
I think you're right that they need like
rock stars on the on the site with you
know like a hit song
what do you think is going to happen if
if Kerry Lake doesn't end up winning I
mean with with all the rhetoric around
uh corruption I don't I don't see
Republicans believing that they could
they could lose people will scream that
it was fraud that's why people are
already screaming in the chat right now
sure sure but what but what happens we
roll with it I don't know we got to make
a system where it's on the blockchain
and and we're able to look at the code
of these programs we have to I mean we
cannot trust the systems we need to we
can't have voting machines that have
proprietary code and that keep breaking
down that's for sure and I'm not
claiming that they're cheating I'm just
saying you cannot verify whether they
are or not well yeah we so so yeah paper
ballots perhaps but my question for you
guys is what happens if these these
locations where I mean uh uh I mean look
it's very early Kerry Lake she was up in
the polls wasn't she
I'm pretty sure she was doing well in
the polls let's pull up the governor
projections and she was behind in the
primary
she was she has consistently been up in
every poll so I actually think she may
still win I think it's very early and
she may still win but Carrie like is up
and uh up in uh all the polls uh for
November
plus three plus three plus four plus
four uh giving her a point three uh uh
3.5 lead and now it's uh with uh 42
reporting Katie Hobbs is actually
leading by a decent amount by about a
hundred and thirteen thousand votes
so
what happens
I think we're going to see uh Arizona
begin to decline uh well look at look at
this Arizona's Seventh District has been
called for Raul Grijalva this is a
border County and it went Democrat two
to one
so if this is the area where the border
is being invaded one of Kerry Lake's
main positions is it really going to go
her way
with 14 percent of the expected votes
counted they're calling it for the
Democrat can illegal aliens vote in
Arizona
no I mean technically they they
physically they can legally they can't
right so that's that's that's the issue
they're just being counted towards the
census
Arizona's first is looking like it's
going Democrat jevin Hodge with 170 000
votes to David schweikertz 89 and he's
the incumbent with 57 reporting so uh
considering all of the issues
man Arizona is a messed up state
it's a joke you want I mean it's talk
about insanity if you keep doing voting
like we're doing it with paper ballots
and expect a new result that there's
going to be a transparent election
that's the definition of insanity we
need a new way of voting
this aborted thing reminds me of how
people in Vegas voted for Biden
right a lockdown president you know like
you're literally almost every job is in
the service industry you need the
casinos open yep but they voted for blue
it just doesn't make any sense
it's easy to manipulate how how could
you want lockdowns
if you're almost your entire almost all
of Vegas is all Trump the kind of start
of the lockdown thing it wasn't really a
left or right but he was trying to
unlock it by that point it's a coach
it's a cult it's a cult it's a cult the
the the amount of people that are
checking independent sources and getting
proof
is small look Trevor Noah's ratings for
The Daily Show were lower than this show
but on YouTube they put him on the front
page so his his total views per month on
Clips was double what we get
how do you compete with that the machine
is working against you now Elon Musk
buying Twitter is a step in the right
direction but without YouTube and now
you've got people who are intentionally
leaving YouTube
on principle and then going to rumble
which again I like but Rumble is
predominantly one audience so they were
moving themselves from the potential of
reaching gen Z and younger
YouTube is already trying to make sure
that we can't reach people on YouTube's
main platform we talked about this this
is why we're working on cultural stuff
we put out the song we got a song Tim
cast genocide losing my mind look it up
listen to the song watch it and we Trend
number 29. only ever wanted totally
apolitical we trended number 23 on all
of YouTube When We produce kind of
that's not political all of a sudden
we're reaching the biggest Heights of
YouTube this show never appear even if
we Clips with a million views because
they want to make sure this gets siled
just because politics yes but it's the
wrong politics Trevor Noah John Oliver
they get put on the front page CNN gets
put on the front page it's the
corporations are getting their front
page it's big ones it's they've got
deals behind the scene I bet you can
call it you call it whatever you want
but it is left politics that are being
put on the front page yeah those they've
been co-ops corporations for sure go on
Reddit you know why you know why they're
so mad about Elon Musk buying Twitter is
because the government runs Bots to
control public opinion and now they've
got to pay eight bucks but if you go on
Reddit it is so completely obvious the
whole thing is Astro turfed just not not
real political opinion it's like you'll
see memes about why Republicans are bad
but there's no real substance to them
it'll just say like what are you a dork
vote Democrat and it's like okay is
anyone the Republican party like aware
how bad this could get if they don't do
something about it uh probably not
I mean like
there's there there is
you know there's some good people in the
Republican party but man I think it's
like when I when I went to when I went
to Austin and met with these these Tech
executive guys I was hanging at a party
it's like I didn't meet with him or
anything like that they were absolutely
clueless as to what was going on it was
just I was just like man all they all
they do is they say like the solution to
our problem is controlling technology
and I was like the associative problem
is building culture inspiring people
making them believe in you you think
you're going to build a car and that's
going to convince people to go for a
ride you're wrong you know I got a
really great car it's got 50 miles of
the gallons like so what I want to ride
in the in the in the McLaren it gets
substantially less and then you have
politicians who are like we need to win
the election so we can pass the votes so
we can get the votes to pass the bills
and that's how we'll win and it's like
no because even if the law is on the
books nobody follows it right now you
have protesters in front of the Supreme
Court Justices Holmes and the cops ain't
doing anything about it but the
pro-lifers are getting locked up by the
feds that's called cultural dominance
and the Republicans don't get it the
tech Bros don't get it and the Democrats
get it 100 percent that's why Jimmy
Kimmel is tapped to host the the Oscars
despite him saying outright F Trump
supporters I think I'm paraphrasing the
tech boys do get it they just don't have
it they don't get it they don't have it
I've talked to them they don't they
understand they need something to spark
it but they don't have the spark no
they're looking outside same with
YouTube and Google in 2006 they didn't
have it they were looking for it talk to
these people I we I went down to Austin
had a meeting with a bunch of people a
handful we're billionaires and all they
did was talk about how if only we
controlled the tech and I'm like
you're wrong the left controls the
advertisers even when Elon gets Twitter
they they for all the advertisers
advertisers drop off and now elon's like
I don't know if I can fund this he's
like we're losing four million dollars
per day it doesn't matter if you have
the attack if the culture is against you
and advertisers are scared of antifa
because they burn buildings down they're
not scared of the right because the
right does nothing I think that they
work you have to have control of the
tech and the culture but if you don't
have control of the tech the person that
has control of the tech is going to
create the culture they want because
they can ban and silence and proliferate
what they want to proliferate same
person if only one political party owned
the printing press we would all be at
the behest of that political party so I
get the tech brothers are doing God's
work they just need the inner the
inspiration
New York Times update the new prediction
51 Republican seats in the Senate with
new data coming in we're back we're back
to slightly winning the Senate it's just
remarkable that the Democrats can win it
all though to be honest
yeah well
I don't think it's actually that remark
called it uh I think we were looking at
this red wave in part because we really
wanted it but no no no but look I I look
at my Twitter I have tweeted several
times the Democrats will surprise
Republicans
100 yeah what do you think I learned my
lesson in 2018 I learned my lesson in
2020 that we see things we think we know
for sure and then we get surprised and
I'm like
it looked like a Red Wave the polling
was predicting a red wave and I want to
believe in a red wave but I still say
everyone get your friends you better go
out and vote otherwise you will lose
there was also a lot of pollsters
speaking about this prior to saying that
the polls might not be
um extremely accurate because most
people will not answer calls when
pollsters call they don't answer the
phone they don't want to talk about it
and that there are a lot of people
um in younger demographics that won't
answer polls at all so
that's kind of interesting too I mean
what's that about because I know that I
know that like people were knocking on
my door for um because I was registered
as a Democrat until like three weeks ago
something like that maybe two anyways uh
Max Rose people were knocking on my door
like a couple of times a week and I
would open the door and they'd be like
can we and I'd be like stop knocking on
my door and I'd just close the door so
be nice about it but this guy Jeff B on
uh on Twitter he's had a tweet he said
to DeSantis in Florida widely wildly
over performs all the hand-picked and
Trump supported Republicans in other
swing States well then gosh that is
going to be a fascinating new narrative
that will be comment upon by positively
no one it's interesting with Trump
actually coming out and jabbing it
DeSantis but to Santa's winning so
decisively what does that mean going
forward with who Trump endorsed and what
does it say for 2024 I think if the
results of this are not a red wave then
I'm DeSantis 2024. the reason being
Trump is so toxic to a lot of people
that
DeSantis is clearly showing he has the
means to win and win big and his
endorsement maybe maybe better and then
maybe we should reconsider the Oz
endorsement over uh Barnett absolutely
yeah I think Miss Barnett was was a lot
better and nobody liked us Oz was
definitely a hold your nose and vote for
Oz kind of GOP can yeah yeah he was
talking about transitioning children 10
years ago yeah uh Barnett Barnett was on
top of it talking about the core issues
talking about the ESG talking about the
larger issues that actually impacted
America and uh I I thought she was
clearly the more uh prominent person in
that race the person that was more
competent for that race the person that
should have been in that race yeah she
also had a lot more to say than Oz
instead of having to run from her record
um we got we got Brian stelter chiming
in oh he says on PBS analysts are
talking about the Red Wave in the past
tense had there been a red wave tonight
agreed
yep Debbie Wasserman Schultz actually
won her position as well and so then
well good for her Thomas Macy
oh good for Tom yeah Thomas also T-Bone
I am almost done putting my faith in
politics to solve this situation anyway
so I'm not really disappointed I you
know I'm rolling with the I'm happy you
said it that way I never had faith in
politics but sorry I just wanted it I
could vote like morality into place but
it's it's become very apparent
especially with when they start 3D
printing guns and they were like no wait
stop and then they were thinking let's
make it illegal to have a gun and I'm
like dude they can print them you can't
stop it and making an underbelly of
criminals now or making a law that you
can't enforce it's just what a mockery
that system has become the way
I understand Trump not wanting to send
up the National Guard because he didn't
want to look like a fascist Tyrant but
and maybe he would have maybe it would
have opened the floodgates for people in
the future be like well Trump did it so
I can smash up 600 people's faces maybe
it would have done that but I don't
think so
JD Vance is also ahead in Ohio still yes
it does seem like it's going to be uh uh
with JD Vance's decently ahead he's
ahead by kind of a lot now with 86
reports he's going to win I think the
New York Times is saying Vance has got
it in the bag
so uh let's see where that with Ohio
what am I looking at is this the key
Senate races yep greater than 95 chance
that uh Vance will win in Ohio
it's just getting interesting with more
data coming in it's looking like Walker
they now have increased a 50 chance of
winning by 1.2
so is that the uh estimate which means
no run no runoff they're they're
estimating he takes it Wisconsin Ron
Johnson expected to win uh greater than
95 chance uh for bud in North Carolina
and Grassley in Iowa Grassley is obvious
though
and then it's possible that Nevada still
does go
um uh still doesn't go Republican
because there's no votes in yet
in Washington no votes are in but
they're giving a 91 chance for Murray to
win so it's too bad yup yup Hassan is is
projected to win with a greater than 95
chance after 30 to the vote is in
fetterman is projected to win
74 chance with 66 percent of the votes
in WoW Senator fetterman you know that's
so crazy because he was so he's
time he was speaking he was just so
clearly brain damaged it's hard to
imagine that he has any idea what he's
talking about or what he's doing he came
out as pro-life do you see that yeah he
did he said he celebrates the demise of
Roe v Wade like that that sure did well
I mean they voted for him they voted for
a man who has no idea what he's talking
about what he's doing where he is
and who should probably be in a rehab
facility you know people thought a
zombie apocalypse would require getting
bitten but apparently it uh just
requires watching CNN yeah that's really
that's really just about it what
percentage of people do you think are
not even looking at social media or even
the news just voting reports anyone
voting Democrat so what percentage is
that I would say that actually
I'd I'd estimate maybe 30 of Republicans
don't pay attention to the news and
maybe 70 of Democrats don't mm-hmm
part of that though is that Democrats
have uh um basically have a lock on
culture they have a lock on culture and
Academia and conservatives really only
have Politics as something to consider
and try to make change in society that's
really all there is so if you're a
Democrat you can you know make art you
can put on a play you can like go teach
at University you can get books
published you can do all of those kinds
of things a lot of old people died yeah
and a lot of newer younger voters
and this is what Republicans are
completely unable to uh to Win It
Turning Point USA I will be speaking
there and I'll probably be the only one
not wearing a suit I'm not going to wear
a suit either oh yeah it's been doing
that I'm not wearing a suit I'll wear
this I was gonna wear a really cute
dress actually that was my plan I think
I think it's cool or something crazier
than this yeah
the idea is they they espouse a lot of
the ideas they have they're important
they're good
but uh
their suits well it's literally it's
it's young people want they look up to
celebrity to excitement and I don't even
think about the meat with the media
controls I think about skateboarders
skateboarders were very much
trendsetters in a lot of ways with with
modern music when uh a lot of the
hipster music that came out
became popular Through Skateboarding so
a skate video would get released and
would have a song in it that was brand
new and cheap so this is what happens
skateboarders film tricks they edit
those tricks like a music video to the
beat of a song or to a good song
they didn't have any money so they would
find Indie label bands who would let
them use the song for dirt or for
nothing then skateboarders would hear
the songs like them and put them on
their playlists go to parties the
skateboarders were considered cool
people at parties would start hearing
that music and it you know spreads
around
it's not completely how it goes but
there's that was a large component
especially mostly where where I grew up
that is one thing that sets trends like
there's just for whatever reason
whatever you want to quantify people
that are cool Republicans they're not
cool they've never been cool at least
not as long as I've been alive
not
suit wearing you know stodgy
authority-minded not really known for
their autism or whatever liberal the
liberal arts is what it was called like
arts and entertainment was a liberal
Pursuit and then it's because it's
different it's weird it's new it's
unexpected whereas conservative nature
is the same thing every time you know
what you're gonna get you can you can
build off of that you guys you gotta
have both but Arts are very liberal this
is why Tom McDonald is so incredibly
important because of his massive success
in making good music that actually
inspires people and it's it's crazy puts
out a song just how big all of his songs
get he was number four on trending with
the release of fighter yeah man it's an
amazing song it's one of my favorite
that he's released it's more melodic you
know but uh uh things just better done
all together I mean he's really well
done amazing video by the way good job
and then that's why we're also uh trying
to uh create music and put out content
and uh cultural content because I know
man you don't convince someone to vote
through facts Ben Shapiro was right when
he said facts don't care about your
feelings but when it comes to winning
elections facts are meaningless yeah as
as as exemplified by fetterman
seriously I mean he was he was projected
to win and then it was only after the
debate started to go or slightly before
the debate and then with the debate the
polling went down but at that point
people had already been voting early and
voting by mail yeah NBC news right now
is calling JD Vance for Ohio all right
the official winner there we got it
right here actually as people were
watching this in real time it changed JD
Vance has won in Ohio so uh there we go
as the night continues it's 11 p.m oh
man I don't know if I'll be able to work
tomorrow
taking the day off I don't want to just
keep it pushing we got a big day tonight
we got a very big guest tomorrow as well
but uh all right we get to criticize
Republicans now I'm all in I've been
criticizing them from from day one ever
since the bush war on terror days and I
think they do deserve a lot of criticism
because at the end of the day they
failed people on covet they failed
people on the War on Drugs they failed
people on the war on terror and and
they've been hijacked by War thirsty
neoconservatives who I think the general
public now understands that hey at the
end of the day they they're just going
to do the same thing as Democrats but
only later down the line in a different
way and I I think we live in a duopoly I
think there are some candidates that do
represent a populist class to do
represent someone that thinks outside of
the box and doesn't just want to screw
people over and give all the jobs to
China very few people represent that and
actually not just talk the talk but
actually you're able to walk the walk
and back it up so
um I I think what we're seeing today it
is not a surprise I'm not a fan of
either political party but I think the
general public also has a consensus also
has a feeling and oh and you were
talking about this a little bit they
want to go with the the people doing
something they want to go with the the
action class they want to go with the
people telling people to be on their
knees they don't want to go with the
people who are just going to be sitting
on their hands and uh acquiescing to a
lot of the bull crap but just postponing
it a few years down the line
yeah it's um
that's a great that's such a deep
there's so much to say there's a lot of
yeah
I mean it definitely seemed more
compelling and more exciting and so on
and so forth I mean I think that maybe
if we get into social decline we could
see the values change a little bit as
well right so a lot of this sort of um
leftist thinking is also in my view
probably a result of too much Prosperity
like Freedom can become top heavy to
where there's so much Prosperity that
people get stuck on kind of like issues
that are maybe not as important you know
this happened in previous societies
before societies go down
I got fact checked I got fact checked on
Twitter uh Ian do you want to read my
Tweet yeah work of Pride this is the
most important day of your lives uh if
the Democrats win they will arrest says
Tim Poole and murder your children Tim
continued uh and historians won't be
allowed to write about it I felt like I
don't want to make fun of fun and I
noticed it says readers added context
they thought people might want to know
there is no evidence that Democrats will
engage in this Behavior rather this
appears to be a joke referencing a
historian that appeared in MSNBC hey I
actually I don't know if that ruins the
joke or if it's really great because my
point was obviously to mock the
Democrats because they had a guy going
MSNBC and actually say that but but then
people would people like these people on
the left are so ignorant to the news
this happens all the time I actually
think it's really hilarious albeit sad
and pathetic that they will start
sharing this as if I said actually a
really good example is Lauren bobert
she said Trinidad on a shop at a
pressure in a tweet and they all said
wow look how dumb she is not realizing
that's what Biden is what Biden said
literally so I like this feature Bird
Watch feature so now when they all start
retweeting it it would appear and be
like this is a Biden quote she's making
fun of Biden you need to watch the news
so that I'm very proud that I got fact
checked for saying that Democrats will
arrest and murder your children
historians won't be able to write about
it I like how they explain the joke it
appears to be a joke
there's a there was actually a different
one there's a couple uh
oh wow we'll call it helpful there were
there were other okay I'm not going to
submit anything get out of your Twitter
a different one said it just said this
is satire or whatever I don't know how
does a bird watch thing work like you
can you can just add you can write stuff
on it or what is that yeah so a bird
watch came out a while ago in beta form
and I signed up for it and then never
used it but what you can do is you can
add notes and contacts it's almost like
the the Wikipedia of Twitter so I
actually right when I tweeted this I
immediately linked the article from WLOS
historian says children will be arrested
and killed the GOP wins but they are
people who just believe it this is
pretty far out there even for you there
are plies in this thread show us
foreigners that while things are
unraveling in the US it still has a way
to go before conditions are uniformly
Third World level
there you go
Katie Hobbs is publicly saying it's
going to take days to count the votes in
Maricopa really yeah yeah I was just
talking about that how would she until
Friday they're saying don't off the
check and that's a heavily conservative
area that that they're getting a lot of
reports that mainly Republicans are
voting well we got uh we got more data
has just come in with 51 reporting Katie
Hobbs has expanded her lead to 14 points
in Arizona
uh any information about what's
happening in LA with the race for mayor
uh
I don't have that on this website
but uh if someone wants to pull it up
I can then pull up the source because I
know that's a race that a lot of people
are also like yeah save Los Angeles yeah
Katy Perry and other celebrities are
voting for um I forgot the guys yeah
Caruso yeah yeah so I'm keeping an eye
on that too yeah
um but uh Pennsylvania it looks it looks
like it's uh becoming closer between
fetterman and Oz fetterman is at 50.1
percent Oz is at 47.5 percent 58 of the
vote is in hold so uh 49 Federman has
dropped to 49.5 to Oz is 48. that's very
71 reporting let's jump over to our New
York Times the needle to see the updates
they've not changed it they're still
saying 77 chance fetterman takes it hey
that's still a little bit more than one
in five that uh Oz wins this one
let's see what their needle as they have
now updated the needle saying it will be
a 50 50 Senate that is bad because even
with the moderate projections it was
that Republicans would get 51 seats it
there was like a a two to one chance
just about maybe 1.5 to 1. that
Republicans would actually gain control
of the Senate and now Kamala will come
in and be the tiebreaker and that means
the Democrats control it yep but if
Republicans take the house it may be
just like uh 2018 where we'll end up
seeing
um
impeachment
well and then it'll fail and then we'll
end up seeing investigations maybe we'll
get bidengate or whatever and you know
petroleum gate or Ukraine gate 2.0
Biden's Revenge
yeah whatever then what they're going to
make people beg for something better and
then give it to them via corporations
Republicans Revenge a lot of people are
in the chat room are asking for Elisa to
come back in by the way yeah you know
what I would love to to step out
actually Lisa do you want to come on the
show also do we have any super chats
that we could read we have quite a few
um because I know a lot of people are
commenting a lot in here and it would be
good to get some of those voices and
talk to some of the audience members
because I bet they probably have some
questions that we can answer more uh
directly Walker communication with them
Walker and Georgia has gone up he's
point six percent away from clearing
winning this election without the need
for a runoff so how much you want to bet
they're going to say it's going to take
an extra week before we can figure out
who won in Georgia
do you think can I can I just point out
real quick I blame all Libertarians for
not voting Republican because it is a
moral and legal obligation that
Libertarians vote against their
principles and for the establishment
political class
it is no I'm just kidding what is it two
percent of the vote if if the
Libertarians vote a republican Walker
would would have it right now but uh I'm
making a joke because I understand
libertarian values and Republicans are
not the same thing yeah it's a mixed bag
too there's there's some people who lean
more to the left in the libertarian
party and some people who lean to the
right and maybe a party maybe if there's
a runoff many of these Libertarians just
vote for Walker anyway I doubt they're
going to vote Democrat yeah
uh you have a lot of crystals there too
I've got crystals
yeah it's like that's Ian's section
because it's like all
heresy yes correct
but uh enjoy your new seat okay fine hi
I'm gonna move this too A lot of people
are calling shenanigans in the chat
about Arizona right now really what are
they saying they're basically saying
that they're saying Shenanigans yeah
shenanigans
you ever go to a carnival game like
Carnival and then you yell Shenanigans
when they're clearly you know pulling BS
the carnival games I think the most fun
carnival game I ever played was was a
bunch of plates and you just throw
quarters and try and land the quarter on
the plate it's just oh I think I was
there yeah we were there for a while
yeah we want a giant monkey yep
my dog was happy what I was doing was a
couple different things I would I would
uh throw the coins I'd flat spin them
and throw them High they'll just plop
Down the Lights happened earlier I don't
know what it is the lights just cut out
yeah it's uh it's that right there the
connection is loose
uh but I don't know if you're gonna be
able to fix it it popped on earlier
maybe it will make me look like pale
actually don't know the lighting in here
everyone here looks like actually
actually the one of the one of the so uh
for those that aren't aware the lighting
in this room is actually LED strips
they're bars that click together and
they wrap around the whole uh just under
the the the ceiling you've got you've
got to push the connector in on the
right side
there you go there we go
all right yep oh it was right there
right oh that was easy good job Splurge
yeah so uh they they connect kind of
like Legos when one pops out the whole
strip will cut out and lose power
there we go man you guys all got to go
have kielbases and stuff I'm jealous
it's too late now I'm not gonna eat I
dug in your fridge for like spicy
mayonnaise how did you find it it was
actually really good yeah was it the
Dukes I don't know I just poured
Sriracha in the mayonnaise and chicken
see that's what it was I knew they were
shooting either or something that had
changed well that was good yeah that one
looked like it wasn't original Mayo but
it had like a really old expiration date
so I thought it was suss so then I found
another one oh what was the expiration
date on it like 5 22. and it's made from
soybeans and that was the one that was
out what was it was like on the counter
no it was like in the fridge oh okay
yeah but it didn't look like regular
minions it looked like you somebody mix
it with something so I'm like oh yeah
yeah no that was probably uh my secret
Family Recipe but yeah like it looked
good like I'm that's the one I wanted
but but I was I was hesitant but yeah
the secret is what you do to make the
the special secret Family Recipe is um
mix all of the condiments in their
fridge into one bottle and then what you
just put that on everything like what
like it's Mayo mustard ketchup Mayo
mustard barbecue no relish Sriracha yeah
Sriracha chili paste I mean how deep do
you go in the regular regular kimchi no
just mix that in that won't come out of
the bottle ketchup Mayo barbecue mustard
is uh usually the mix that's like the
Chick-fil-A sauce right it tastes just
like Chick-fil-A that's what yeah that's
what chicken is probably what it is
correct like the Chick-fil-A Factory
they were like what do we do with the
with the with the crust at the bottom of
the bin for all this like mixed together
and then they did it was delicious I'd
rather just have kimchi kimchi's good
kimchi is good too good what's going on
here Masters is losing by a lot wow by
uh 250 000 votes it looks like yeah but
don't we remember we just had this issue
in Arizona and then it looked like
Carrie Lake was losing losing losing and
that like two or three o'clock in the
morning for the primary she beat
everybody in one it's gonna be the same
thing with one percent reporting Tiffany
Smiley is winning the Republicans
winning in Washington yeah well that
would be great look at my phone real
quick didn't we see it wasn't the New
York New York Times saying that uh
Murray was winning Murray yeah didn't we
see that weren't we talking about that
91 chance of winning in Washington oh
these are chances I see because we
haven't started counting yeah in Nevada
there's still zero percent reporting
2024 will be interesting
so it means we gotta go through another
couple of years of this hikes man I
wonder if like this is a simulation and
we're just being tested to see how much
we're willing to tolerate
like that's the real point of this yeah
it's like everyone's really frustrated
and angry over everything that's going
on but the Democrats keep winning for
some reason
I think it's just even worse than being
a simulation I think it's just actually
real life
you know it's a test and challenge to
see what you could do in the face of all
this adversity you know that's the way
that's the positive way to see it like
hey there's a lot of things going
against us what are you going to do to
make sure that you're not affected by it
in the best possible way and there's
multiple ways of voting
that I think personally are a lot more
important than just casting a ballot in
a voting box uh where you vote where you
move
um where you pay your attention to I
think is way more important than just
The Ballot Box and I think we make those
decisions every single day and if we can
make them more consciously I think the
world would be a better place if we
would understand the consequences of our
microactions and expressions I think are
you trying to say something no I'm sorry
I thought you were just Landing in there
but uh you know to me again I I don't
like the Republicans I don't like the
Democrats I'm skeptical of all of them I
I see the true solution towards a lot of
our problems being personal small
decisions that all of us could be making
and the the food you eat the the things
you consume the things you watch
absolutely matter at the end of the day
so when you make your decision to make
them wisely and try to think about them
a little bit I'll tell you what I think
happens
what I one of the things I think
happened is that in Florida and Texas
Abbott won decisively by 800k votes so
so far with only 71 reporting in Florida
with 94 reporting DeSantis is up 1.5
million and it's because people were
leaving their blue States who agreed
with Abbott or or DeSantis and going to
Texas in Florida that was the
predominant that was like the big areas
we were going to what that means is
people in Arizona who would have
normally voted for Kerry Lake left
because of how bad things were getting
and went to places like Texas and
Florida where they were guaranteed to
win or where the very least they were
likely to win I'm not saying
definitively but I'm saying this that
probably contributed to a certain degree
I was I was so
hey 24 reporting and Christine Dresden
how you pronounce it is winning in
Oregon
73 are reporting now in uh the
Pennsylvania senate race
and Oz is gaining ground it looks like
he is he's very close Oz is 0.9 away
with 73 reporting Oz may actually take
this what do we think about 37 to 30 37
000 more votes and Oz can take this do
they do runoffs in Pennsylvania I don't
think they do do they that's Georgia but
it's the governor I didn't do
Pennsylvania no we don't do run off yeah
it doesn't do runoffs no what are we
looking at Oregon governor 24 reporting
and we have some parts of uh Portland
and uh we have Benton County Lincoln
County they're going blue how great
would it be if how great would it be if
Oregon had a had a GOP Governor that
would be spectacular after everything
that they've been through in the past
couple of years it's been such a
disaster there yeah
just like she did in the primary by the
way right I'm calling that now I
remember the primary I was shocked at
night when we were like she was down I
was like I couldn't believe it because
she's amazing and then I woke up in the
morning I was like oh she's wept why did
that happen uh like you have to see how
many late early mail-in drop-offs there
are so right now they're reporting that
the
those came in first or what yeah that so
far like Katie Hobbs has uh 484
000 and to carry Lakes 348 000 but
they're still that's early yep so oh so
the the day of hasn't tabulated yet
correct oh so Carol so yeah Carrie
Lake's gonna be fine fingers crossed
um the other thing is that I I was told
a couple hours ago that there were some
big Texas flips from D to R in in the
house yeah
let me see um house District 74 37
27 Corpus Christi area
so the Morgan LaMotta family from a well
like whatever it was beat by a
Republican
um
well they were they were up
they were up I don't know if they beat
this was a couple hours ago so maybe I'm
wrong so it looks like 63 reporting in
the 34th District it's leaning Democrat
now it's still okay in the 15th it's
leaning Republican with 74 reporting
that's really weird
and then in 60 quailar is currently
winning choir he's basically like he's
basically like a republican anyway for
the most part I mean his chief of staff
is a friend of mine and they call him
GOP Jake oh like he's basically a better
border situation too absolutely yeah
he's a good guy actually yeah
um Claire doesn't bother me that much
look at these absolutely micro
microscopic districts that just have
massive population density yeah it's
ridiculous jeez
stay racist
oh man it's all starting to come in look
at this Montana going Democrat how about
that
no really that's like 21. it's only 21.
but this is the Bozeman area so I
wouldn't be surprised if it goes
Democrat yeah Bozeman's population is
totally different now uh recently
they're probably like beginning of last
year I was up there last year too and
yeah it did feel very it's very
different very liberal yeah they just
they have a large influx of people for
the you know it is not looking good for
technomads 73 reporting and bobert is
down about 9k I shouldn't be happy about
that but I am why is that why why are
you happy about that Lisa's not a fan I
don't like her why don't you like her is
there we were at the border I told you
this border story when she with the kid
and the crying all right maybe but she
just like smack him or something no she
like fake cried dude oh she fake cried I
mean over a five-year-old and like I
have a five-year-old oh she did an AOC
like we we were all like at the border
and like I actually was one pound on the
bus like they're crossing here like
let's get out and talk to them and
there's like this poor five-year-old and
he legit was being used he clearly
wasn't like a kid of the people that
they were with you know and so we go
back to where like Customs and Border
Patrol are like taking like doing intake
or whatever she calls the camera over
and she like meals over and she like
starts me crying and then sees the
cameras roll she's like done and she's
like on to like doing whatever it was
it was gross honestly like and
I don't know I take kids seriously like
I don't care if you're a migrant child
or whatever you're still a five-year-old
like you didn't ask to be there right
you're not to be exploited I I wasn't a
fan and I I didn't like the way she was
so like camera hungry like she just is
inauthentic to me and I think that that
reflects that like I want people that
are that are Republican but that are in
it for the right reasons and I mean Poco
one yeah she's celebrating right now
yeah yeah with 57 of the votes 54 is in
and hocal has 59.6 to zeldin's 40.3
she's just a terrible terrible leader
she's probably gonna clip me saying that
well she's finally elected
finally congratulations finally Kathy
you want something I don't know who
elected her or why or what they think
that they're getting in this Governor
fetterman just gained a little bit and
now Oz is within one point from point
nine so it got a little worse for for
odds with 74 reporting that's like
that's a close one that's a close one
whoa California they're calling it for
the Democrats in the Senate already
that's so surprising yeah
shocker wow
hey I mean actually though it's 59 to 40
percent so that's actually bad for
Democrats it's like it's like a two to
One Republic Democrat state
North Carolina they called it for Ted
Bud whoa there you go hey North Carolina
that looks like it's going to be a
pickup then isn't it no so they're not
still not calling it over the New York
Times
for uh is that a pickup that was right
or no was that yeah
was that Republican or Democrat
Governor uh North Carolina yeah
was it Republican was it an empty seat
or something I don't know why I'm not
even seeing it on the Reuters map
North Carolina it's a state I know but
okay but look look see how it's gray
oh what are you you're on Governors yeah
I'm on Governors and he's running for
Senate oh
normally when I was going on off 20
minutes ago Walker is still within 0.4
of taking this with no runoff
come on man he's got to come through
there
yeah should be interesting and another
Minnesota way down way down
Oregon they just called it for Ron Wyden
Ron Wyden wins Oregon Senate
how's Oregon coming in before Minnesota
like there's nothing even there
Minnesota is not not uh there's no Tim
Walls that's governor governor right yes
we just did the same thing I'm so glad
you did the same thing he's up 20 points
I just love this stuff it's driving me
crazy
they should just have it all why can't I
just click on the state and then have it
all listed there
right that would be a different map you
could launch that map next season next
next election season you can launch I
have no Tech skills um I need to learn
to code yeah I could do this map on
paper really well like
yeah all right so here's the current the
currently we're looking at 106
Republicans have flipped six seats
so that looks like it's they're
basically getting it the Senate has not
changed there has been no uh no no gain
or loss for either side
not looking good we got four more seats
to go well we got more than four more
seats but I really care about Masters
and like like yeah but so far Democrats
have gained two states governorships and
Republicans have lost two states
that's a shame oh yeah
the media propaganda machine is strong
yep that's the only thing it's culture
man the Republicans
or is it big Tech social media is it the
corporate Media or is it what people see
online and what's curated to them and I
think we also have a we also people are
not on Twitter well no we also should
consider you know our experience online
is curated for us other people's
experience is in their own Echo chamber
and their own bubbles so they're
probably seeing a totally different
reality than we are and that's
controlled by you know Facebook
Instagram Tick Tock you name it you
don't see the prices at the grocery
store they don't see the prices at the
gas station I think they do but but I
think also you know the the the mass
hypnosis mind control does work very
effectively especially when it comes to
ramping up people's emotions and trying
to get rid of their logic and then
talking about you know Maga dangerous
and abortion and women's rights I think
were their key issues that they were
running on and then we had people like
Lindsey Graham coming out and of course
kind of playing into that during this
election cycle so that this was their
strategy was it an effective one that
worked I think it's worth considering
right now as it looks like yeah it has
and again our perceptions are are skewed
so is there so so what we're seeing
online is show I think what we're seeing
today is the importance of of big Tech
social media with their influence on
this I think yeah and it is big I think
you also look on the bright side of a
fetterman winning in Pennsylvania if he
does
I want to see him be president think
about all the memes Eclipse so right
right now Oz is within 0.9 again yeah
the memes will be insane Clips are gonna
be crazy if we think the Biden Clips are
funny can you imagine what those
veterans but just but that's for
Democrats but they're gonna it's gonna
be sad but the thing is like look at how
well they spun the whole fetterman thing
right like every he clearly has this
this brain damage situation from his
stroke
down on his neck yeah whatever what's
going on there but then also you saw the
Democrats and leftists jumped out right
away and said that criticizing his you
know disability
they did this whole thing with it and
that was clearly really effective saying
that fetterman was not actually you know
suffering the ill effects of a stroke
but that he had this uh auditory
processing deficiency which if anyone's
seen it that's not what's going on and
that he was so brave for being out there
right regardless of you know whatever
Walker has dropped oh he isn't now point
eight percent away uh point eight
percent away from avoiding runoff which
is is not looking good it's getting
worse and there's 88 reporting so it's
looking like it's going to be a runoff
not all bad though if the Libertarians
do end up going Republican then he wins
so
we will see but it's going to require
everybody to turn out again and it's
going to get crazy it's again the media
is going to go nuts you saw how that
happened last time yep
I don't know I'm getting more black
Builders tonight's going on like I can
tell they're like no experience yeah I
mean it is kind of crazy that uh uh so
so here we go if we take a look at the
the meter here while the Senate forecast
for the New York Times does show the
meter is 50 50. you can see there's
actually more opportunity still for
Republicans within their range to win
despite them saying it's a toss-up but
their their meter is suggesting it's
more likely to go Democrat despite the
fact there's there's more opportunities
for republicans
so look at that it's
shifted slightly to the left
the house I think is is a done deal like
we basically know they've already
they've already picked up six seats
they're likely taking the house and
that's good I mean it's a midterm
election it's a president's first term
what more did you expect it's not like
investigations all right help or at
least be entertaining at least be
entertaining
yeah
hopefully more entertaining than the
January 6th committee
which was just tedious the entire time
yeah and that will be over now right
like we have an end well what's going to
happen now is they're going to have
inquiries on Hunter Biden and then
YouTube's gonna make a new rule saying
that if you question the Integrity of
the Biden family they'll ban you um
right they'll have to do that and then
we'll just all have to keep going to
rumble here's a question I heard that
like accounts that I know that happening
be demonetized and stuff are like when
the Twitter when Elon I guess bought
Twitter that they started getting like
remonetized on YouTube like when Elon
brought Twitter all of a sudden like
along with that people were getting
remonetized on Facebook and re-monetized
on Twitter I mean on YouTube notice any
of that I don't know I've actually been
getting demonetized more uh right before
the election than I've than I've ever
been in the past three or four years
like Elijah got remonetized on things
like right when the Twitter stuff
happened well I do think that with Elon
Musk putting his foot down and the woke
panicking and fleeing Twitter or getting
banned and Twitter's growth growing I
think the real redwave might actually
just be 2024 and I think what we're
seeing here is just relatively similar
what happened in 2018 you can't expect
much it's not looking like you know the
Democrats were like Blue Wave Blue Wave
part of the reason for you know
championing the idea of a major victory
is to Rally people to go vote so if
Republicans get the house then we'll
probably see some inquiries
investigations people are asking
questions and then like I said earlier
we're probably ahead of the market so
maybe we'll see the swing go a little
bit harder in 2024 with like a trump
Resurgence or something but I don't know
at this point looking at how well
Florida did it's like DeSantis is
probably the better candidate
yeah cernovich had a very interesting
comment on this he just tweeted a couple
of moments ago Trump as king maker or a
viable 2024 general election candidate
is over as of tonight that's according
to Mike cernovich what he just tweeted
okay but like like again it doesn't
concern you that like uh Ken Griffin is
like ready to invest uh what is it 60
million in um
because these are like the right like
these are the people that we as populist
or whatever want out of politics now
they're backing our our guy our DeSantis
like because maybe they realized you
it's either him or Trump
take your pick
and they're alive yeah but then but then
now DeSantis is beholden to them where
Trump's not I I disagree I think if they
do go for DeSantis it's more likely that
it's the best we can do and he's better
than Trump because Trump's a Loose
Cannon and uh Trump was more of a
disrupter so some of these individuals
could be like we could maybe calm down
the situation and not have it as
disrupted with with Trump in power and
have less chaos that could be
potentially the thing you know it but
you know what you're getting with Trump
with the santis you don't know if he's
gonna go along to get along you don't
know if he's gonna you know
go with the GOP establish establishment
that's been selling out the base for
years if Trump couldn't beat Biden why
do you think he'll be the next candidate
I I think Trump rallies Democrats it's
it's like I do agree I do agree that he
I mean look we're he draws them out we
were seeing polling that was predicting
like 538 showed that it was it was
likely going to skew more favorably than
it was it's it's looking like a
referendum on Trump they said this is
like basically with Trump for the most
part what they campaigned on January 6th
heavily Non-Stop and and Biden came out
and said Maga Republicans are a threat
to them and then you had Korean John
bahir say mega mega Republicans which
was really nice but like how many people
actually like when you when they were
doing like exit poll polling stuff like
nobody cared about January 6. like it's
not a topic well but you know what like
a lot of Democrats do care about January
6 even though it's not really a top
issue for anyone else you know and so
maybe those people turned out I mean I
know that there's some Democrats in my
life who were glued to the TV during the
January 6 and I'd just be like you are
kidding with that right like this is a
joke this must be a joke Fox News is so
uh so staged sorry go ahead Fox News
just said Oz is not doing as well as
Trump did two years ago in Pennsylvania
when he quote lost the state so that's
what Fox News is reporting look at
looking at the numbers still coming in
from Pennsylvania and obviously saying
that it's not looking good for us I
would be embarrassed to be from
Pennsylvania
well look you gotta lie that's how they
win right they have to lie and make sure
people don't realize how bad it is and
it's amazing we saw a lot of lies
leading up to this no that's all it is
all I do is lie and then and then while
they're lying they go you're lying and
you're like so great here's the video I
don't like what's it there's there's
this viral video where um I can't
remember who did it might have been from
Flacco's talks or something this guy
asks people do Democrats deny elections
and they'll say no and he goes I have
150 examples of Democrats denying
elections can I show you and they go no
that was James yeah James Luke oh there
you go yeah yeah they're like yeah
these people are an occult it's like
hello friend please watch evidence no no
okay because we you know we we destroyed
religion we removed God from everything
and so it's been replaced with uh with
uh an allegiance to narcissism and uh
this is the religion and we are breeding
narcissists collect the misfit says
DeSantis won his race by 20 points all
of Trump's competitive endorsements are
imploding look past the cult of
personality hmm
yeah they're saying that with Carrie
like damn right now but she's gonna win
and that'll take that right off the
table
it's close we're gonna see it's very
close I mean it was close in the primary
20 points no like no joke to Santas with
94 reporting is up nearly 20 points wow
that's embarrassing yeah he got
obliterate it
was like what he's doing isn't even that
complicated like like what he's actually
doing is it's it's awesome he's amazing
but like that should be the starting
point right to what a republican person
is doing right that shouldn't be
exceptional that should be the basics
yeah you know I want to move to Wyoming
at some point and like you know I look
it up yeah and and I go skiing there all
the time I spend a lot of time in nature
so it's I spent um about 250 days a year
of nature on average even though anyway
so yes I drive the country I'm in nature
I ski every ski resort I was always in
nature going to every National Park Yeah
so basically
um
so I'm thinking of Moving to Wyoming but
the governor's not even ready to fully
remove masks you know or or or yeah I
mean it was like I know people there who
are they masking I mean this is what I'm
saying right now Jackson Hole which is
the you know one of the trendy parts of
Wyoming sure good place to move to the
great skiing
um I think that they were kind of
uniquely saying that for like the
tourism component but it's like why
isn't there someone like DeSantis in
Wyoming but that should be the bare
minimum so I don't know maybe in 10 or
20 years from now it'll catch up and
there'll be more people like them so New
York Times says 49 Senate seats have
been one or our favorite to win by
Republicans 48 by democrats and there
are three toss-ups
we have reports that uh Oz will be
addressing supporters in a few minutes
oh
where he's not conceding is he already I
don't know I just saw that I would be
surprised if he can seats I wouldn't be
surprised
you know do you think he was hoping to
be president that's what that was his
end game
uh maybe he's any anybody at his level
has a big ego and has big Ambitions I
bet you thought if you could win this he
could become yeah that's what I say
depending on how he did this if he would
go to the next The Next Step Up
basically I think he was trying to gauge
his support and if he had support in
this maybe he would try but all right oh
Abram's conceded oh wow wow
what if she just goes nuts she starts
throwing stuff it's really too bad if
she concedes I was looking forward to
Maura Stacy Abramson conceded the
election
[Applause]
thank you Daddy
it is good to be here in this moment oh
is it surrounded by your love and
support
and let me Begin by offering
congratulations to Governor Brian Kemp
oh look at that wow she did it our soul
our state has experienced one
soul-crushing crisis after another over
the past few years
but even during these trying times the
fighting Spirit of Georgia has prevailed
we've seen what's possible when we stand
up for our neighbors and protect each
other
we've made sacrifices we've pitched in
we've seen each other's fights as our
own and we've done things we never
thought we could
it is in the spirit of that endurance
and that persistence that I decided
again to run for governor okay do we
want to listen to this not really really
not really I'm surprised she conceded
that's pretty big because she didn't do
that last time is she actually conceding
yeah she did she said yeah
cernovich says some clear takeaways New
Yorkers want crime it's who they are
stay out of cities Arizona today shows
2024 is unsafe indictments must happen
highest priority Trump can't carry a
general DeSantis can pull independent
voters flipped Miami-Dade it's his time
yo yeah I agree he flipped Tampa and
Miami we were talking about this earlier
this was the main discussion that we
were talking about the santis and Trump
the future of the political party and
it's it's a battle this is something
that I was looking at for a very long
time I'm seeing it right now and I and I
think it's you know what I've been what
I've been kind of seeing has been kind
of been coming to fruition I think
DeSantis is going to win
2024 yeah
I think he has he has a very good chance
Drew you're coming back in here yeah I
don't think they can muster up against
the sand is what they could against
Trump correct Trump they just they're
just people don't like him
DeSantis the average person's gonna be
like I don't know who that is and
they're gonna be like he's bad like do
who Trump was on The Simpsons they made
fun of him people knew his name he was a
celebrity Justin the average person is
getting sick of the culture Warner just
wants it to wind down I think the
average person has always hated the
culture War but the problem is also
their kids were getting double these
books right and then they were like why
is this happening Make It Stop could you
see DeSantis picking Tulsi gabbard as a
VP to try to calm down the culture war
and just kind of people are just sick of
fighting that's one possibility
like people like me you would you'd piss
the base off but maybe but you maybe
Society right now just as sick of this
and just wants to I see it in the chats
like comments videos where people talk
about it all the time no they're tired
of the culture War I see that all the
time yeah it's it's obvious it's the
truth everyone is tired of it yeah I'm
tired of it but I also don't want that
smut being forced down my kids throat do
you ever feel like it's got to cool off
at some point like yeah where's the end
game of this oh what is this what I
think about too that's and that's what
that's where we should be going well you
know it should be yeah like I didn't say
this world I want to have him but I
don't see another way out of it maybe
you told CVP no no because I'm never
gonna yeah like they're never gonna stop
you think they're just gonna like leave
us alone
what is a Tulsi VP have to do with with
solving any problem it just begins to
cool things off no but she's a
republican you're like if a republican
runs as a VP that'll change it's just
not it's just not I'm not saying it's a
one you know magic pill but it just
begins to slow these books are
everywhere
why would a republican running for
Republican office
slow anything down I don't understand
what you're trying to say what would you
guys say would start to cool things down
getting rid of like naked pictures of
kids it won't that cools down the
culture it won't I mean if you if if you
understand uh
if you look at what's been going on for
the past 10 years then you'd realize
that this country is completely
bifurcated culturally that you can walk
up to someone say can I please show you
a video of Democrats denying an election
they will say no outright there's
nothing you can do well I learned that
from you four years ago right and I
started telling my friends that they
didn't believe it and I agreement but
what's what's the way out of this
I think I think what I would advocate
for to people is to focus on having
families having kids uh instilling your
values and your kids getting your kids
out of schools getting out of cities
that's the way out of it the way out of
it is not going to people who are
already culturally Divergent and begging
them to come together the solution is
having a bunch of kids so that in 20
years they vote your way I think what
happened in Florida is significant and
uh you know I know you brought up uh
Tulsi and DeSantis this is something
that I've been seeing online even just a
couple days ago saying that this could
be a potential ticket together because
if you look at Florida it's a purple
state it can go either way remember
you've also had everybody from New York
and everywhere else that didn't want
these radical you know Democrat policies
flooding into there too so it's not like
it's like a purple state that he just
won all these Independents from you've
also had lots of conservatives fleeing
other states and then migrating heavily
Democratic areas are voting for him like
in Miami and I think that's a lot more
significant than a lot of people led on
when it come comes to the bigger
possibilities of what could happen in
2020 I don't think like a lot of
conservatives also moved into Miami
um I mean I I've been to Miami and it's
it's it's crime ridden in in many places
it's it like like South Beach isn't it I
heard the mayor like brought crime down
like 30 or something like that not if
you go to South Beach the one particular
area is is absolutely crazy the mayor
there also has like a a Bitcoin currency
and an altcoin currency he's an
interesting guy uh but but for for that
place that that went 20 points in favor
of Hillary to now vote DeSantis I think
it's something to to consider here
especially if he's going to try to
create more of a middle line not a hard
Republican kind of ticket but a middle
line ticket with potentially Tulsi on
there who again is a CFR member who was
anti-gun now she's pro-gun so so there
could be a potential for this that that
I think is worth considering because it
might bridge that Gap that you might be
talking about I'm not saying it's a
magic pill I'm just saying I'm I'm PR
I'm I think you're right I'm probably
class being stress an extent but it just
there's got to be something to cool this
off the average person who I know
doesn't care about this and we don't
want this yes yes but listen listen
the average person wants their kids to
go to a good school the average person
wants to put gas in their tank to go to
work policies of Democrats are making
that worse and worse the reason youngkin
won in Virginia is because parents
started learning about the smut that was
being put in front of their kids it
doesn't matter if you want the culture
war or not it's been in front of your
face for 10 years and the problem is
regular people have consistently ducked
they they are they're putting they're
they're putting the signs above their
home hoping that they will be passed
over but it will not happen the far left
they they March the neighborhoods with
fire bombs and and and rocks and sticks
and crowbars and these people think if I
just agree with them they won't smash at
my house until they do and they do so if
you look at Berkeley
this should be like you really want to
wake your kids up bring them to Berkeley
every single storefront has signs in
their Windows begging for forgiveness
and espousing whatever ideology they
dictate because I'll put it simply
anybody who owns a storefront knows this
if if you own a store let's say you sell
cheeseburgers
and you put an American flag
hanging in front of your store at three
in the morning one person in a black
mask throws a brick through your window
what will the police do about that
nothing nothing and how much will that
cost you to fix thousands thousands so
these people would rather put up a BLM
sign instead of an American flag because
they know there's no justice and there's
no way to stop it that is just going to
keep happening the solution
get out of cities
focus on making money
stand up for what you believe in but
build this parallel economy out use
become a member at timcast.com using
using parallel economy we use parallel
economy Dan bongino co-founded this
company it's through it's with Rumble
and that's the thing that we need to do
start building up our resources our
manufacturing base and have kids
cue all the comments saying Tim doesn't
have kids I get it but my point is true
regardless of what it is I'm doing it is
true and my personal business and my
personal business but uh I have to we
can just pretend but have kids right
have a lot of them and then in 20 years
all of those kids will vote for the
right thing so I have I have three kids
and I made sure to take them um out of
school for about half a year I took them
around the country I took them climbing
into the mountains took them around you
know safely with grizzly bears took them
skiing double black skiing and I tell
them every day you know being a coward
is worse than death and I make them
repeat this over and over I bring my
kids up in front of crowds they're
they're literally in front of two of my
11 year old kids in front of a 200
person crowd leading seminars right I
explained to him about the media I show
all this stuff I show him what it means
to be a leader we work really really
hard on this and he still get straight
A's and he's still in all the gifted
programs right even with missing all
that school so it's one of these things
where shocking right but it's like just
experiencing the real world you know I
also bring them to homeless areas I show
them what homelessness is I explain to
him that he's not getting a penny out of
me when he's older that although we are
you know in our position that he is
broke in effect you know I'm like no
we're this way but you're broke until
you work you know I want I want him to
make his first Million by about 15.
um I'm gonna show him how to do that
um I'm gonna bring him around mentors
get him around the right people so I'm
working on this right
um and and I agree with you that there's
probably going to wind up being a
parallel to come you're the person that
I learned that from and I tell to all my
friends
um but what are some immediate things
that we could do to cool things down as
well not a 20-year thing I don't I don't
get your kids out of schools get out of
cities they disengage so focus on I
would advocate for look we're we're out
in West Virginia now we're building new
facilities we're looking at starting
businesses so that we can expand the
economy in these areas we can create
jobs in these areas make life better for
people in these areas it's
non-confrontational it's not it's not a
conflict it is just building something
nice and doing something good that's
what people should be doing make money
have a family and then start building
businesses and creating parallel
economies for I I recommend people come
to West Virginia it's a great
opportunity second most Trump supporting
state in the country cheap land start
building stuff but what happens just
like in the cities when their
democrat-run cities turn to crap and
then they're spilling over into the
suburbs and it's leaking out everywhere
else what do you mean like look at
Philadelphia right Philadelphia is gross
and for a while we were like gentrifying
and getting nice or whatever fine but
now they're they are the carjackings and
all the clothes
I actually almost got credit check there
okay it's starting out though into like
into the the counties that are not even
part of Philadelphia County it's in
Devon now it's in like that's why we
left because I was in South Jersey and
decided to get up because the crime was
spreading but uh but that's gonna happen
anyway I didn't say go to suburbs I said
go to West Virginia buy cheap land all
right and when they destroy the cities
and then the suburbs and then they come
for your land like it's you'll be in
West Virginia with a Barrett M82 and
you'll say I think I think it comes down
to making entrepreneurship cool
self-reliance cool I used to live on a
ranch with a big strong man with lots
and lots of guns like that's that's like
that's what needs to happen
like to do okay this is what happens in
Detroit right now the industry in
Detroit was destroyed so people middle
class people fled
the city can't sustain itself the water
system can't sustain itself when you
build a city that can accommodate a
million people
you have to build a water system water
pipes you split the cost of that system
as a tax on all the people who live
there so if it costs a million bucks per
month to run everyone's got to pay one
dollar well half a million people leave
now the price has doubled for everybody
it's two dollars and all of a sudden
they're like well I can't afford two
dollars that's double the cost
then another 250 000 leave and that's
three dollars now you're like we have
the highest get the highest water prices
this is actually what happened in the
Detroit area when the city was big and
bustling because the Auto industry they
could accommodate this massive
infrastructure
there are actually rumors I don't know
if it's true but I had a friend from
Michigan who told me the police would
burn down houses around Detroit because
they were dangerous falling apart and
being used for crime and there was never
any chance for repairing them no one
wanted them they were worth nothing so
they would go around burning them down
periodically I don't know if that's true
it's just what the the locals would tell
me when you know we'd be hanging out
nearby I would hang out in like Grand
Rapids so
when people flee because of the collapse
of Industry eventually the city becomes
completely unsustainable everyone there
starts doing substantially worse and it
becomes a wasteland
stop supporting these places with your
money stop being the person who's
enabling all of that I agree with that
you get out of these cities and you say
look if you live in New York you want
crime I'm not I'm I'm not gonna mince
words I know you listening in New York
may have voted for zeldin but the people
in this city overwhelmingly want
lockdowns and crime 30 people last month
were pushed in front of trains in New
York City
you should not be there if you don't
agree with this at this point I don't
like the idea of saying cut tail and run
when I what but but there's there's a
point where strategic Retreat leads to
Victory vote with your feet you you get
out of this place say you've got it and
what you can do as a Pioneer is come to
places like West Virginia or even
Kentucky or Tennessee find cheap and
available land West Virginia is just
Rife with it and then start building
something I've heard from so many people
who say they've begun homesteading
that's a great start
it's an excellent start so one of the
reasons I wanted to come to West
Virginia we're originally going to
launch our business and expand in New
Jersey I'm glad that didn't happen
because that was a terrible idea and so
we're expanding in West Virginia where
the towns are very small but the land is
cheap there's its proximity Is is there
it's not too far away from airports not
too far away from other big cities it's
a great opportunity to start bringing
jobs to a lot of people who have been
negatively impacted by failed Democrat
policies particularly with the energy
energy policies and the opioid crisis
and so I'm looking really I'm looking
forward to not just expanding this
business but we're actually looking at
purchasing a building and doing a
storefront a new show selling products
and just
building and it you know
they say Society grows great when people
plant trees whose shade they know they
will never sit beneath maybe we launched
this Media company we launched some
stores we build culture in West Virginia
and 100 years I'm after I'm dead it's
new Hollywood
maybe and then the values that are born
here will expand and this will be a
hollywood-like ecosystem that has
libertarian-minded values and not
socialist-minded values do you think
that that uh the individual listening to
collectivize maybe then
like is that maybe the problem right now
with social media so a little bit so
lending itself to collectivism a little
bit the challenge is that individualists
don't collectivize they don't organize
they don't boycott they say uh let's not
do that so maybe maybe that has to
happen also I really loved what you said
but I was just just for a added question
how is that different than people
leaving YouTube and going to rumble
like going to West Virginia for example
so I live in the Hollywood Hills I live
in LA so I get to associate with a lot
of other people in entertainment
industry things like that and so as soon
as I would leave say that I do go to
Wyoming which I've been thinking about
well then now my influence is no longer
in Hollywood right so that's kind of
like what you guys were saying with you
but are you being suppressed by
Hollywood or are you are you changing
their minds um we're definitely changing
their minds I think that a lot of people
now like The Cutting Edge that are
Forward Thinking are thinking very
differently I think what happens is that
um
and what do you think is the percentage
of people that are just deeply deeply
locked in a group thing what do you guys
think they're just in group things so in
other words they're mostly they're only
willing to think that's the same thing
then I will agree with you and perhaps
another potential outside of building a
parallel economy is more of a cultural
Invasion so if you're willing to remain
in a state full of high crime and
horrible policies
but continue to expand your business and
gain influence
that's also a good thing what also
depends how much money you have right so
if you have a lot of money and you're in
LA or New York or San Francisco it's a
paradise right if you have money in La
it is a paradise there's nothing in
Austin or even in Miami as good as
what's in La if you're rich okay
um if you're a person of typical means
you're dealing with a lot of crime right
that was something that came up in the
uh in the in the video from yesterday I
was saying how I love La I'm talking
about the crime they're like why'd you
say loves LA and likes the crime well it
depends what neighborhood you're in
right if you're in a gated community it
is Paradise if you're in Malibu it's
Paradise Hollywood Hills it's Paradise
there's nothing yeah Beverly there's
nothing like it beautiful that there's
police Etc that make sure that there's
no homo sequel no crime there's no like
destitution anywhere on those streets
anywhere in those neighborhoods and
that's the part of La that is but people
that are voting in these bubbles are
voting for they're not voting for like
you know 6th Street or seventh street
they're not they're not looking at those
situations down to another they rarely
even go there if they ever did they
would just they live in their bubble
they don't have to ever go yeah I think
is also a misconception about people
think of leftism as you know they
associate that to redistribution of
wealth they don't realize it's often
very top down right so so it's it's
basically yeah it's basically that the
ultra Rich get money right so I was just
in Martha's Vineyard I was just in
Nantucket I was you know I live in the
in some of those nicer areas in LA right
so it's like I'm around people that are
like that and I see those bubbles and
it's completely crazy and the amount of
wealth that is kind of you know combined
into one little place it's just a
completely different world it is it is
and that it may if you've seen it you
understand why they were made in this
bubble why it's so easy for them to make
these decisions and why they think the
way that they think because you
understand what why they're thinking
these things yeah it's also it's also
reinforced I think also you know what I
ask you drew you know why you do what
you do the first thing that you say is
I'm a Christian right so you have the
belief that what you're doing will be
judged by God after you die so you're
not as much in the body you're more in
the spirit and that's motivating you
right but a lot of people they don't
have that understanding they're more in
the body and so they're saying well what
you know what can I get right now right
I assume that you do what you do because
of what happens when the body dies is
that
accurate well in a Christian biblical
perspective my sins have been judged at
the cross so everything I do after that
is because of grace and the gift that
God has given me of Salvation and I'll
be judged for rewards not to get into
heaven when I see him face to face but
because the new life I've been given I'm
now responsible uh to really do the most
I can with what he's given me moving
forward now that I'm born again um I
think uh that was February 1st 2012 when
I gave my life to Jesus Christ the real
question is how do you how do you
how do you get someone out of a cult
right yeah
step one yeah I'm serious number one and
you separate them from the cult but with
phones you can't anymore yes so how do
you how do you get someone
effectively out of a cult that doesn't
even know they're in a cult
that is fully functioning for the cult
without even realizing it what do you
think are the main elements of the
culture I think New York is the perfect
example right because what I was
watching with Kathy hulkel and all the
propaganda that these people were
speaking during this whole midterm
campaigns all this
they effectively created this problem
right defunded the police the crime is
out of control the lockdown's added to
that they're releasing criminals and
pedophiles out onto the street because
we don't want them to get coveted and
all that crap right they created this
massive problem right which they know
was destabilization in New York
so now in the midterms Kathy holkle
mayor Adams their narrative went from we
know there's crime and then they shifted
and said it's because of gun crime that
was that was the the the pivot that they
took which was interesting but that's
part of the cult-like propaganda because
the same people that were isolated and
abused in New York that haven't fleed
yet that are still Allegiant to the cult
that slapped on The Masks took multiple
Jabs because they were afraid that they
were going to lose their jobs their
children are being targeted all these
crazy things the riots were going on
these people that stick with the cult
they still stay with the cult at this
point what I'm saying is they stay
Allegiant to the narratives because they
don't even realize that they're being
isolated and abused every step of the
way it's through fear look how they
switched and pivoted that message so
effectively how did they go from we
started this problem but it's because of
the guns we're gonna solve it an abuser
okay an abuser will always isolate
you're thinking a conservative and
abuser no I'm not I'm thinking as an
individual that has been abused before
when an abuser isolates you this is what
they do through fear they get you to
believe that they are the only ones that
can get you in a situation and outside
of a situation through fear and through
manipulation over things that is how
these people are being dealt with and
that is why it is repetitive like
Stockholm they believe that no matter
what happens their overlords will take
care of them no matter what no they
don't even if they are the ones that are
causing the problem that is the way
annual simulation that we are
experiencing in the way it works in New
York is that someone is sitting on their
couch watching office reruns on Netflix
or whatever it is now it's on Netflix
and their friend goes you're voting
Democrat right in the goat sure
yeah they don't even think about it
that's it there's no more thought or
it's what what we see a lot of in these
places especially Universal mail and
voting is their friend who is zealous
will be like you felt your ballot and
they'll go oh I didn't like you're gonna
fill it out right and be like oh yeah
sure I'll do it right now a Democrat
right here you go cool they're doing it
because their friends are doing it
that's it they don't know anything if
you walk up to them and ask them who's
running for governor they'll be like I
don't know but like who was Ocasio
Cortez running against I don't know
which policy of aocs do you like she's
she's like gonna get health care and
stuff they don't even know
that's what I started saying I said
they're in a cult but they're Allegiant
to the cult and they don't even know
that they are all right but but what I
was disagreeing with we said that they
they look to their leaders if the
leaders and take care of them they don't
even know or think the leader exists
it's they're just marching along that's
my point and their friends are like
we uh we're going to vote Democrat I
remember one hour you're saying that
they're very apathetic right no no no no
no no no no no no no no no
they want their they want to just do
what their friends tell them they're
supposed to do
that's what they all are doing that's
what their sole motivation is they can't
think it's but but even group they might
be an overstatement it's just social
groups that's it and because the social
Norm of New York is vote Democrat many
of them will just do it and not think
about it and if you ask them why they
voted they'll be like what do you mean
it's a cult it's my point right there's
there's no there's no you know you're in
a cult no and my point is they're not
going I hope leader keeps me safe some
people are but most of them are just
like my friend voted Democrat
and then you're like so what are you
hoping to happen and just you know
Republicans are bad it's just more
simple as I think what Tim is saying
it's just way more there's way less
thought going into it it's just like
this simple as making sure that my
friends did this so I'm gonna do this
too I actually haven't actually thought
that the average that is true under the
surface the average under the surface of
that of that apathy is the belief that
they'll be okay if they just vote and
that way and the average person in New
York if you are if you're part of a
friend group there's going to be a
social structure and if you're the cool
well-known popular guy and you say I
don't know I'm probably gonna vote for
zeldon because you know they'll go oh
for real yeah I was thinking about that
too
that's it yeah so this this is the
challenges that you know in 2020 we saw
a group think versus people who see for
them think for themselves as becoming
really the main issue of the entire year
right is like do you think for yourself
or do you go in a group thing do you
believe that two plus two is four or
five so what what I think is happening
is um
somebody's thought process like like
what I tend to study is I like to go
inside people's heads right like
sometimes when I ask you questions I'm
saying can we go into the other person's
lens of the world right how are they
seeing it so I keep asking myself that
how are they seeing it and I try to
really have a deep deep awareness of how
the other person is seeing it even that
Trump conversation with the uh the the
uh rioting and all that stuff okay I'm
just asking myself how's the other
person seeing it so what I see in a lot
of people is that they're not capable of
thinking is this true all that they're
thinking is does this keep me safe so I
in my view there's two types of people
that can say is this true what is
somebody who's very very confident
that'd be somebody like yourself you're
just really confident so like even when
I when I talk to you you're like I talk
to this person they don't understand
this I talk to this person they don't
understand this it's like the curse of
intelligence because you're doing your
own research and I think I think you're
projecting right now it could be when
you when you say you know like these
people want to feel safe I'm telling you
they don't feel anything well okay
we got to finish the point at some point
okay so the the because otherwise we're
just not hitting it so the main thing
that I've seen is that if somebody feels
confident in themselves then they can
think for themselves because they're not
afraid of being attacked to think for
themselves no you're already making it
well let me just finish the point though
so then the other one would be if they
have a spiritual connection you know
Drew you're a confident guy you also
have a spiritual connection so you care
about whether or not what you think is
accurate but what I see in a lot of
people is what they're thinking is does
the group think this like how do I just
twist my thoughts to stay within the
bandwidth of what it is that the group
thinks how do they go past that they get
scared how do you convince a dog to vote
for a Republican or a Democrat
I have no idea that's a great question I
wouldn't well put yourself in the dog's
shoes right
how do you how do you get that dog to
food right and then and what happens
when you tell the dog go vote Democrat
what does a dog do
wants food crap on the floor so what
you're doing is you're an intelligent
guy and so you're assuming these other
people have the same capabilities as you
do in terms of thought process
but there's a lot of people just watch
these videos from like fleka's talks
these people do not think the way you
think they do when he goes when it's not
flakka it's the other guy you know who
works games
who else does it James flaccus um
Savannah Hernandez
when you see
how they do these man on the street
interviews
when they talk to someone in Times
Square and ask them the question
you have to realize like these people
I'm not trying to be mean to them but
they don't think the way you do in terms
of a you know a plus b equals c or point
A to point B to point C they don't think
at all and it's I mean I know there's a
lot of mean-spirited Man in The View
interview man on the street interviews
that Target people for a lack of
knowledge like what's the capital of of
uh you know of Uzbekistan or something
they're going to be like I don't know or
they might say like name a country that
begins with the letter U and they'll go
uh and then you go United States oh I
got you no no these questions are
actually like a lot scarier and these
people like it's just I watch these
videos I was like there's no way it's
less about them being afraid or fearful
and more about them being a slave to
their desires they're a slave to their
desires that's what 90 of the population
is they they do not have a higher God
they do not have anything else you're
overthinking to be happy just want to
get their drugs or their friends to like
them or the likes on Facebook they're
assigned to their desires you ever play
a video game yeah what's your favorite
video game uh Horizon zero Dawn oh very
very good game
um the name name two characters in
Horizon zero down Eloy
um obvious choice
I'm not a good guy with names I don't
know all right how about
um the let's just say I don't know the
names of the actual robots but uh
there's that giant uh Tyrannosaurus
robot you fought right how do you play
as that
I don't know well you've played the game
you beat it right how do you play the
game as the T-Rex I wouldn't know well
you can't okay but have you tried
convincing the T-Rex to vote Republican
no this is an NPC it's it looks like
it's functioning you say these people
are slaves to their desires I also
disagree I don't think they're slaves to
anything I think
they're NPCs you go to them and they'll
say I just do what what people do
there's no deeper thought there's no
deeper Quest there's no deeper meaning
yeah some people but everybody have that
in that what I see is you'll be talking
to someone and there is a light in the
eyes but as soon as you go outside the
bandwidth of what they're allowed to
talk about you'll see the retreat and
they even change their tone right so
they're like oh hey Tim what's up and
then you go a little bit outside and
they're like well I think and then they
go into NPC mode there's a reason the
NCAA became so prominent because people
started to recognize that there's there
are some people where like you mentioned
the light in their eyes there's
something you can see when you're
talking to someone that even if you
disagree and even if you really hate
each other you know there's a
conversation happening but the reason
the NPC meme emerged isn't just because
someone wanted to insult someone it's
because they realized some people just
weren't processing things the way they
did and they felt like they were talking
to an NPC in a video game but no matter
what people are going to pursue their
own interests and they are going to do
whatever it is that makes them happy
like it's just like in basic econ right
that everybody is self-interested and so
while they may be a non-npc or whatever
they're still going to pursue the little
tiny things in their lives that make
them happy so you know rather like
sitting there and playing on their
computer and watching video games
instead of doing work all day is still
them pursuing their self-interest
because that in that moment makes them
more happy they don't have the foresight
like you're saying to think through
those things but they're still pursuing
their desires and they're a slave to
them rather than being a slave to a
higher being or having some other
calling in life they're they are only
pursuing their own happiness therefore
will never be free yeah versus being
surrendered to God not a slave to God
what kind of person do you have in your
mind Tim like just someone that's watch
Fleck is not not interested in politics
at all or someone on politics or someone
that's like engaged that's on the left a
Democrat or just someone that's totally
just you're at like out of maybe
completely maybe you're not you're not
your average person but the lower bell
curve people I suppose and again I'm not
saying this to be insulting derogatory
or or to diminish human beings uh oh is
that Governor just got called for Tim
Waltz in Minnesota
uh I'm saying that like watch watch
fleka's videos or spend time
uh and you will you will find people
that behave as if they're NPCs in a
video game yeah there's no there's no
amount of words you can say to get them
to to behave differently and the cool
part of this conversation is that it
brings up is that
to what extent
um do certain political factions
actually try to encourage that mindset
in order to get elected right and this
is um
you've got to start asking yourself like
what is the state of consciousness of
the average person what is causing that
State of Consciousness and then what
kind of political interests does that
serve I wonder if that's a right way to
view it is that uh it's not just about
you know people can say intelligence are
you a smart person are you a stupid
person do you have book knowledge do you
have wisdom maybe there's also a
question of to what degree is someone
conscious yes like do you experience the
world to a high degree of sharpness
where you're thinking and calculating
I'll put another way did you know that
there's a large amount of people who
don't have an inner monologue have you
ever heard that yes they don't actually
communicate in their mind and think
about what they're doing it's the
craziest thing I've never I didn't know
that was a thing until I read the the
you know the stories about the
scientific studies talking about testing
people for for inner monologue
some people don't have it so this is
actually what I teach in seminars so I
bring people up to the front of the
class and I've got to wake them up this
is what I do yeah
15 hours a day yeah I've actually I have
some friends we talked about this
because a long time ago I was you know
my friends are all smoking pot or
whatever we're hanging out playing video
games and they would say they didn't
have one and I had a friend was like I
don't I don't I don't do that I'm like
you don't like think in like words and
visuals and experiences you don't
imagine and they're like
no there's a task they do for it where
they tell you to imagine an apple then
they show you cards and ask you which
one represents what you see
and there's varying levels of
consciousness that people have some
people when you say imagine an apple
they'll say I'm picturing a vivid 4K or
greater realistic image of an apple I
can see the the the the rot in it I can
spin it around in my head and rotate it
I can see it hanging from the tree I can
now see myself pulling from the tree
some people say I see a flat still image
of an apple in my mind that's it can you
spin it no can you think I just see the
Apple some people report seeing a black
silhouette of an apple some people
report uh just thinking the text word of
an apple and some people report
literally seeing or thinking nothing and
so this is a series of tests they've
done and that's I guess perhaps a
varying degree of consciousness
well I think also there's a lot of
political disenfranchisement I think
there's a lot of people sick of the
two-party duopoly and a lot of people
don't know this but the majority of
people don't vote even in the last
presidential election the biggest
election of our lifetime or the biggest
turnout more than half of Americans
didn't vote in that election 154 million
people voted in the last presidential
election there's what is it was there
333 million people inside of the United
States so a lot of people are either
apathetic don't care or just know that
the political system is rigged against
them as they have these two parties that
that clearly have been screwing them
over one year after another year so I
think that's another element here that
we have to understand and I do think
what I've been saying earlier
specifically with Facebook investing
hundreds of millions of dollars into a
voter outreach program I think that
worked very significantly because when
you when you have the average Joe who
doesn't care about politics and is
watching you know the office or whatever
you have someone knocking at their door
being like you don't have to provide ID
you don't have to do anything he could
vote right here right now right right
where it says blue right here just vote
right here and I'll do everything for
you and when you have ballot Harvesters
when you have mail-in ballots when you
have this Facebook hundred million
dollar effort by Mark Zuckerberg you're
going to have a a bigger turnout than
you naturally would we did still the
majority of people said I'm not voting
so that's something to really consider
here we're good it's uh so we're past
midnight and I I am going to get up and
start uh recording again and I'm already
losing my voice so I think we'll wrap it
there my friends if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
at timcast.com if you want to support
the work that we do and so much more we
will have more tomorrow we have a big
guest coming tomorrow and hopefully two
big guys but probably just one big S
unfortunately and then we'll we'll
mention it on the show someone it's a
guest who works for another guest who
would be really great to have but we'll
probably just get the one person no I
don't know who it is oh you'll find out
you'll find out so um you can follow the
show at timcast IRA you can follow me at
timcast if you really want to help us
out you can buy our new song genocide by
timcast we can bite on iTunes or Amazon
go to losingmymind.com really do
appreciate it uh Drew you want to send
anything out yes thank you guys for
having me it's always fun we'll see what
happens uh in the middle of the night
with these numbers uh you guys can
follow me on Twitter at Drew H live and
watch my show frontlines nightly on real
America's voice you can find all those
links in my bio Twitter get her truth
all that good stuff
um if if you'd like to see some examples
of transformations of people that are
unconscious to becoming very conscious
uh go to my YouTube channel owencook
self-help I actually have two YouTube
channels owencook self-help which we
shoot videos all over the country we
just shot one from Montana Ed Jackson
Hole but the other one is the OWN cook
free tour I actually do free seminars
all over the world there's hundreds of
people there we do them completely for
free and we post them and actually bring
people up to the front of the crowd and
actually show that kind of
unconsciousness that we're talking about
and then show the kind of
Transformations that we could do we do
it on the spots super eye opening um you
can also follow me on RSD Tyler RSD
Tyler my name is Owen Cook you can also
look that up on Instagram hit me a DM on
Instagram I'll hit you back I was really
really excited to see the people who
jumped onto Instagram yesterday we had
some great conversations over uh DM and
on YouTube uh really excited to see
people that came over to the channel
excited to chat with you more and
respond to the comments
oh no it's me um okay so um Lisa
Elizabeth on Twitter make sure you
subscribe to the lives of tic tacs Tick
Tock sub stack oh my gosh I can't talk
I'm very tired
um and that's about it for me I'm tired
too thank you guys so much for coming
this was fun uh this was a great
conversation my website is
lukeansensored.com I did an interesting
video on the Rothschilds uh that you
guys could watch right now on
lucasensor.com see you there
and I'm search.com there's a lot of
people out there saying that they're me
they're not it's at search.com we're
everywhere you find me like whatever you
want to find out any social media Etc
thanks guys we'll see you all tomorrow
I'm tired thanks for hanging out big yes
tomorrow yeah thanks for having me
thanks